of spots that have not been seen by u.s
cameras since the war ended
with vietnam
good afternoon thanks for being with us
this is again day four of vietnam
revisited and we have been all this week
for six hours each day showing you some
video of a program that we taped and
aired earlier this year c-span traveled
to vietnam with the senate pow mia
affairs committee took our cameras along
and shot a lot of footage which we
packaged into a series called vietnam
revisited it ran for the first time over
memorial weekend many people expressed
an interest in seeing it again so we've
been bringing it back again this week
along with a number of
open phones and call-ins with new guests
to allow you to participate those of you
who watched before and had some
questions those of you watching it with
us for the first time again we'll be
here for about six hours today
and we've got lots ahead our focus today
is going to be on economics and the
future relationship between the united
states and vietnam so many of you with
questions about pow issues lots of time
this week we've already addressed to
that and we can take some calls during
open phone segment but mostly today
we'll be looking at the economy and the
current trade embargo that the u.s has
with vietnam and where that should stand
in the future so that's a word to those
of you preparing to watch today and
those of you who wish to phone in we
also have a great deal of video to show
you and we're going to just do that over
our segments here so you can see some of
the scenes that we saw while we were
there with our camera first up we've got
some video of saigon
wow
oh
baby
oh
[Music]
[Music]
that's one of many street scenes and
village scenes of vietnam you'll see as
our day continues here today what we
tried to do with our cameras in addition
to
some official events is just capture
some of the sights and sounds of vietnam
up next we're going to let you listen in
to some viewer response to our program
when we aired it over the memorial day
weekend
in a few minutes we'll be back with our
telephone lines open here live today for
your comments if you've been watching
our program after the over the past
couple of days we welcome your
participation this morning for this uh
next segment coming up in a few minutes
we'll open our lines with no guests just
a chance to hear you
and during that time we'll put our
c-span phone numbers up on the screen so
you can dial in with your comments but
next we'll listen into some of the
reactions we had when we aired this
series in memorial day weekend
i'm a vietnam veteran uh 68 and 69.
i'm in favor of normalization
but i believe that the mia pow issue
should be resolved
as a precondition
for negotiations for normalization
i believe that the conditions for
normalization should involve
democratization
overall i think the programming is
extremely well done especially brian
land's input however i just don't think
you people are quite getting the message
or getting it out to the american public
you just don't get the message the
message is
that you just don't send people out to
spend their blood every 20 years
only to ask the american public to go
back into business with the same people
i've absolutely loved your program on
the vietnam and i think that before we
renew relationships or normalize
relationships or lift the embargo we
really have to ascertain without a doubt
whether or not that we have any men
still over there or whether or not there
are
missing in action that are dead haven't
been returned to us otherwise if we go
to help them economically we would look
like complete fools just five years down
the road we find after where men still
hit and still alive i guess we're going
to bail out vietnam now along with
russia no wonder we're going down the
toilet
yes i'm a vietnam veteran i served in
the infantry during 1969
and i think the program is great i
really
i'm very happy about the fact that
they're
moving forward toward some
reconciliation and i think it's a very
interesting
and informative program and i'd like to
see more of it
uh but i think the reconciliation part
is really a very good thing something we
should be doing i think c spans doing a
wonderful job but i think c-span also
needs to talk to the families what the
families are saying is true
and the government's not giving us
information
c-span needs to broadcast that side of
it
and
so we can get to the bottom of this it's
not that the americans are unforgiving
or we're not generous we'd like to lift
the trade embargo but we need our
answers first
i think the program is excellent i
fought vietnam in
66-67 second battalion nice marines from
uh
got in
to caisson
um i think in the future
once we resume diplomatic relations with
vietnam they will probably become one of
our best allies in this whole world
those are some of the comments that we
heard in may when we aired vietnam
revisited right now we'd like to hear
your comments if you've been watching
this week our phone lines are open again
for your comments no chance to answer
questions here so much as to hear from
you if you live in the eastern or
central time zones our number here is
202-628-2525
if you're watching us in the mountain or
pacific time zones it's 202-783-2720
and if you are watching this program
outside the united states and would like
to participate we do have an
international line it's 202-737-6734
first viewer comment comes from
birmingham alabama
yes ma'am i was in vietnam in 1970 71
and we was in the operation ranch hand
but when when i was there i kind of was
exposed to agent orange i'm on 100
disability now from social security but
i'm having a hard time with va they
don't want to recognize the people that
was there
and
they just you know they don't want to
give
any help at all
and
we had to sign a statement when we was
there that we would never reveal any of
the things we went through on the ranch
end i was in the asa which is
military intelligence and
we was in cambodia and we was all along
the cambodian border
but the va hospitals now just they won't
give us any help at all why would that
be sir uh i'm not sure they just they
just say they always have inconclusive
evidence now i've applied through the
agent orange pavement program and
they've approved it
but the va will not approve it but the
agent orange payment plan did
and it just they just won't give us any
medical help at all
i'm on social security and i draw a
thousand dollars a month but 458 of that
has to go to my blue cross blue shield
to cover my medical expenses and the va
just won't do anything about it and and
i just don't know what
if we just got dumped on really all the
vietnam veterans did about asian orange
do you belong to any of the veterans
associations vfw and are they helpful
for you in this issue no ma'am they're
not why not do you think well they're
just not equipped to do it and uh
not that i know of the only help i have
got is through the agent orange program
you know the payment program on that was
just a you know class action lawsuit all
right thank you sir appreciate your
participation and your comments this
afternoon
uh watosa wisconsin is next
yeah i am a vietnam war veteran uh 1968.
uh where'd you serve sir pardon me where
did you serve i served a little bit uh
north of chula and south of danang with
196 infantry brigade
i was in the armored cavalry i uh i just
want to make a comment that i
i
i would think that it would be just uh
absolutely ridiculous to uh think that
the uh the vietnamese have any more
american pows and cat in captivity
it certainly doesn't serve them to do
that uh if if there are pow there are
certainly mias there because these uh
soldiers have been missing in action uh
in every single war and they could have
been buried anywhere they could uh you
know they probably just haven't found
them but i don't believe that uh but i i
i do believe that they could possibly be
in places like cambodia and laos and red
china uh but it just doesn't serve the
vietnamese uh today we're going to be
talking quite a lot about what the
future relationship should be between
our two countries what are your thoughts
on that let's open up relations with
them right away um uh it's uh i don't it
doesn't uh
i certainly don't think that um
that it would hurt either country by
opening up relations as a matter of fact
i think it would help both thank you for
the call next comment is from danville
california you're on the air
oh hello
i just wanted to make a remark about
your show
i i certainly hope that you run it again
in about three months
i think everybody in this country
should see it
and tell us
what uh what are your thoughts on the
current state of relations between u.s
and vietnam
i don't think that there should be any
trade relations whatsoever until we find
out what happened
to the men that are missing
whether it's bones
or live bodies
it's the same way with world war ii
i am 74 years old
and
it's unbelievable
we all know what caused the war in
vietnam and why it was done
and anybody that doesn't study the
history and listen
to the
what's going on the government in this
country won't believe it
it is absolutely unbelievable
caller from danville thanks very much
for participating this afternoon sharon
pennsylvania is next with your comment
um hi uh this has been a pretty pretty
good show i thought part of it when you
first aired it and
i seen it you know today and stuff and
what i went and
had was a comment and a question uh the
comment is
i believe mr pitak was talking on
p.o.w.m.i.a
yesterday or day before
and he'd put a number on that the
question was i don't have a number i'd
like you to be able to at least say it
again but the other item is that
not too long ago our organization
received some information from
a vietnamese national from washington
d.c who had been in vietnam now i have
no reason no understanding of why they
went and gave us the information
but it was on american names serial
numbers you know information like that
it was on paper and this was smuggled
out of vietnam
um
at the time it had only been about two
weeks old
now i don't know how this works first
off i i won't pull no bones i don't
trust senator kerry because he is
pro-business man he's trying to get them
in there there's big bucks
high
literacy rate
willing to work for low money
lots of natural resources that's the
basics that businessmen need
but the thing is i go to offer this
information i i've given it to uh
various people one of them was senator
smith's office
he's also on the senate subcommittee i
gave it to a man who is i could go
between his name is dino carluccio i
have faxed this material to her office
i've given this to various other people
i've received no reply as to what the
status is or anything so when a man sets
her on television says if you have any
information please give it to us i'm
beginning to doubt if they really want
this information they come on there and
they give us lip service as usual
and we're trying to help too even if
it's a bad lead for god's sakes anything
that comes out now these are from
vietnamese who had resettled in this
country
and that had relatives that came over
from vietnam
and i just don't understand it i we're
we're going out of our way supposedly to
get this
situation taken care of but yet when
people offer the information and they
ask well what is the status or anything
like that nobody wants to talk to you
i've received no reply from their office
or anything all right sir let me jump in
because you've made your point about not
getting reply let me give you alan
peatock's telephone number and for
others who may be interested in it as
well alan pitock is uh with the pow mia
affairs office at the pentagon and his
telephone number which he gave out when
he was a guest on our program here was
is 703 area code
703-284-1297 let me give that one more
time 703-284-1297
and that's the telephone number for the
pow mia affairs office at the pentagon
we're taking your telephone calls from
around the country to get your thoughts
or reactions on uh this whole us
vietnamese relationship issue and also
the pow mia
and veterans issues that we've been
talking about over the past couple days
here during our vietnam revisited series
next call comes from rocky mountain
north carolina
how you doing uh
i just wanted to comment that we need to
make sure we get those pows out i'm
currently army reserve soldier this time
i serve with fourth attack and 17th
street and i think it's our duty to get
those men out there if they're there i
think president bush is the first
president to really put forth an effort
to do that
i know we're not supposed to ask
questions but i was wondering how do you
go about
seeing how to get on a team to go over
to vietnam for that purpose
well i don't know the answer to that but
in a few minutes we're going to have a
guest jim webb who's been to vietnam
himself and we'll pose that question to
him
thanks for the call next is seattle
you're on the air
thank you
go ahead sir hello i was in vietnam for
a year and a half in 67 and 68
and i found the people there to be
extremely
likable and
friendly
and i think that
it's unfair to continue this embargo
we're hurting the people we might not
like the government that the people are
the ones that are suffering and and
like previous callers said
they'd be
uh
loyal allies i i think the people would
if we
normalize relations we've
we're buddies with all the other bad
guys in the world so
it's time that we gave vietnam a chance
and i think that the people that
continue this
mia pow
question
are
the extremists i don't believe that's a
mainstream view in the country i think
that there's a few people that want to
continue hating
or holding a grudge or
whatever on any subject
no matter what it is there's always a
few people with extreme ideas and i
think that
the mi pow thing
has gone on long enough thanks for that
call next is rochester new york you're
on the air hello i just want to have a
comment
a vietnam war not only involved with the
u.s
vietnam soviet union and china but today
u.s had a good relation with china and
russia
why not we have a good relation with
vietnam i think this is about time the
u.s should leave embargo against vietnam
because that not only have the vietnam
but will
bring the vietnam into the international
community
what i saw in your program now the
vietnam government so far
they did a very good progress
towards
the um
relationship
with the international community
so i think this is about time for us to
live embargo against them
and about the live build up you probably
that when we leave the embargo this is a
good chance we will find out the truth
about the bo
uh
you know if they are arrived in vietnam
or they behave in vietnam
all right sir thank you thank you very
much new york city is next your comment
yes uh i'm calling from new york city uh
my father is a vietnam veteran he died
there in
the early 60s
i think that if we had let communism go
the course as it has gone in russia
we would have had a tragedy that we um
had there
i feel that the veterans in the united
states are getting a bomb deal
you know from our government and uh
my family has suffered greatly because
of the vietnam conflict we had
and um
that's basically it thank you thanks for
the call next is longview washington
hello you're on the air
yes i'm a 100 disabled veteran and
i'm from the san diego area
visiting temporarily in washington i had
to call in and comment about reed irvine
yesterday
as far as asian orange goes yes sir
and
i believe he's working for
bowel chemical or some of the other
agencies because my wife is a chemist
and
if she works around oxygen she has to
put a mask on she has to get under a
hood that sucks
the dioxin out
and
she has to wear gloves
and all that yep reed irvine says that
the oxygen is not harmful to anybody if
that's true i'd like to know why
that uh chemists around the country have
to take such precautions to make sure
they don't come in contact
with the dioxin that was in asian orange
all right sir i'm assuming you said
you're a disabled veteran vietnam era
veteran
yes ma'am 100
and where did you serve in vietnam i
served in three corps
with
the first air cavs and 11th armored cavs
and i went into cambodia with them and
what years was this 70 and 71.
and i have plenty of pet eye
which was mentioned yesterday as a skin
rash and ailment
plus i had a stress induced heart attack
at the age of 38 which the va
refused to recognize
and i don't drink i don't do drugs
i don't do any of the things that
the va is totally against and
i got my claim through the help from
senator kerry's office back in
washington dc i got upset so bad i went
back there
and
you have to fight with the va and i've
been threatened by the
head of the
va regional office in san diego he
called me up one morning said i
had embarrassed him
nationally
and
he would do his level best to get me
and unfortunately some other vietnam
veteran flipped out went up to his
office and put a lot of computers out
and stuff and got in trouble and i think
he's in jail now
and they immediately transferred him out
but
he was on there and supposed to be
accuracy and media
and he was totally inaccurate you know
all right uh
why don't i interrupt you at this point
sir because you did make your point
about uh mr irvine that was a program we
did yesterday i got a lot of calls here
so i'll thank you for participating this
afternoon and uh we'll move on to our
next comment sewell new jersey uh yes
ma'am i was in vietnam 65 66. i went
back there again in 90.
um
if you notice on the tv the
there are very little traffic a lot of
people been taken out of out of saigon
there's two divisions of communist north
vietnamese troops stationed at saigon
to stop any uprisings
i'm in favor
of
normalizing relations only because i
think that we get american dollars in
their american expertise that it will
change the
um
the form of government vietnamese are
very nice
people how did you happen to go back in
1990 i went back on my own do you have
any difficulty getting in no not at all
how did you travel there i went to
bangkok got a visa out of
out of bangkok flew in
here vietnam air vietnam is not a very
nice airline
uh i wouldn't recommend anybody that
wants to go back to go buy air vietnam
uh air france flies in and says
just a tourist visa that you and were
you able to travel anywhere you wanted
to yes and did you have anybody
caring about your whereabouts no
they had uh you know they you're on a
tour so i mean if
you don't
they wanted they went down to uh mito or
you could have gone up to vong tao on
this tour but i went to neither one i
stayed in saigon right and would you
recommend it for others sure uh they
treated me fine i mean you know i went
to the presidential palace thinking i
was going to get a you know a big uh
propaganda dissertation and basically
all they said was
you know before
1975 and after 1975 i mean they didn't
really
talk and disrespect about the previous
administrations in south vietnam the
only thing that i found
in talking with the people and i i speak
fairly decent vietnamese is that
they um
you know they got doctors driving cyclos
that kind of situation where you know
people that were
fairly well off in south vietnam
uh
before it fell are now
uh
having to resolve to manual labor and
and uh menial jobs because uh viet cong
are put in positions of authority thanks
for participating appreciate your
comments that was sewell new jersey go
to texas for our next call wichita falls
is on the air
yes uh i was in vietnam 66 67
served on a wine if you ran from donghae
to da nang way
and the people that are very friendly i
i like them real well
and i sure would like to see normalized
relations with that country again
regarding
mias and pows
i imagine by now most of them guys if
they were there or they're dead
it's it's
it's just a shame the way our government
has treated this country since the fall
uh
it's about all i got to say about the
whole mess
thank you caller seattle washington is
next to your comment please
uh yes ma'am um i just like to say that
i enjoy your show thank you
um my dad was he served during in
vietnam during 67-68
i myself served in the during the
persian gulf war
um as far as political politics is
concerned i'm not
very politically inclined as you might
say but uh i do realize that if we
lifted in trade embargo not only would
it and i know you've heard this million
times not only would it make us look
like fools if there were actual um
mispaws alive or dead whether or not we
we haven't returned them um
or they haven't returned to us
it would it would really fall to the
hopes of those over there that are still
alive and their
uh their last glisten of hope in the
country that sent them over there to at
least get them back
um
as far as
as being over there i myself have never
been over there i've been keeping up on
vietnam issues and affairs
since i was a child since since uh
i learned a lot about it for my dad
and uh i would like to go over there and
from here from everybody else vietnam
vets included it seems like a really
nice place and the people look just
absolutely friendly
i think the movie industry did a really
good job on screwing that up for the
public that's not aware
or has not
experienced vietnam or being there
as far as making them look like the bad
guys and making them look like you know
they would do anything and everything to
to stab any countries back whether it be
the us or anybody else so that really
kind of misleads people misguided people
as far as wondering if there are actual
pows or hermione's over there all right
terry thanks very much that was seattle
washington the call next from manchester
new hampshire you're on the air
oh hi i'm a marine veteran i was there
on 6566 force recon
uh i core area and some layouts
my comment is
i believe we shouldn't normalize
relations
until there's accountability my opinion
is is more dead than alive as far as the
number of missing and
supposed prisoners
but
as far as normalization
the uh
corruption of that government
is such that i think we'll be wasting
yankee dollars
and i believe that
we should talk to china before we talk
to them anytime soon
if their hawaii government is so great
that they uh
force their will on our people in the
south
then they should they should take care
of them
all right thanks for the call that was
manchester new hampshire new york city
last call for our open phone segment for
right now you're on the air
uh i'm an ex-service man
uh
during world war ii i missed it but i
got in during the korean war
and it's an awful thing that
we have was and everything but my
prime
thought is
when we feed everybody
in this country
and have no homeless people walking
around
everybody's belly is full
then we should worry about
other countries like vietnam biafra in
those places
i'm from old school maybe i
saying the wrong thing
but i think america first
and everybody else second charity begins
at home
and the way
the politicians are running this country
charity is not at home
charity is in foreign countries and
that's the way i feel all right sir
thanks new york city
we will have more opportunities as our
program progresses today for you to
participate i participate either by
asking questions of guests here around
our table or
through open phone segments and again we
will be here until six pm eastern time
with our fourth day of vietnam revisited
next we're going to uh show you an
interview we taped with a gentleman by
the name of james clovis clad mr clad is
senior associate of asian politics and
economics at the carnegie endowment for
international peace here in washington
dc and he's also a professorial lecturer
in asian studies at the school of
advanced international studies at johns
hopkins university he's going to be
talking about his view on the politics
of southeast asia
professor james clad senior associate of
the carnegie endowment for international
peace and an expert on southeast asia
when you think of that part of the world
what comes to mind
what comes to mind is an awful lot of
variety what comes to mind an awful lot
of people we forget that the
six countries in the association of
southeast asians alone have more than
300 million people if you bring in the
indo-chinese countries you're talking
about 380 million people it's a big area
and
a lot of variety inside it how much time
have you spent over there i've been out
there one way or another about 12 13
years mostly as a correspondent
and when you think of 380 million people
and its relationship to the united
states what's the future hold for that
well i think it's probably the biggest
understudied area in the united states
today i mean people get very worked up
for example about vietnam for
understandable reasons to go back to our
history and so on people get worked up
about other areas of say southwest asia
but if you look at economic potential i
think we just miss most of the
developments that are going on there in
malaysia indonesia thailand we worry a
lot about
politics in bangkok and whether or not
the generals are behaving you know
democratically i think what we miss
though are these tremendously buoyant
economies that we should be
participating more in when you hear the
four tigers what are they talking about
what they're talking about is an awful
lot of nomenclature you get a little bit
lost and and all of some people call it
acronym for mania you know it tends to
be you know apec and asean and the
tigers and the knicks and all these
names but i think what we're talking
about with the tigers are singapore
taiwan south korea
and hong kong and i think you find that
those areas tend to be ones in which
people are
expecting an awful lot of future
economic potential from they're
expecting a lot of
improved
expert sorry export performance i think
what we're also looking at are economies
which caught the
baggage train if you like toward
exporting to american european markets
these are places which really
came online in the 70s and
really have been following behind the
japanese and koreans and an awful lot of
their performance
we've got a lot of video tape we used
during our discussion and let's roll
some tape from singapore
as we look at this uh tell us what
what you think of when you third have
you been there yeah oh sure
well what we're looking at there is a
a skyway that goes out to a small island
off singapore itself they have an
amusement park over there i understand
that there's going to be a u.s naval
base in that area that's right but we
shouldn't assume it's going to be the
kind of base which we saw in the
philippines in subic bay which is a huge
area with a tremendously large staff
what the singaporeans used to have
remember was a big
british naval base as well
and uh we're looking at a country which
um
has terrifically high degree of
urbanization it's a city-state really
it's a small island
but we're talking about a place that has
a per capita income that's edging up
close to ours why why because they were
always well placed as traders they're
people who uh
are mostly ethnic chinese and they're
legendary for being entrepreneurial
dynamic
also because they've been very well
governed for the last 25 30 years people
complain sometimes about the
authoritarian nature of
the government run by the people's
action party in singapore but at the
same time they provide an honest and
consistently effective administration
lee kuan yew
lee kuan yew lee kuan yew was prime
minister uh really from the very
beginning of the independence of
singapore right up until
about a year and a half ago he's now
called the sm in shorthand the senior
minister and he
continues to have a very strong hand
behind the scenes
when you read things like a 11 ticket
for jaywalking and you're not allowed to
eat food in the subways you're not
allowed to eat food there's always in
washington but uh you get some sense
that they are very controlled are they
and if so why i think the people put up
an awful lot with a government which is
um
obsessively meddlesome in little ways
there are also rules which
are designed to prevent people from
urinating in elevators for example and
some of the elevators are even
equipped with equipment which will
detect you know whatever happens when
somebody does something like that
there's also fines for chewing gum and
spitting it out in the public street
it's obsessive in that way but i think
again the predominantly chinese
population of singapore
finds these merely irritating and not as
examples of say an authoritarian state
run amok i think they're prepared to put
up with those things for the bigger
picture which is good governance
got some more videotape of singapore
have you been there often yeah
and why so many actually this
i think this is videotape of thailand uh
what is the relationship between this is
on the river in thailand what's the
relationship between singapore and
thailand and there's a great deal of
difference in the size of the countries
well a huge difference in size and
populations you've got um
you've got
2.3 million people in singapore a small
city-state it's really kind of buildings
and roads from shore to shore in
thailand of course you have this
tremendously interesting picture of the
bangkok greater bangkok area getting
foreign investment by the hundreds of
millions of dollars every year and
you've also got areas like the northeast
the high northwest which adjoins burma
which are really desperately poor
if you look over here on this map that
we've got you go down to where singapore
is
again the size of this
area this this this country yeah is how
big it's tiny it would be something less
than the size of uh i think the city of
new york now if you go right up the
peninsula here you go into malaysia
what's that country like that country's
very interesting place in fact malaysia
comprises that little wedge that you're
pointing at there west malaysia or it's
known as peninsula malaysia and then
some two states over on borneo on the
cross the south china sea sarawak and
sabah there that's right move the
pointer that way and then right up at
the very top there next to the paper
itself on the other side of brunei asaba
but west malaysia is a
federation of about nine states
it's a rich and rubber it's rich in
foreign investment
electronics industry especially
and it's a place that's comparatively
underpopulated there's only about 15
million people in malaysia all together
now we go back over here on the map to
malaysia and if you kept going by the
way can you drive all the way up to
thailand yes you can it gets a little
bit hairy the road itself and also it
gets a little bit shaky there are some
areas that
you can't be too sure of driving at
night time but you can go up by railroad
very easily very comfortably go all the
way up to bangkok in fact can go right
up to chiang mai at the very top there
of thailand that's right you just
pointed to it there and it's a
the both the railways in uh in malaysia
and in
in thailand and singapore are all very
good it's an excellent trip hope you can
do it sometime is there any way to
describe the differences in the people
that live in singapore and malaysia and
thailand yes there is the thais
obviously most importantly were never
colonized it's a country of 65 million
people
most of whom are ethnic thai there isn't
that kind of
ethnic smorgasbord that you find in
malaysia or also in singapore
in thailand of course they're buddhist
they have incorporated
the chinese there
very very well and i think what you'd
find is that the thais
most of all have managed to remain very
very
confident of their ability to remain
independent and they have been the
fastest growing southeast asian economy
in the last five years on the screening
video tape from thailand
what's the
standard of living there well varies
tremendously uh in the northeast of the
country
you have people who are desperately poor
dirt farmers in bangkok which has grown
explosively so much so that people
describe the bangkok streets as 24-hour
parking lots because of the traffic
there this by the way was taken on
holidays yes i can see i was astounded i
actually see cars moving i wondered
whether this was footage 10 years ago
but i guess not
this this footage was taken by the way
during our trip over to southeast asia
back in april and the reason i mentioned
that is because after this is when you
had the
uprising over there against the military
coup yeah and the military government
that was another thought that went
through my mind this might have been a
day or two after the coup and you know
businesses were slow to start up
standard of living increasingly very
high one of the main factors behind that
big disturbance in may of course was
that the
people in thailand especially in bangkok
are increasingly middle class
and
i think are increasingly chafing at a
government which is run mostly at the
behest of the military
why is the military so influential there
it's been influential ever since the
1930s it's regarded itself as
part of the inner circle of government
which includes the elite bureaucracy and
the monarchy and they're very very
reluctant to give up those privileges
there's a sign there that's kind of hard
to read because it's a little bit fast
but it talks about
tourists being aware of people on the
streets who are
not uh you know after they're after
their pocketbooks uh
what's the relationship of the thai
individuals there to the american
tourists for instance when they go there
oh i think
the thais are very commercially minded
people and there is a great sense of i
think shame when for example tourists
might be attacked by muggers or
something like that i don't think people
need have any worry about
street crime particularly in bangkok um
elsewhere can be a little bit more dicey
up in chiang mai and all the rest of it
but it's a country which takes tourism
very seriously because after all after
uh x i think in after exports of some
electronic
things and also some agricultural
exports to europe tourism is the biggest
foreign exchange earner
what impact did the vietnam war have on
thailand and on our relationship with
thailand had a tremendous impact
it um altered thai society in ways that
i think the thais are still trying to
struggle with today
it's uh it had an effect of for example
increasing
the bar and you know rest and recreation
industry as it's euphemistically
described
it also
i think opened up the thai
infrastructure to a lot more imports
but since then i think the point that we
should never forget is the thais are
very much in control of their own
destiny we may look around and see all
the signs of japanese electronics
industry banks that look familiar and we
think wait a minute this is just another
fast industrial country that looks an
awful lot like us but the thai political
culture is very unique and they have a
strong sense of identity it says bangkok
on the screen it's actually about an
hour and a half outside of bangkok and
it's the canals and it shows where the
you know the floating market is and and
a lot of tourists go out to that area
uh we don't have scenes of this but um
the uh pet pong area of thailand i mean
bangkok uh which you know the the
prostitutes and the uh evening
entertainment and all that stuff was
that a result of the vietnam war yes its
growth as a result of the vietnam war
but thai
social mores the habits
of young thai men encourage
in many cases
sexual initiation by going to
prostitutes into brothels so it would be
a mistake to say that somehow the west
and particularly the united states
bequeathed pat pong and it's an enormous
sex industry as you know it involves
people flying in from
sweden and germany and japan
and of course one cannot these days talk
about this in the same breath without
mentioning the aids epidemic in thailand
you
when you're there you hear all kinds of
stories about the prostitution and
the the philosophy of the families and
the young men in thailand and
all that it is
what is the the
the uh
folklore of that and why is it so
different there than it is other places
or is it
firstly i don't think it is so different
and it is elsewhere there's a
significant brothel industry right down
on the thai border right to joining
malaysia and thailand hyundai it's
called in this area
right down there and uh enormous numbers
of malaysian men will go across for
sexual tourism reasons
um i think that it uh speaks of an
attitude in the culture which doesn't
see this to be something sort of
tremendously reprehensible i think it's
ingrained in buddhist society buddhist
culture and they tend to see it very
commercially in very pragmatic sense
what are the countries we've just talked
about singapore malaysia and thailand
export
okay
the thing to understand is these
countries as well as indonesia as well
as even the philippines were places
which got their start in the
international trading economy by
commodities long long time ago spices
after that
plantation coffee plantation sugar that
kind of thing but this century and more
specifically since the end of the second
world war we've had waves of foreign
investment which go in there and
basically have done the following things
have reinforced the development of
mineral resources oil tin metals that
kind of thing and then beginning in the
1980s getting into consumer electronics
for two reasons one to exploit the local
markets in southeast asia which are
increasingly richer i mean you go to
jakarta bangkok kuala lumpur singapore
you're talking about major
urban middle class markets with very
sophisticated lifestyle choices and
preferences and then after 1985
especially when the yen suddenly
appreciated enormously visibly the
dollar and it became just too expensive
to manufacture in japan and increasingly
in taiwan and korea you've had this huge
wave of investment coming into southeast
asia mainly aimed at production of
manufacturers for third country markets
japan and this country out of all of
those things a good resource spread
a country that's familiar with business
for hundreds of years and now this wash
of foreign investment those are really
the pillars of the present prosperity we
watched the king play a major role in
that
i don't know how you would describe it
it wasn't you know when the military
was in power recently over in thailand
yeah what role does the king play in
that country and how long he was born in
boston
that's right that's what i'm here too i
think i keep wanting to ask somebody if
that's really true but i think he i
think it is because i think he went i
think his parents were there going to
school that's right i wonder if that
entitles him to american citizenship he
probably would if he'd stayed here
that's right but i don't think he's the
one person thailand probably isn't going
to ever have to leave for political
reasons
what role does it does the monarchy play
there a very crucial one uh the monarch
in thailand this king is very
widely respected you'll read it in
journalism and you sometimes think oh
they're just putting it in as a mantra
you know the widely respected
universally loved king but it actually
is true
and he plays a key role in being the
arbiter of conflicts between certain
factions of the military i think one of
the things that we tend to overrate and
those disturbances back in may you know
it was kind of portrayed as a as a
urban middle class yearning for
democracy and a bunch of ruthless
dictatorial soldiers suppressing street
demonstrations well of course that
happened but the motivation behind it
was a conflict between different
factions within the military it's called
class five and class seven
and uh suchenda belonged to one of these
factions and uh the mayor of uh bangkok
the other and so we had behind this
arena in which we thought we saw a
democracy playing out against
authoritarianism you had
different military factions maneuvering
for power the king is the only one who
can arbitrate in that sort of dispute
and you may remember those photographs
where he had both the
major contenders approaching on their
hands and knees very important
symbolically and
many people worry that when the king has
is inevitable at some stage passes from
the scene who is able to fill his
particular personal role and that's
going to be a tough one have you ever
lived
in that part of the world oh yes
where oh i lived in um
i was bureau chief for a magazine in
manila
in kuala lumpur i was in the foreign
service in jakarta many travels to
indochina so i'd say all together about
10 years residing there from what you
know that area if you had to pick a
country that you would live in
permanently which one
well that really is a hard one because
you're asking me do i prefer my creature
comforts or do i like you know variety
and occasional scent of danger i think
if it's creature comfort singapore hands
down phones always work and you know you
can get from one place very easily
if you're talking about
a tremendously interesting country i'd
say i'd go back to indonesia how big is
indonesia indonesia is huge it's the
fourth largest country in the world
people forget that with the
disintegration of the soviet union uh
here down
got indonesia and particularly java that
island right down there at the bottom
that
it's below sumatra so it's the next
island right down here that's right
there are over 110 million people living
on that island
and it's after bangladesh the most
densely populated piece of ground in the
world
but it's all together 180 million people
fourth largest country in the world
biggest muslim country by far
a great mistake that we especially in
this country make is to assume that
muslims are arabs the arabs are in fact
a tiny part of the overall
number of muslims in the world and the
indonesians are 90 muslim they control
these strategic waterways they have a
lot of oil timber industry they're
tremendously interesting you're actually
from new zealand originally well i was
born in this country grew up in new
zealand and in fact when i was in
jakarta i was there for the
new zealand foreign service which
is a small show i can tell you that but
what were your parents doing well what
happened is my father died in um
when i was a
young teenager in california and we had
some very distant relations in new
zealand and my mother got it into her
head that we should grow up there
and so we left in 1964.
came back to this country permanently
when a year ago so it's been a long time
away passing through a lot
and keeping track of the us but coming
back here to live after 28 years i can
tell you is a very big adjustment what
was the biggest adjustment biggest
adjustment is thinking that i understand
what's going on either in politics or
sport or on television talking to you
and
sometimes discovering that in fact i
haven't got it wrong so much as i might
be missing some of the basic plays
one of the more interesting things that
i know in our trip that we saw and this
is a tiny little thing but i wanted you
to put it in perspective let's show this
video tape
in bangkok
is that is the vietnam
embassy yeah
and it was closed at this particular
time but
in order to get into vietnam you got to
go to that embassy unless you do it
through the u.n or canada or some place
but
the position if you keep looking
right across the street
from the vietnamese embassy is the big
rather
large both in
ground area and in size is the american
embassy that's right how important is
this american embassy there
i think that we
are going to be looking at major
restructuring
of u.s foreign service
needs over the next decade
so much of
our thinking about southeast asia has
been driven for so long by security
considerations
and i think what we're now looking at is
a situation where i mean just that
picture itself shows you that
the economic dynamism look at the
mercedes look at the late model cars
that the
key issue for us
the united states in southeast asia now
remains continuing to improve our
economic position in this tremendously
dynamic region of the world the
countries of asean grew faster
the last couple years in any other
region in the world eight nine percent a
year look at that truck there it says
tat duty free on the side of it and you
see english all over that's right how
does how does the english language and
the local language mix
well in thailand
most people in the middle class and
certainly people with any education will
be speaking english everywhere in
southeast asia if not the world today
english is the preferred second language
after one's own mother tongue and i
think it's a great advantage that we
have there isn't much of a willingness
to have people
learn japanese you'll have specific
businesses will send say you know
businessman's family will send a son for
half a year to japan to get to know the
right people but english is the language
of international commerce everywhere and
no more so than in southeast asia and of
course you have the malaysians and
singaporeans
and the filipinos experienced with it as
a language of the former colonialists
anyway check the numbers
close to 3 million people in singapore
that's right 15 million people in
malaysia that's it 65 million people in
thailand that's it
and then uh what was the philippines
about six philippines about 1665.
and then vietnam and that one that we're
we're going to go to vietnam next but uh
vietnam's about 65 or 70. yeah getting
close to 70 now why is it that a country
like thailand has a much higher standard
of living
both asian countries than say vietnam
both same size yeah well the answer is
right there like the nose on our faces
because vietnam fought
these incredibly intense wars because
vietnam was
obviously experimenting with a socialist
approach to economics which visibly
failed on the screen is uh hanoi have
you ever been there yep a long time ago
how long oh gosh i'm trying to remember
when it was it was years and years ago
but doesn't look like anything's changed
that is you know
the extent of the cars that you see
there
yeah you see the right there's that
vehicle there that's an usa it's a
russian-made jeep
i was just actually in central asia
about a month ago riding around on one
of those things they're good good
machine but um
as you can see it's about the only car
on the street we'll cease shortly a vast
difference between hanoi and saigon why
well saigon uh
firstly has a number of ethnic chinese
who continue to live there uh make it
their place of abode
secondly uh saigon is the place in which
a lot of money from what's known as the
vietcuda the overseas vietnamese who
primarily came to the united states they
send money back there they remit money
back
and simply because it had much longer
experience with let's say american style
western style prosperity i think we're
in saigon now we are yeah to show the
contrast yeah more cars i mean you don't
actually see them there i think both of
these were shot uh
i can't remember the exact time uh
possibly on the weekends or on sunday
where there's a great deal of difference
in yeah how many cars and bikes and all
you see a lot more color a lot more
fresh paint in saigon yeah why
again uh
and i have to emphasize i have never
been to saigon but uh many of my
colleagues in the foreign press corps in
southeast asia of course visited a great
deal and i think it's simply because the
material level of prosperity never
slipped in saigon after the end of the
war to the extent that it did um at the
extent that it was never achieved in
hanoi this is the famous tudo street i'd
call that anymore where they
american servicemen i'm sure will
remember that uh street some of them
were at least
infamous
where were you how old were you during
the war the vietnam war i was in new
zealand finishing my first degree
i was uh
far away from the war although new
zealand actually during the time sent an
um
an artillery battalion to the war but it
was regular soldiers who were actually
sort of rather itching to go
who'd been too long away from some war i
think the last one they'd been in was
korea so it never became something in
new zealand that was intense as it was
in the united states that said i marched
down with just about every other
university student to protest visits by
you know visiting american secretaries
of state it was just
the fashion of the time i mean i think
it was the correct thing to do the war
was not
sensibly thought out and i think
everyone would agree about that you work
for the carnegie endowment for
international peace here in washington
what is it it's a
major think tank in washington that's
considered one of i suppose the top four
or five in washington as far as the the
range of work that's done it's also
known as not having any particular
ideological position that it wants to
advance unlike say the heritage
foundation it's not seen as overtly
liberal or conservative and it what it
does is invites people in such as myself
to advance research in particular areas
such as asian economics
security issues what i do there is
as being the only resident let's say
foreign correspondent
i do work that plays upon my past
experience which was in
south central asia and central asia
itself recently and then in southeast
asia looking at security and especially
this question of economics i'm
just so mindful of how we need to begin
to really think about turning these
relationships which as i described were
ones that were based on
security thoughts and making sure that
our relationships with the filipinos are
with the ties and it remains strong
countering soviet naval ambitions uh
countering in an earlier stage of
chinese and vietnamese now that's
changed it's changed a lot let me ask
you if you had um
let's say that you were overtly liberal
and across the table you had an overtly
conservative person in foreign affairs
thinking about that part of the world
both here in america and
american uh american view on this what
would the differences be today
in the views
the difference between today and say 20
years ago
well you know 20 years ago you had the
war and all the difference but today
based on the way the world is today
looking at southeast asia would
conservatives and liberals differ
greatly well if they put at the top of
their agenda the economic interests of
this country and the absolute need for
us to be
very serious and grown up about
advancing those interests then i think
what we would be doing is having very
little disagreement because
i support efforts such as for example
president bush
earlier last year called up the
president of indonesia president suharto
and said
we're watching the way you're going to
award this telecommunications contract
and that up until that sort of effort it
looked like the japanese were going to
get it as it turned out both the
japanese ntt and att got parts of that
contract but i think that's what we
should be doing a very serious
narrow-eyed
approach to advancing our economic
interests which is still very
considerable we have
very big fixed foreign investment
interests in southeast asia too much in
my mind is located in the petroleum area
but if you look ahead to burma burma at
some stage is going to have to come out
of its shell it has oil potential
burma is about from memory about 50
million people but i could be wrong in
the figures there
but you know i've talked to um
british petroleum engineers who were um
in burma recently they came back
and they said the oil potential there is
just incredible right there and it's
called the irrawaddy delta you could say
rangoon's down at the bottom that's
right and then up that area there is a
tremendous basin people believe of oil
and gas
and it's going to be much cheaper to
exploit that than it is exploiting oil
for some of these offshore rigs in
indonesia and malaysia got some more
videotape from hanoi
street scenes and getting some sense of
what it looked like this is back in
april
one of the things you notice there is
lots of fruit
everywhere
available for people buying it on the
street
uh why is it
there's so much food in a place like
vietnam and there's so little food in a
place like russia any idea
well you've um
hit the bullseye with that question
because i just came back from central
asia where you have the same phenomenon
you've got the
markets overflowing with fruit i mean
the same picture here but magnified 100
times i mean just imagine the street
full of products and
also the same range of consumer goods as
we also see in this frame
doesn't have to be motorcycles
motorcycle seats i was hoping that's
what it might be otherwise i wasn't sure
what it was you'll see i mean i don't
know what we've got here but you'll see
a lot of things that are very consumer
oriented well
firstly the thing to remember is that an
informal parallel private market never
disappeared in vietnam no matter what
the government was talking about and
socialist sort of high ground you know
command economics but to answer your
question about why
do the russians have such trouble
getting food to market i think it's
simply because
the
tendency to have an informal market
never disappeared in places like for
example central asia i was in tashkent
for example
a place i'm trying to describe where the
markets look like this all around you
have something that looks like an old
dreary socialist city but you have this
as well in central asia you also have
people don't even know about this there
are 200 000 koreans who live in
uzbekistan they were moved there by
stalin at the end of the war they're
collective farmers now when we think of
collective farming we get depressed and
say well it sounds like some sort of
monstrous
tyranny but the koreans have taken to
collective farming very well and they
lease land from every other failed
collective farm they grow onions and
other horticultural goods
the basic reason is that you have always
had informal
private markets which were served by
horticultural growers as a way to
supplement income and as liberalization
has proceeded
the opportunities for those people have
grown accordingly
looking at scenes of a market in hanoi
back in april
you know it was really hot there and i
i remember asking about this question
what impact i mean like 100 degrees
every day uh lots of humidity but this
goes on forever and except in the rainy
season what uh
i mean actually in hanoi it gets cool in
the winter as you know and down south it
never does but
what impact does the heat have on their
way of living
well
there used to be a theory propounded by
people that one of the reasons that uh
the non-western world which meant
non-european world
remained in poverty was that it was just
too damn hot
and i think that the experience in
southeast asia shows that this is a
something that has to be thought out
again
growth rates of 10 or 11 percent a year
for the last 10 or 15 years in singapore
and in thailand
should convince us that heat alone is
hardly an inhibiting factor
but it does mean that social life is
you know avoids the the most intense
period of the day you tend to stay
inside women do not run around looking
for a suntan
and also the evenings can be tremendous
fun anyone who's lived any length of
time in southeast asia knows that one of
the most enjoyable parts of it is the
the sidewalk cafe side of life in
southeast asia where you have food
cooked right in front of you and you sit
out in the open
talking about economics this country has
an embargo or trade embargo with vietnam
from your perspective why is it still on
well
let's get back just a second ago to what
i said a second ago which is that i
as a young person younger person missed
the intensity of the vietnam war and
what passions it engendered and still in
genders in this country so it's an
important caveat because perhaps i come
to it
slightly more neutral in that sense i
don't come to it with any chip on my
shoulder any sense that we've got to
exact the last bit of blood from the
vietnamese stone
i think from
being familiar with
other countries commercial efforts in
southeast asia i mean i know that the
french that the japanese especially that
the koreans and all kinds of people are
there informally and are pre-positioning
themselves for a tremendous upsurge of
business when our embargo lifts now you
say well why are embargo aren't they
getting on and doing business some of
them already are the singaporeans for
example would give lip service to a
boycott of vietnam during the period
when the cambodian war was a major
dispute and yet they were selling
hundreds of millions of dollars in goods
there anyway
the other thing is that um
we would
i think you'd find that the embargo now
is inhibiting everybody's
ability to lend commercial money to
hanoi if you look on the screen there
this was shot to show
the number of american goods it still
gets through
in many cases you see stamped on a
coca-cola company singapore
uh
there are a lot of other goods there how
do american goods get through by and
large through an embargo like this well
simply indirectly
singapore is great source of wealth
among other things that is a re-export
center the trade statistics show x
number of goods going to singapore and
then singaporean import export firms
simply re-export them up to um
to saigon
and it proves the point what i said a
moment ago that here you have the
singaporeans
simply continuing their trade with
vietnam i think you'll see here i'm not
sure we still have it in there but
there's a general electric fluorescent
bulb there
i think there's even a tungsten uh
product from hungary yeah
the are
the people of asia that live in this
environment are they happy people from
what's your experience
i think so
i uh
i
have always loved working and living in
southeast asia it really is a formative
experience you know as a journalist as
an area of tremendous as i said variety
the people are
extraordinarily
pleasant charming there's a great deal
of civility which characterizes social
relations which are noticeably lacking
in other parts of the world
i hope that we can get back to a level
of normality and governmental relations
with with vietnam i personally feel that
the
that the embargo served a number of very
very good uses including
forcing the vietnamese to accept that
their adventure in cambodia wasn't going
to work but i think for exa for example
for us to wait
until let's say the communist system
collapses in vietnam before we then go
ahead and honor them with formal
diplomatic relations is probably a bit
conceived simply because
communism in vietnam for all its faults
was a
nationalist
a way of expressing nationalism and
against the colonial intruders unlike
europe where is your citizenship uh new
zealand still
but i've just been told my american
citizenship is now i'm back in place so
how does that work it works
because
when i naturalized as a new zealander
at the time the law said that there was
an automatic dispossession of american
citizenship but i understand that the
supreme court in 1979 said that you have
to make an act of renunciation and i
never did that in fact i fought for the
american citizenship and so
i'll now have to make sure which one i
pull out of the pocket so you can keep
them both well i think i can keep them
both for the purposes of the new zealand
government and i must say as a
journalist when i would do assignments
say in the middle east i went to iran
and iraq during the war i was always
glad to have the new zealand passport
because you always felt that the chances
of somebody standing up in the back of
the plane with a kalashnikov saying okay
everybody with a new zealand passport
stand up
were very remote
how many people live in new zealand
three million
back to the embargo in vietnam let me
show you some tape of a
french vietnamese
joint venture
this is the old metropol hotel turned
into the new metropol hotel which is
right in the center of hanoi
it's only been open since march i think
it's forty percent owned by the french
and sixty percent owned by the
vietnamese
but here again uh it are the french
that basically are ignoring the american
embargo uh what does that do to the
relationship between the americans and
the french or do we care i don't think
we care
i mean really at this point it's a
question of timing a formal
opening of diplomatic relations with
vietnam and i think that timing is
simply held up by our election
i mean
i think most people expect that we will
have an embassy in hanoi next year
how do these joint ventures work from an
economic standpoint uh you know the
french the pullman company went in there
and i don't know spent millions of
dollars refurbishing this place
do they
would would you say that is a good
investment
yeah although it looks a little bit
empty in these pictures well actually it
was full the
during this time the malaysian there are
200 member malaysian delegation
economic delegation including the prime
minister
this happened you know again a lot of
these shots were not taken in the middle
of the day probably early in the morning
or in the evening
i think that these are smart investments
i think that the next area of dynamism
in southeast asia is going to be
saigon i think without
a doubt if you want to look ahead to we
talked about success stories a bit
earlier on if you want to look ahead at
areas of dynamism if you could
pull your pointer out again if you look
at saigon
there's no question but the the
the
infrastructure is going to be there the
talent of local people is going to be
there i think burma again for oil
reasons one that opens up and i also
believe that the philippines has been
regarded as a
you know a lag art in all of this but
with the new government there's probably
a good chance that we're going to be
having
some improved economic performance there
we still have some video tape left i
think of uh of the pullman hotel i'm
sure no don't have it anymore i thought
it might have shown the outside of it
if you were
advising american business would you
advise them to get
over there into that area of the world
and if and what's the best kind of thing
that american enterprise can do for uh
southeast asia well as you probably
discovered when you were in vietnam uh
it's one of the few places in southeast
asia where people believe the americans
can do everything there is a natural
assumption that americans are still
on
question top nation
and i think there's a willingness to
sort of deal and trade with the united
states secondly
there is a feeling now that the
predominance of the japanese and so much
investment now in southeast asia is
something that needs to be sort of
countered if you like by the european
investment by investment for the united
states if i were advising people i do
from time to time i'd say build on your
existing strengths
and those are in service industries we
still have a real competitive advantage
in some areas of banking some areas of
trade finance the whole service sector
department stores it strikes me is
amazing that american skills and you
know retail marketing and all the rest
of it didn't get into some of these
economies in the major department stores
you find in malaysia and singapore
japanese and french
so i think there's a lot of work that we
need to do and i concentrate on the
cities where which are getting huge
which are very very wealthy and which
lifestyle preferences are very very
western right outside of the airport in
hanoi
is new construction
and they're
houses
again there's a 1991
structure meaning last year and there's
some in 89 and this is all new and you
know i don't know how it translates
today but our
our guide said that these places cost
somewhere on the order of two thousand
dollars to build uh that looks like it's
in downtown but actually it's it's uh
it's along a stretch of a highway from
from the airport
and from the hanoi airport into the city
uh one of the i i've always wanted to be
when you travel around that part of the
world you see an awful lot of people
living in high rises or
jammed together families and all that uh
how come there's such a dramatically
different way of life there than say
here in the united states where we have
our individual single-family houses well
remember a couple reasons that much of
the urban commercial life all over
southeast asia including vietnam
malaysia thailand indonesia philippines
was if not controlled by ethnic chinese
and certainly they were they put their
stamp on it so you would go into the
downtown area and what you would have is
a very classic form of
living in which the downstairs the
ground floor was the business and then
if you look
upstairs now these aren't necessarily
shop
shops but they reflect in fact they may
be shops if you look at it i think the
downstairs is the shopping could be
shops you can't tell because none of
them are open no no i'm almost certain
they are so the ground floor will be the
um the area of trade
trading and upstairs the family lives
and it's a very characteristic feature
of chinese urban life
in southeast asia it goes back hundreds
of years you go to malacca in malaysia
and you'll see three or four hundred
year old
shop they're called shop houses in which
people live like that we mentioned
earlier about the malaysians
being in hanoi and in saigon the same
time we're there and we've got some
pictures of the of the motorcade with
the prime minister that happens to be
around what was one of the hanoi hiltons
on the left there one of the prisons
where pows were kept
[Music]
during the vietnam war american pows and
on the right there you'll see a
motorcade coming by the reason i bring
show you this to ask you about 15
million people in malaysia what what are
the what's a way to describe the
differences between a malaysian and say
a vietnamese
well malaysian is um
it's you've picked the toughest category
of all because malaysia is such a
multi-racial country you've got barely
50 percent of the country ethnic malays
you've got about 35 39 ethnic chinese
and they in turn are all little
subgroups based on where they came from
from southern china then you've got
ethnic indians indians from south asia
who came over as plantation laborers and
as civil servants for the british
colonial administration so you got a
real
salad there in malaysia what is a
malaysian
i think that's something the malaysians
are still working toward but that said
if you're for example going to be
looking at vietnamese and say contrast
them to people like thais or say
javanese who are the most dominant group
in indonesian i think there's an awful
lot of similarity
this motorcade included the prime
minister the one thing i noticed about
the malaysians that they were bigger
people yeah in the vietnamese well
nutrition really counts i think that the
malays as a people and remember they
spread all through this huge archipelago
that now is malaysia and indonesia but
you know there's 20 000 islands in the
archipelago so they were seafaring
people and i think the vietnamese were
more uh were less inclined to do that uh
mahathir
mahathir mohammed is the malaysian prime
minister and he's
very anxious to
cut a figure in southeast asia as a sort
of leader of
developing southeast asian countries
that want to create their own trade bloc
for example vis-a-vis the united states
what would he be able to provide the
vietnamese well
malaysia is a very rich country the per
capita income is only slightly behind
singapore and if did you have you
visited kuala lumpur no well you will
see there that is the most startling
contrast it's a central valley in the um
malay highlands and you've got these
high-rise buildings glass and steel
kuala lumpur is just up that's right
just slightly to the west of your your
point there we are uh
coming out in the middle of this
tropical jungle and it's this brilliant
picture of
modernity of prosperity and they have
plenty to offer in plantation
agriculture especially when i was a
journalist in malaysia in the mid 80s
already then the malaysians were talking
with the vietnamese about improving
their rubber plantations palm oil oil
that comes from the oil palm plant is
very well developed in malaysia so is
coco malaysia in the period of five
years came from nowhere to be one of the
fastest and best producers of highest
quality cocoa in the world what's our
relationship as a country with malaysia
we sell
to and buy from malaysia more than we
bought from the entire soviet union
before
that puts it in perspective doesn't it
uh
southeast asia is really the unknown
quantity it is an area which is as i say
rich
has tremendous resource spread receiving
foreign investment from the japanese and
from us i'm not saying that we're
totally left behind from the koreans
from the taiwanese and yet uh the
popular understanding of southeast asia
is next to nothing if you cut out our
obsession with vietnam let's go back
over some of the countries we've talked
about uh in singapore how is the prime
minister chosen and and i guess i'd also
ask in each case how much do the people
really have to say about it okay
malaysia and singapore took the british
parliamentary system you know where
you've got a party and it wins power in
parliament and the leader of that party
is chosen by the party itself not by the
electorate
so it's a party decision who is the boss
of the party and then assuming they win
a majority in the local parliament then
he becomes prime minister so that's how
it works in malaysia and in singapore
individual have much say so in that no
unless he's a member of the governing
party and the governing party has been
in place in power in both those
countries really ever since their
independence back in the 50s and 60s how
would you describe their political
philosophy uh authoritarian
very much
matching the wish of the people there
not to have too much uh partisan
politics there's a fear that if you have
two uh
rambunctious two vocal uh electoral
politics that you're going to play to
racial politics which is what was
happening in the 50s and 60s they like
the idea of a governing a government
keeping order of continuing to fuel uh
economic development and i think that
most certainly in malaysia and singapore
i think the trade-off is we'll have less
political liberty that's all right
we're not you know we have elections
which are fairly counted and we have an
opportunity within limits to express
ourselves the trade-off is
a promise that's been kept which is
economic prosperity the way how much the
public have to say about what goes on in
thailand in thailand uh there the
military are extraordinarily powerful uh
we've have now the is it the 13th or the
14th constitution that the thais are now
bringing into force since 1932. in the
philippines it's the eighth constitution
constitutions and formal electoral
politics matter an awful lot less than
who is traditionally in charge of the
place and in the philippines it happens
to be a group of elite families with a
provincial power base in thailand as i
said before it's the military and the
elite bureaucracy but with the military
very much
top dog
our producer has a note here that says
that in in thailand the impact of the
coup last february was the 17th in
modern history uh 17th coup that's what
it says 17th grade modern history i
would think he means it dates from say
um before the second world war because
there was a period there in the 30s what
happened there was a fundamental change
that the
the monarchy became limited at that
stage and there was a military coup
which limited the monarchy's power at
that time now since then i think that
that figure is absolutely right but
that's how it happens in thailand and
the feeling usually is that thai coups
are something of a joke you know you
have a few tanks on the streets the
generals talk it over between themselves
new faces appear and the people get on
about their business press freedom in
singapore malaysia and thailand well
that's a tricky one for me to answer
especially i should put my cards right
on the table i was prosecuted by the
malaysian authorities for a breach of
the official secrets act back in 1985
which
caused a bit of interest at the time
because it was the first time a western
correspondent had been
charged for breaching official secrets
in southeast asia
uh so i have direct experience of um a
an approach which says look i'm sorry
a lot of information that we have is not
something that should go into the public
domain it's something that we prefer to
keep to ourselves
there are a whole lot of controls
formal and informal they have official
secrets act they have annual publication
permits so if a newspaper is getting out
of line quote unquote they can withdraw
the permit and then informally a lot of
these newspapers are owned by holding
companies that are actually linked to
the political parties so the whole
controls both formal and informal are
really heavy and if you're a journalist
anxious to make a career in
investigative writing i think you've got
a hard road ahead of you what happened
to your prosecution i was convicted and
fined 10 000 malaysian dollars dow jones
paid it not me and to the malaysians
credit i was able to continue working
as a correspondent there until the visa
came up for renewal and then i had this
very southeast asian i had a an informal
phone call from
the deputy prime minister saying look
you know if it was in my hands of course
james i'd extend you but
the prime minister really would prefer
that you move on and that's what i did
and you were living where then kuala
lumpur
now you were the the publication you're
with the uh far eastern economic review
is owned by dow jones that's right were
you there at all involved when the
singaporeans or mr lee kuan yew mr lee
said
the asian version of the wall street
journal no more can you publish in this
country well i've been uh
one way or another either involved or a
close witness to a lot of these moves in
malaysia and in singapore and in
indonesia and their approaches are
varied and very interesting in malaysia
they used a formal legal approach to
send a message not just to me and to the
foreign press but also to members of his
cabinet i mean that's what these things
are usually about they're what do they
say beating killing the chicken to
frighten the cow you know you go after
an easier inquiry so that other people
in your government get the message which
is to be quiet and not speak so much to
the foreign press in singapore they
simply
held up distribution of the publications
and for many foreign publications
malaysia and singapore are very key
markets for obvious reasons english
speaking very wealthy
habit of reading from british colonial
times so a lot of the markets there
indonesia had a rather cruder approach
which was to look at the offending
article and take a big black
felt pen and actually
individually scrub out the offending
article and let the whole magazine come
in
as marked
one of the people
that i know i visited with in singapore
said that if you look at at the bottom
of some of the stories in the
singaporean papers there's a little
initial
that tells you who the sensor was i'm
not too sure about that i know that it
changes from time to time there's a very
interesting thing that happened in
singapore the
we were we the united states were
pushing singapore to enact intellectual
property laws like copyright so that
people wouldn't rip off american designs
and also steel copyrighted materials
basic thing that we needed to have them
do they agreed to do that and then they
got into problems with dow jones and
with the far eastern economic review as
well so what they did was
they took in the
magazine eliminated all the ads
photocopied it printed it again
distributed it to people inside
singapore and made an amendment to their
own statute which allowed them to go
ahead and do this which of course they
were breaching their own copyright law
so it all got very weird and wonderful
back to
south vietnam yeah a lot of our american
viewers will remember what especially if
they were over there south vietnam
there's a something new there if they
didn't watch us back when we ran this
first over the memorial day weekend
that's a hotel
it's called a floating hotel the saigon
floating hotel
supposedly according to the people there
told us that that was you'll see a
better version over here in a moment
that it was built
in singapore
moved to australia for a year that is
the floating hotel subsequently bought
by the japanese and i may have part of
this wrong and then moved to saigon or
ho chi minh city where it sits there on
the river
it's like the queen mary it sits it
sells uh there's you know there are a
couple restaurants inside tiny little
rooms but
it's a luxury hotel
and each night's lodging is about 200
american dollars
the reason we show it is to see how
things
are changing right you know as even
during this embargo that we have on
there but what about all those countries
the singaporeans and the japanese and uh
the australians do they all they all get
along
uh they get along most of the time there
are squabbles and one of the interesting
things about southeast asia is
adjoining neighbors often have their
little um you know
hidden agendas the malaysians and the
singaporeans quarrel
uh the singapore feels very sort of
isolated and of course very small by
comparison to the malaysians and the
indonesians they see themselves as a
sort of chinese island in a malay
indonesian sea the indonesians and the
australians quarrel over things like
timor
division of boundaries and also the
australian press is always writing on
uncharitable things about indonesia
but there is a lot of commonality i was
just thinking about the
hotel you showed i mean
it's a very good move because it shows
that instead of actually going to the
trouble of getting the right contract of
the right building materials the right
fixtures you know telephones and
internal wiring and all the rest of it
which could be a nightmare who knows if
you can get all this stuff
they simply went ahead and said look
here's one we'll buy off the shelf or
sail off the shelf or whatever they did
with it well at this same hotel and this
all fits in what we're talking about
there was a sign
and also a visitor when we were there
by the name of lee kuan yew
who
we understand is
his
father i think was vietnamese and his
mother was chinese or vice versa maybe
his mother was vietnamese and so they
kind of claim him but here's you'll see
that sign up there on the left it says
saigon floating hotel welcomes the visit
of senior minister of singapore mr lee
kuan yew and mrs lee
the thought being at this point point
back in april that mr lee would be a
counselor to the country
would you expect
that kind of arrangement to eventually
really happen and would then vietnam
eventually be governed the same way that
singapore is that's a really interesting
question and i think that you're really
on the right track uh lee kuan yew you
know
advises lots of people around the world
he invites people outside asia he uh
likes giving advice um many people feel
that lee kuan yew is a man who was
destined to become leader of a country
is far too small to
encompass his ambitions and he's
extremely talented how old is he i think
he's getting to be in his mid to late
60s but remember he is
one of the few asian leaders who ever
said all right i'm going to step out of
the way the younger generation is there
the new singaporean prime minister
gohchuk tong is only 48.49 there's no
question but that lee kuan yew still is
consulted a lot but within the asian
political culture that's a big step
what's so special about him well very
few people have done it
what does he have
as a human what does he have that makes
him so successful he's extraordinarily
intelligent
a cambridge graduate he can he's at home
in mandarin he's at home in english he's
at home in malay i think he even speaks
tamil which is the language of most of
the small indian minority in malaysia
and singapore he is extraordinarily
formidable presence i met him once and
he's one of the few people who sort of
had my knee slightly shaking i think the
other one was george schultz you know
because they're you know very sort of
hard guys to deal with and if they're
not happy with your line of questioning
they'll let you know it
um but beyond that he's always felt
comfortable with the role of being some
sort of the elder statesman or the
middle age and then the older statesmen
of southeast asia and western
politicians got into the habit of
dropping in in singapore and having a
chat with him one last little bit of
tape and you've been very patient we'll
let you go soon uh is again from saigon
and what it'll show here in a moment
again not on a busy at a busy time but
there are a lot of
new billboards and ads there's a lot of
fresh paint there this is again back in
april
you can see the national panasonic off
in the corner the japanese company the
kenwood there in front of you a japanese
company these are companies that are
doing business
in
san tsui in
in vietnam sharp another japanese
company there are
i don't know whether we have the
billboard here but right in front of the
rex hotel which is right behind us where
we are there there's a list of the
number of companies from the number of
countries inside the hotel and there's
the germans and
the dutch
and the japanese and the koreans
oh yes no it looks like any um
major uh city intersection in southeast
asia i mean unless you knew if you
you're dropping it to the street you can
see that it probably is vietnam then you
can see occasionally some of the um the
script but that could be anywhere in
southeast asia and yeah
oh absolutely it's it's it's an open
season economic system and i think it's
uh
disgraceful that we're not more
prominent there already i think but go
back to our embargo our all of our
allies around the country basically
saying to us
we don't care what you do we're going to
go ahead
it operates at a number of levels um one
of the levels that it operates at is
that we
i mean we
american petroleum firms continue to
have um links with the vietnamese for
example who have large areas that they
have told people informally that they're
going to put aside for them
it also works at a number of other
levels where people make arrangements
informally to really as it were sort of
come out of the closet once the embargo
is finished i wouldn't say that we're
sitting there shooting our foot
completely but the main thing about the
embargo is not so much what we're doing
or not doing but the effect that our
policy has on getting commercial credit
going again to vietnam
most of the signs that you see there are
signs that
reflect the presence of companies that
are drawing on their own finance to get
started up and established in vietnam
and we can't let our people do that yet
and moreover we're
preventing a um a deal going through the
international monetary fund which would
allow vietnam to get over what's called
the arrears problem because they had a
severe shortfall of foreign exchange in
the mid to late 80s they began to fall
behind in their payments of interest to
an imf
and i think the united states
has taken the view that
no we're not going to let them come up
with a deal with commercial banks to
repay that credit
and that was used very deliberately as
part of a way to get the vietnamese to
agree to a cambodian deal before we lose
you where'd you go to school
new zealand universities canadian
universities
a year at harvard and a year at oxford
and what kind of degrees do you have i
have a law degree
and
a bachelor's degree and
i know it's on the list here how many
different languages do you speak well
that's always a tricky one i always
blush a bit at that because of course
what happens you go one place and you
replace the last language you spoke with
another one but i think if you added
them all up
conversational fluency about six or
seven
final uh question to you about the
future of the embargo with vietnam you
mentioned earlier something about the
election
predict what will happen
our election well not not predict
what'll happen in our election predict
what will happen after the election and
how long will this embargo be on in your
opinion my own feeling is that we're
just about ready to go once the
election's over i could be quite wrong
but i know that there is the feeling
here in washington that whatever
administration comes back in and of
course depending on what happens in
cambodia if the vietnamese were to do
something foolish such as to become
involved again in any military sense in
cambodia or misbehave in a variety of
ways all the bets are off but if things
continue as they are now
i would say we'll have an embassy there
next year professor james clovis clad
senior associate uh for asian politics
and economics of the current endowment
for international peace thanks for
spending this hour with us tom enjoyed a
great deal
you're watching vietnam revisited on
c-span
one pillar pagoda was built in 1040 to
honor buddhist advisors who had been
loyal to king leiloy
vietnam still used chinese characters
after gaining independence from china in
the 11th century
it was not until the 20th century that
the country utilized the romanized
script discovered by french missionary
alexander de rhodes
vietnam revisited continues in a moment
but first some samples of vietnamese art
[Music]
come on
[Music]
ah
[Music]
down
[Music]
james webb on a sunday not too long ago
millions of newspaper readers around the
country woke up to you on the cover of
parade magazine on an article that you'd
written on your trip to vietnam with the
headline can we put the war behind us
how would you answer that question
it's a
very complicated question
how can we put the civil war behind us i
mean when you when you have
an experience a national experience that
divided the population the way that it
did and
set people against each other
just you can see from from the calls
you've been getting on this show
how deep the emotions run i think what
we need to do and is something that
i tried to do when i first started
writing my novels first novel was about
vietnam was rather than saying can we
put it behind us can we assimilate it in
in the right way and move into the
future
james webb is with us for this segment
in vietnam revisited we're going to talk
with them a bit here on our set and then
open up our telephone lines for your
questions from around the country uh you
traveled to vietnam but first i want to
explain when you served there yes i i
was a marine in vietnam
with first battalion fifth marines
infantry in guangnam province a place
called the anwar basin i was wounded
twice
i like most people came back i did
hospital time
went to law school started doing other
things
went back the first time a year and a
half ago with senator bob carey he asked
me to come and advise him on some
meetings that he was having in hanoi and
then saigon stayed
for five days after he left in saigon
and then went back again this may
with tranbanka who was on your show
yesterday
on a humanitarian
visa
and i would i would like to emphasize uh
at the beginning of this that
since i was on a humanitarian visa i
believe that it was my obligation to
conduct myself in a non-political manner
when i was in vietnam and i i would have
a little bit difficulty talking to you
about political reactions
in in terms of the visit there i can
talk to you politically as long as you
like about
what we need to be doing as a nation
here but in terms of the visit over
there it was a humanitarian and not a
political visit what does it mean a
humanitarian visit what'd you do
car as your viewers likely know has
set up an assistance program and has
been assigned a clinic in kanta in the
mekong delta
to help
people who were disabled
mostly those who were disabled during
the war and most of uh those or special
attention from our perspective going to
the former arvind soldiers who
are not considered veterans under uh
current vietnamese law i
have a
very strong feeling about the
former urban soldiers i think that
they've taken a bad rap in terms of
how they've been dealt with historically
uh in the writings about the war and the
coverage during the war i think they
were misunderstood in terms of what they
contributed on the battlefield
they suffered 254 000 combat dead from a
nation uh about one-tenth our size which
is 40 times the combat dead on a
national ratio basis that we suffered
they suffered another approximately 56
000 dead in the re-education camps after
the war
they have no veteran status inside
vietnam and they have no veteran status
the ones who are here and so i i
had heard about cause program a year ago
and
introduced him to the disabled american
veterans
with an organization which i have a
great amount of respect for
and
was invited baika to go with him
uh to
help the people in his clinic and to
observe uh what he was doing
and
once we uh
were permitted once i was given a visa a
labor ministry visa rather than a
foreign ministry visa which they still
have not issued me
over over the years to do
journalism
we were allowed to go to clinics all
over the country
in the north uh and in the south we
drove
from hanoi uh to haifang uh spent five
days in hanoi and then drove the length
of the country uh
very emotional going through central
vietnam for all that's been written
about the bombs over hanoi and the tanks
in saigon
central vietnam on both sides of the dmz
is still suffering greatly
as i wrote in the piece i think you can
legitimately say that's one of the worst
crossfires in history
what happened to in min chung the
to the people of central vietnam
we went to nyatarang
along the coast and then over into
saigon down to kanta in the delta and
then went all the way to the cambodian
border uh to the temples at chow dub
during a festival
uh and then eventually back on and out
of saigon the total trip was how long
about three weeks now you emphasize the
labor ministry visa and your parade
article you talk about uh your adventure
in trying to leave the country
could you explain surprise what happened
um
yeah i
when we
left uh from the airport we were singled
out and very
on orders from above and my things were
gone through completely even my shaving
kit was open the aspirin bottle and my
shaving kit was opened
and as much as anything else it would it
represented
two different things for me one is uh
just
letting me know who really was the boss
we sort of were given a string to go
through the whole country they're very
curious about me i've spoken out very
strongly on the issues of
the former vietnam kung hwa people the
people who worked for the south
vietnamese and fought for them
i think they wanted to see if i had
anything that they took my papers into
another room and photographed them all
my private papers that sort of stuff i
think they wanted to see if in fact i
had been engaging in political
activities inside the country
uh and then secondly i think it's it's a
clear indicator of the division that
inside the hanoi government right now uh
there is a strong uh moderate force i
have been able to meet and discuss
issues with with a number of them uh and
there also is uh a hard-line element
that still mistrusts americans and a lot
of these people have never been outside
the country
they are heavily represented in the
interior ministry
and those were the people who control
exiting the country in the cover of this
magazine article again it says it
suggests that this is the land that
forever changed your life you agree with
that i think that's true i think for um
for anyone who
uh spent time in vietnam as a young
person and particularly those who
were exposed to
heavy combat
and in the areas that
that
my division my marine corps division
operated
heavy combat where
constantly the civilians were in the
middle
you cannot
help but have that uh affect you for the
rest of your life when i was 22 23 years
old i was making
moral judgments
uh
that were as complex as anything i would
ever face again
we
often fought in the villages with the
villages in between and one thing that i
have have
often
said to the vietnamese community here
and
and also to the people that i've dealt
with over there is
uh the people that i feel the strongest
for uh when i look back on the war uh
were the the civilians in in this area
who were caught in between because this
was uh in in guangdong province
half of the marines who died in vietnam
died in this one province they fought in
five provinces there was no kaisan there
was no way city there was no kantian but
every day there was something going on
and like as not it was happening in the
villages and
when uh when you have that kind of an
experience it it does
in a way change your life and what you
do with it is you attempt as i said to
assimilate it and to use it
for good but also you cannot forget uh
other people americans and and
vietnamese who uh suffered through that
and still need help
you said you've written some books about
the experience you've written some
articles
you're involved with the vietnamese
community here in the country and you've
gone back can you gauge how important an
issue this is in your life overall
um
well that's hard to say i mean i i can't
say it's it's the dominant issue in my
life what i what i can say is that uh
over the last year and a half
a couple of things that have happened
that have allowed me to to really focus
on this uh one is uh
the dissolution of the soviet empire the
uh
uh
the elimination of this immediate
security threat to the united states
that frees us
uh those of us who have worked in
national security area and this sort of
thing so it frees us up to
to spend more time on on areas that
might not have been front burner issues
when we had the intensity of the
east-west military
potential military confrontation
um and then the other is since i left
government
when i write i can control my schedule
enough that i can that i can stay
involved
and both of those
issues dovetail with the fact that this
is the most important time
in terms of american vietnamese
relations since 1975 that the issue has
become ripe as has been pointed out so
many times on on the shows that you're
doing here
we are going to define our relationship
with vietnam in a way that's going to
affect uh the relations between the two
countries for the next 20 years so it's
it's an important time for all of us to
uh to put it more toward the front
burner and to and to look at it could
you crystallize what your view on where
where those relations should be in short
order um
quickly uh i think your previous guest
is is probably correct whoever wins uh
and however people feel about it the
trade embargo is going to be lifted
i am extremely disappointed in
the way that the state department has
handled the issue of normalization over
the last four or five years
they've been dealing with
a road map that quickly became outmoded
when the soviet empire fell apart
the major requirements that our country
has placed on the communist government
in vietnam had been a cambodian
resolution and accounting of the
prisons were prisoners of war in the
mias
we are the only country in the world
that
has
a deep obligation toward the people who
fought for us and their families
and we have not articulated that in the
normalization process i'm i'm extremely
disappointed about that uh at the same
time i i do believe that
we should
proceed uh with normalization but we
should do this
uh
at this point with the negotiating
leverage that we have in a way that
ensures that those millions of people
who align themselves with us during the
war and their families uh have equal
access to the benefits that our
normalization
process will bring to to the country
could you be more specific what does
that mean
well
if you uh
served the south vietnamese government
there are a number of disabilities that
are built into your ability
to
get a job
have a career
move forward uh for a classic
uh example that i've already mentioned
is that if you were a soldier for the
vietnam kung hua
uh even if you're totally disabled
if you want an artificial limb you have
to buy it yourself and you can't work so
how do you buy the limp so these guys
are walking around on little chocks of
wood
we need a clear commitment
from
the hanoi government and also
from the provinces that these sorts of
legal disabilities and
quasi-legal disabilities will be removed
from the people who believed in us
otherwise
you have this this odd situation where
we will be viewed inside the country as
moving back and shaking the hands of the
communists and ignoring the people who
suffered because they had believed in us
before um everywhere i went when i was
in in vietnam on this last trip i
mentioned the vietnam war
the veterans of the of the vietnam war
people not the governments per se but
the people who had served the government
and
on the one hand i would be told
by literally everyone i met and i met
the heads of the veterans group in the
north and the south it's time to make
peace we want to shake your hand the
past is the past we need to move into
the future
and i would say i believe that when you
will tell me that you want to shake the
hand of the
the kuchimban pinakanwa and bring them
into the future as well
uh that's an issue that if they don't
hear from this government on they have
no real obligation uh to follow up on
and it creates problems inside vietnam
if if the hanoi government moved forward
on that by itself
it would create uh i think some
resentments uh because of this the
suffering among the people who fought
for the communists uh
uh the tremendous casualty rate that uh
that the communist soldiers had uh it's
something that we need to advance and
does this government the united states
have the power to affect internal policy
indeed we see i don't believe that's
internal
not in this situation uh any more than
apartheid was internal uh in in south
africa i believe it's our unique
obligation to people who align
themselves with us uh to raise the issue
of equal treatment if you want it's an
internal issue if
if if we tell you how to run your
government it's not an internal issue if
we say
you have an obligation to treat everyone
the same you can't create separate
statuses of people based on conditions
that they can't change
it's
it's to me not a large barrier it just
it's uh it blows my mind that uh our
government our state department has not
seen fit to raise it
uh but once that barrier is removed or
once once those guarantees have been in
place then it is time for us to uh to
return a very interesting thing for me
having having been in in vietnam uh last
year and then this year
uh the difference on the street in
saigon
you know forget the
the elevated level of
business activity and that sort of thing
the interesting thing was
last year when i would walk the street
to saigon everyone thought i was an
american
this year when i was in saigon everyone
thought i was an australian or a
frenchman or anything but an american
and
the mood on the street was not as as
warm
uh as it was a year ago what does that
say to you it says to me uh
two things number one
um
when this a year ago
people were very excited about the
americans coming back uh now they're
turning toward these other countries but
the other thing is
we are the only nation that really has
the institutional memory uh that can
reconnect with the people who fought for
us and helped take care of them they're
turning towards those other nations
because they're there right on site
we're going to take some calls for jim
webb and he
talked about his service in government
those of you who follow national issues
will remember that during the reagan
administration mr webb was secretary of
the navy 1987-1988
uh we're going to open up our phone
lines so we'll put the c-span phone
numbers on the screen for your questions
for our guest and we'll take our first
which is from fairfax virginia
uh yes mr webb i served two tours in
vietnam
and uh i've never received any medals
that i
was supposed to earn
all i've got was my dd214
it's got the vietnam service medal
with two bronze stars
and vietnamese
cross of gallantry with the palm
i would like to know what these are even
well you should have more than that if
you uh serve two tours uh what service
were you in
maybe i got the campaign medal
uh
vietnamese campaign mantle vietnamese
across the gallery with palm vietnamese
service medal with two bronze stars
which service were you in sir which
branch i was in the navy the navy and
why don't you tell us what you think
about future relationship with vietnam
what's the right role
well i sort of agree we ought to start
taking care of our veterans over the
united states before we start
going back to vietnam and organizing
relations
we've got a lot of veterans here i'm
i've got a job i'm doing fine
family
but it still does bother me you know
about vietnam thank you sir fairfax
virginia mr webb okay um i would
encourage him to uh contact the
department of the navy and they can
reissue him all of his awards
what about take care of our own veterans
first
there is a there's a hierarchy here
i i spent four years on the on house
veterans committee as a council back in
77 to 81 i am very sensitive to what
happened to our veterans when they came
back particularly through the 70s but in
some people's lives were forever changed
not
by vietnam as you and i were talking
about by but but by what happened to
them when they came back uh this is the
uh the clearest uh class issue that this
country has faced in a hundred years who
went and who didn't
so
when when the people here when the
veterans here talk about need needing to
be taken care of
there is a lot of legitimacy in what
they're saying they're comparing
themselves to the people in their own
age group who did not serve who made out
who in many cases started successful
careers and who in many cases even today
have a stake in
a historic historical articulation of
the war that is not affirmative
at the same time
i feel very strongly that
the people who fought alongside us
the same battlefield
against the same enemy
need help deserve
our help
and we may talk about not being able to
get into some clinical program
or
not having
enough
different types of
programs from the va
a south vietnamese veteran is talking
about the very basics not even having uh
a pros prosthesis unless he can buy one
and i think we're big enough
uh we the veterans that were are big
enough to turn around and extend a hand
to these other people i'm gonna show a
little piece of videotape from the trip
and this is of our plane our cruise
plane uh landing in hanoi you can see on
your screen right there i think
your first visit was a year ago can you
remember emotions when you were flying
into vietnam for the first time
well you know people asked me when uh
when i was going back if i was nervous
about this and then i said
well
or if i was it was going to affect me
emotionally and i said uh
first of all i've never been to hanoi
and i've never been to saigon so you
know that's going to be new and second
of all i'm around vietnamese people
every day all you got to do is go down
to clarendon so that wasn't
going to be a particularly
new experience
the one thing that really had a strong
impact the two things had a strong
impact on me
the times that i've been back the first
was
when i got to saigon and
i met
a veteran
who had been a helicopter pilot at way
city and had been in a re-education camp
for four years and he was my siglo
driver when i was in saigon for the
first time
and
watching his emotions when he was
connecting with an american again and
the guy actually cried he said we knew
you'd come back sooner or later that
affected me feeling how uh
you know how badly i felt about having
abandoned
friends on the battlefield and the
second was this year being able to go
back into the anwar basin in guangnam
and going back to some of the places
where i had fought
i went into one place we used to set up
a lot we called it henderson hill and
some villagers came up and you know they
said we were the first americans that
had come back in more than 20 years and
there was one woman who was 30 years old
who immediately started talking to me in
pigeon english
the same
jargon that we would use with the kids
at this place when they would they would
help us wash and fill our canteens and
we would give them food and cigarettes
and gum and that sort of thing and it
was very clear that
the people in that age group had kept up
their uh
uh their conversational dialect and in
this pigeon english over all the years
let's take a call kansas city missouri
you've been waiting you're on the air
now go ahead
yeah i'd just like to say that i agree
with uh mr webb that the embargo should
be lifted
uh really what the embargo does is it
it hurts the people in vietnam and and
after all that's what we went over there
in the beginning to what was to help the
people in vietnam
and
i was over there in 90 and 91 and and i
uh
share his uh
uh beliefs that that the vietnamese
people want us to come back and they
were really
extremely excited to see us what took
you over there in 1991 sir uh work we
were working on
the airport there in saigon and a couple
other places up north
all right thanks for the call
mr webb no question there we can move on
if you'd like unless you respond sure i
would i would like to make a make a
point here though that the
the embargo lifting the embargo uh has
been the uh the key ingredient in terms
of our being able to
to use our negotiating leverage on
behalf of of the people who were there
there's a fine line and a lot of
arguments between what is going to help
the people and what is simply going to
help the government and
and draw out the the suffering of the
people and
my belief is
either way you look at it the embargo is
going to be lifted and and what i am
hoping for
is that however belatedly our government
gets
a statement
uh a guarantee from hanoi regarding the
equal access by all the people to the
benefits that are going to come as far
as you know are we the only country now
honoring an embargo against vietnam i'm
not sure i'm not sure how that works
because uh for instance uh i haven't
followed exactly what the japanese are
doing for sure i i know there was a
communication a couple of months ago on
this but previously what the japanese
had done
at uh you know on an official level were
saying that
they were not going to commit japanese
government resources and loans or
government-backed resources and loans
but individual companies were permitted
to go in on their own uh and
invest but um
when you look at countries like taiwan
you know which is there isn't a country
that's been struck more strongly
anti-communist in that part of the world
you know look at their relationship with
communist china and yet last year they
put 700 million dollars in i mean this
has fallen apart
the main
thing that we need to do and we probably
could have done it a couple of years ago
is to put the other issue on the table
and get the guarantee los angeles is
next what's your question for mr webb
please uh yes mr whip unfortunately our
cable television just went off
so i wasn't sure what was on last person
that was on with the gentleman
from the
carnegie foundation
um i'm a former vietnam vet
i've been back to vietnam seven times
since the war
and and the seven times i've gone back
that's in the last five years i've seen
dramatic changes
all about vietnam
um
i
do feel that we should
some is this as medical aid and whatnot
something like the marshall act or
something we should go in and help the
people like we did after the world war
ii
in korea um
what is the chances of our
halfway or at least going in and doing
that officially
sort of a half lifting of the embargo
uh i my reaction is that's something
that uh we have already begun to do with
these humanitarian programs
i i would be real careful with one
distinction it's not one that this
gentleman
the government backed resources and
loans but individual companies were
permitted to go in on their own uh in
when you look at countries like taiwan
you know which is there isn't a country
that's been more strongly
anti-communist in that part of the world
you know look at their relationship with
communist china and yet last year they
put 700 million dollars in i mean this
has fallen apart
the main
thing that we need to do and we probably
could have done it a couple of years ago
is to put the other issue on the table
and get the guarantee los angeles is
next what's your question for mr webb
please
uh yes mr whip unfortunately our cable
television just went off
so i wasn't sure it was on last person
that was on with the gentleman from the
carnegie foundation
i'm a former vietnam vet
i've been back to vietnam seven times
since the war
and and the seven times i've gone back
in the last five years i've seen
dramatic changes
all about vietnam
i
do feel that we should
some is as medical aid and whatnot
something like the marshall act or
something we should go in and help the
people like we did after the world war
ii
in korea um
what is the chances of our
halfway or at least going in and doing
that officially
sort of a half lifting of the embargo
uh i my reaction is that's something
that
we have already begun to do with these
humanitarian programs
i i would be real careful with one
distinction it's not one that this
gentleman has made but one that i have
seen written by some veterans who've
gone back when they say that uh
we haven't done this we did it after
world war ii and we haven't done this
now simply because we're bitter because
we lost the war i mean the distinction
is after world war ii
the systems of government which we were
fighting changed and it was possible for
us to go in and do these things and know
that we were assisting the people
this was not the condition in vietnam
and particularly
while the cambodian
incursion was going on full swing
we are now reaching the point where we
can provide humanitarian assistance and
know that it's not
going to further the efforts of war on
cambodia for instance when you're
sending stuff to hospitals
the climate has changed it's changed in
many different ways is the point that
i'm trying to make and the halfway
measure that the gentleman
suggested is is probably where we are
right now with the increased
humanitarian assistance that's been
allowed over the last year next question
is from austin texas
yes my name is paul and i'm calling to
first of all find out how can an
american do business in vietnam
and secondly i want you to comment on
why why do you think neither vet neither
presidential candidate
is debating about the veterans
administration and how we can fix it and
also i'm very proud of you your
work in the department of the navy and
you make my generation feel very good
thank you thank you very much
um there are three questions there the
first one in terms of doing business in
vietnam
technically un until the trade embargo
is lifted
you can't although the way that i
understand where things are now you can
make contacts and
and and begin the research that would
allow business to be done immediately
when the trade embargo was lifted
i don't have the
uh the specific route on how to do that
but i would suggest contacting our state
department perhaps the vietnam desk the
second issue on the on the veterans
administration i will say
this is a political comment that i think
needs to be made
i think both
presidential candidates should speak
about the future of vietnam and the bush
administration's policy toward asia as a
whole have been weak
we need leadership uh in in that region
we need to understand from president
bush how he sees the future of
vietnamese and american relations how he
feels about
the issues that we've been discussing
i think with
governor clinton
one of the questions that has not been
asked of him and which needs to be asked
of him instead of simply focusing on his
draft record and and the fact that
he uh used a number of uh
methods in order to
avoid serving in the military i think he
needs to be asked number one
why
did he
continue to work
to aid the downfall of south vietnam
after all the american troops were
withdrawn in 1973 he was one of a small
element
of a political activist who did that and
number two how does he feel about that
now that's something that's not been
asked of him how does he feel about what
happened in vietnam after 1975
given the naivete of so many
people of
our generation who made these
broad-based
judgments about the benign nature of the
hanoi government etc it was a much more
complex issue than that i think it
requires all of us to uh
to sort of reassess where we were then
and to come out with some honest answers
now you show a piece of videotape over
this next call just a couple of detail
questions for you it's of the
presidential former presidential palace
in what is today ho chi minh city
formerly saigon did the local residents
call it ho chi minh city or saigon
sargon
and when
it was funny even even the uh i find
even the north vietnamese
as they move south start calling it
saigon when was the name changed
uh i would i would assume it was changed
uh
almost immediately on the up on the
takeover in 1975.
austin texas your call's on the air yes
mr webb i'm a vietnam vet and i've been
fighting for my benefits i can see what
you're trying to do is good
but uh my case in particular i filed a
claim in 71 for ptsd which wasn't on the
books i've actually found my army doctor
who treated me
i've gotten a hundred percent from
social security for ptsd i go to the vet
center and get tr treatment and yet the
va i'm still fighting my case it's been
remanded by the board it's been on the
front page of the austin american states
and
can you see where my bitterness is
coming from when you're trying to go
back and help and i'm still fighting for
my benefits i can't get in the front
door
well i uh
i can empathize with with your case and
to me they're not mutually exclusive
i've spent uh i personally have spent a
great deal of my adult life working on
veterans issues for our veterans uh and
also
for uh the people over there and and the
people here who fought uh for the south
vietnamese there's no excuse
uh for bureaucratic uh intransigence
and uh the people who
fought in vietnam as i said earlier when
they take a look around at what happened
to so many elements in this age group
who were
able to to find other recourse
uh
have had a legitimate uh
i don't want to use the word complaint
they've had a legitimate case to make in
terms of
their citizenship when we have callers
to make reference to ptsd for people who
have no connection with the military
what does that term mean post-traumatic
stress syndrome
is a
medical condition that actually
we first discovered i counseled the
prisoner of war
studies when i was counseling house
veterans committee
they first saw this condition uh
clinically observe this condition in the
world war ii prisoners of war who came
home uh they when they first got back
they were elated to be here and then all
sorts of feelings set in so that after a
period of time
they had a number of emotional problems
uh related to
to uh and in their case feelings of
guilt because they this had been a great
victory and they had sort of set it out
and this sort of thing um about 25
of the soldiers in world war ii
according to a national academy sciences
study had also manifested some of these
conditions and with respect to the
vietnam war uh because of a number of uh
elements first of all the uh
the continuing
um
the unending nature of the way that the
operational units uh operated
the uh for instance in the marine corps
we took
more casualties in vietnam than we did
in world war ii and yet there were no
great battles there was no ebb and flow
in this combat environment
and
the continued stress caused problems for
a lot of people once they returned and
also returning to a very hostile peer
group uh contributed to that as well
lake tahoe is next
hello you're on the air sir thank you hi
uh hi jim this is uh jim hunt we had
dinner 10 years ago at the vietnam
memorial
dedication uh you might remember that
at that time i spoke about the cambodia
yes i remember you remember very well
good i don't remember how i drove you
back across the bridge
don't remember either but the question
is this jim you published an article in
the washington post in april uh
following in 83
and about a year and a half later the
movie killing fields came out
i was just wondering if that article had
any influence on the initiation of that
of that movie
or if you know there were similar
feelings existing at the time that you
wrote the article
i i don't have an answer for you on that
although i
i think that your call is is very timely
uh
since we've been focusing on vietnam uh
on on this show but there are a number
of americans who uh spent a good bit of
time trying to assist the people in
cambodia and uh that also is a you know
a very wrenching story and i remember
the dinner that the gentleman is talking
about and how he
uh spoke so passionately about the
people that he had served with and what
was happening to them at the time and i
thank you for your call on hollywood we
had a caller earlier in an open phone
segment on the power of hollywood to
influence an issue what about with
regard to this one does it has it
absolutely
does have that power it has and to this
point it is not done so constructively
we tend to forget that of all the uh
cultural elements in our society
hollywood was the most adamantly opposed
to the vietnam war one of the one of the
most mind-boggling things i have ever
watched in my life was the 1975 academy
awards
when a movie called hearts and minds
received the award for the the best
documentary
this was a scathing indictment of what
you want whatever you want to call it
american values and its connection with
vietnam whatever
the producers when they receive this
award read a congratulatory telegram
from the communist delegation in paris
as vietnam was falling and received a
standing ovation
so that was our starting point
with hollywood on attempting to
refurbish
the the image of the people who had
fought in vietnam uh and it's been a
very long road i
am not aware of
of a film yet that has really gotten it
right
uh there are a couple who
that in in emotional rather than
specific terms
could could bring out uh
something similar to what a veteran or
you know i don't want to speak for all
veterans because everyone's different uh
to what
the people that i know in the veterans
community would
would find palatable but
i think
on this issue
the the film industry has failed us boca
raton florida you're on the air
uh mr webb it's a pleasure to talk to
you
i come from a family both of my brothers
are
vietnam veterans i was an opponent to
the war at that time
recently
actually within the last five years my
older brother who was a very strong
supporter of the war at that time
began to
and we were both very politically active
began to change his uh his viewpoint on
the decisions that were made
in that era by johnson mcnair at all
i was wondering if your viewpoint the
overall strategic decisions that were
made at that time of your viewpoint has
changed at all and if you think that
those decisions that brought us into the
war
were
as valid now are valid now to you now as
you felt they were then
i think a lot of people have gone
through a lot of changes
um
in in our age group i don't know if you
followed the writings of david horowitz
there was a group of people who were
very strongly against the war they wrote
a piece a couple of years ago called
lefties for reagan
uh talking about
their own reassessment so people
people i think have been reassessing
this on on both sides
from my perspective uh
i've learned an awful lot about the
vietnam war since i returned i think
that all of us who remain interested in
in government
and in the functioning of government as
well as
in vietnam have an obligation to do that
my belief at this point is that this was
a war with a valid objective that was
very terribly implemented in the
decisions that that were made
i think particularly by lyndon johnson
but if you go all the way back and read
some of the writings say of bernard fall
bernard fall was writing in in the two
vietnams which he finished i believe in
1962
with a prediction that if we did not
uh get our arms around
what the vietnamese called the dick bun
the
political terrorists
that were a part of the the communist
mechanism that we were never going to
win the vietnam war that if we simply
viewed this as a military
endeavor that we were never going to win
the vietnam war and when uh john kennedy
put the first large element of troops
into vietnam
in 1961
uh the dick vun had assassinated
four thousand uh
low and mid-level government officials
in one year
eleven government officials a day
policemen school teachers nurses anyone
that just demonstrate any contact with
with the south vietnamese government uh
that was uh when you were talking about
the the early reasons for getting
involved i think that was probably the
strongest early reason something had to
be done we now understand
counter terrorism uh in in a much
clearer way than we did then i have no
desire to re-fight
the vietnam war day by day i can just
simply say to you
that i am comfortable with
the reasons that our country became
involved
and i hope
that
even given all of the tragedy that has
taken place that we can now help the
vietnamese people
move into a future where
they have the kind of liberty that and
freedoms that allow them to advance the
same way that the vietnamese community
here in the united states has
demonstrated that their culture is is
capable of using to advance they're a
very strong culture in my view they're
the strongest culture in southeast asia
if we can peacefully
assist
the country of vietnam to move
into an environment that allows
creativity to flourish and allows these
people to take advantage of the strength
of this culture we will have an ally in
the future we will have a different
system of government
bloodlessly brought about i hope
and we will have a much stronger region
beaufort georgia
yes i just wanted to make a comment i
had a son
in vietnam in
1970 i believe it was
and he had his 18th birthday there i had
another son
who didn't serve in vietnam in fact he
has never been in the military
and i just wanted to say i i feel that
these comments about governor clinton
are just uncalled for because at that
time i think a lot of young men had
their own uh
ideas about what they believed in and
didn't believe in
and uh
it this is 20 some years later i don't
think it really matters
and uh
i don't know that's all i have to say
all right thanks before georgia mr webb
okay um
this is i i have no desire to use this
uh this show as a forum to attack
governor clinton on his record of
military service i think that uh the
issue has been uh
uh illuminated
quite a bit in the media i will say
though that there is one distinction
that uh
i would like to raise to the woman
by the way that she phrased her question
and that is that someone ought to ask
governor clinton what he was doing uh
after 1973 when there were no americans
at risk
in vietnam uh
in conducting continuing political
activities that were designed
essentially to bring about the fall of
an incipient democracy that's something
that i think does matter and that's a
lot more than having to struggle with
whether
you were going to serve or not we have
about four minutes left with jim webb
you are today a full-time writer yes
why'd you leave government
i've never considered myself to be a
you know a
a government person in terms of career i
uh started when i left the marine corps
uh and went to law school i sort of
developed a dual track career without
really consciously deciding it where i
would write for a while and then i would
come into government for a while and
i felt like
if i was going to write about issues and
and have opinions that i should also
know what it's like to be on the other
side and have to implement programs
and
and so this sort of evolved without
really deciding my deciding it and my
uh most natural function i think and the
one that i feel happiest doing is when
i'm writing medford oregon you're our
last call for this segment go ahead
please oh jack webb jim webb jim webs
i'm sorry jim our jack i was also
stationed in anwar in quagnom providence
and i'm very interested in going back to
vietnam uh my question is uh how
restricted were you in uh traveling
throughout the quangdon providence like
that is are you allowed to go back to
the old fire bases uh because i was uh
in third amtrak there at anwar for a
little over a year
you are restricted if you're traveling
anywhere in vietnam
you have to have at this point you you
have to have internal visas
to move from one district to another
you have to have a guide with you a
government official in our case with you
uh no matter where you go and then when
we went back into anwar
that area
uh
we had
as i is my understanding i was told that
they they put the uh they sent the
interior ministry people out there the
day before uh to conduct some security
uh
measures to make sure that there were no
problems it's still uh you know central
vietnam more than hanoi more than saigon
still feels the bitterness and the anger
even among its own population because of
the war
this was
the the lateral hatreds
in this area as you well recall
were were enormously strong and a lot of
that still exists
also just by way of reference liberty
bridge is blown out so we ended up
having to make a 30-mile detour
instead of simply crossing the uh the
bridge but it was quite emotional to go
back there on the note of your trip you
speak vietnamese yes how did you learn
i spoke some when i was
stationed in vietnam
but then when i started working with the
vietnamese community i
just
felt like i really wanted to to be able
to to speak more fluently and uh
through friends in the community i
learned what difference does it make on
a trip such as the one that you made all
the difference in the world all the
difference in the world and you know
there are there are three major dialects
in
in vietnam uh
uh and so
you're in the it's it's harder to hear
some of the dialects but
when you can go up to a person and not
have to rely on a government interpreter
to find out what they feel and what they
think
what they will say and the warmth of
of the whole communication is much
better and also you have some surprises
for instance when i was at one clinic uh
i asked the director of the clinic where
he was from and he said he was from
guangzhou which is south of guangnam
then i asked him why he was speaking
with a north vietnamese accent
we're out of time thank you for being
with us
james webb vietnam veteran former
secretary of the navy and now uh writer
journalist
author thanks again
vietnam revisited continues here on
c-span we'll be here tonight until 6 pm
eastern time with lots more to discuss
and show you on this issue next an
interview with noah bantai she's a
former member of the national assembly
and the subject of this is on future her
views of future relationships between
her country and the united states
i want to thank you for the programming
memorial day was never a big thing in my
life i've never lost anyone personally
but the pain of the war was something
that i preferred not to think about your
programming i think um
allows us to go through a healing
process
and i think it's been very very helpful
thanks a lot i'm a former peace corps
volunteer and served in the
second civil affairs company and also
served as a forward observer and fire
direction officer in vietnam and i sure
have enjoyed the programming the last
couple of days i think it's uh
very informative and uh and helpful in
the healing process
i've absolutely been spellbound all this
weekend watching this i think it's
really been a service brian i'm
uh 57 i pretty much protested the war
i have such an understanding of the
vietnamese after this the whole thing's
been very very very moving very real
thank you i spent three tours in vietnam
totaling 48 months total time uh most of
which was in the infantry with the first
imagery division in the 25th infantry
division
and i just want to say that
i hope that someday i could forget
everything that i ever saw
and maybe
if i go to the wall that would probably
help but i just hope that i can forget
because whatever i do talk about i get
chills it's really weird
my husband is a disabled vietnam marine
and he's off fishing this weekend that
often proves difficult for him and i
think the nicest vietnam memorial gift
he will ever have are the videotapes i'm
making of your programming
he and his fellow veterans dearly want
to see footage of keith and fubai play
cool places that they were
and i'm getting little snips here and
there and in this film and they're going
to really appreciate it you know what
all us vietnam veterans said around here
and you won't let it die
how the hell are we supposed to live
with this if you don't let it die
yes this is miss j.t wells
i have enjoyed uh seeing where my
brother
was when he was in santa down
he retired a colonel
from the
army he was a helicopter pilot
and he picked up many of his friends
when they were dead or wounded
thank you very much
my first marriage was was a casualty of
this war my husband returned emotionally
scarred and being a teenager myself i
was too young to realize his pain
this show has helped me a non-active
participant in the war to begin to help
to heal some of my anger thank you
mrs time what is it like living in
vietnam these days
my thing is
fascinating
and i would not miss it for anything
because
this is
the time
where history is being made even though
we are making history easy
all the time but unless we've got
the
we've got uh every day
more improvement that is to say today
better than yesterday tomorrow than
today then otherwise not worth it but if
we're not uh cautious if we took the
wrong path now this everything could be
lost
so to me it's it's fascinating
now you're an elected member
of the national assembly
how do you get elected
i am actually a deputy from ho chi minh
city which means that i my direct
constituencies is the
10th
11th
present
at the same time i'm representing the
lawyers and the women association for
the whole country so it means that i've
got a lot of support
it's a mass organization how how long is
your term five years
that's true when was the election
well i suppose with the amended
constitution that's going to be next
june
this coming june yeah this is coming
june this legislature is over how many
members are there in the national
assembly uh for the time being 500
almost
but
this time we mean to have less
in terms of quality
and so as to have a very efficient
in terms of quality and that is why we
are reorganizing here for example my
place is supposed to be the uh
guest house of the new elected the mp
and we
some of us will be watching full-time
are you going to run again for the
national center yes i'm going to run
again
and that's why i have to to run back to
her chiming in a couple of days
and
try to get
you know same support
what's the difference in your opinion
between living in hanoi and living in ho
chi minh city
to me it's the same because you know i
am
even though i'm from ho chi minh but
being the chair
of the rocky mission
here it means it's not the
capital but it's for the whole
country
and of course the uh impact and the
entrance and support and the prestige
it's
nationwide what about the difference in
lifestyle in the two places
well i just run from place to places and
many places at the same time see our
country is very exciting thing is that
everywhere something good
and it's something which is not so good
as other places so this is swiss to move
around
so were you born in ho chi minh city i
was born in hanoi where you were yeah
when did you move to ho chi minh city i
went back i went outside to study
france
spain america i took my law degrees
i've got two three doctoral degrees it's
more that i actually needed but now it's
being appreciated because we are now
having and
market economy oriented so those who are
trained
in the west
now it's
quite helpful when did you study in the
united states i was in colombia
university in
57
58
and then got
internship in the united nations
and then i went back
to europe
and teach there in the
international active competitive law
where were you during what we call the
vietnam war
well i
spent five years in jail
in the various trials in the south
and i was released only with the end of
the war on the 30th of april
and of course i was against it well i
was against the
american intervention i told that to the
various american ambassadors who were
good friends to me
but all the time i was told that no no
victor was right in the corner and we
won the military victory
so too bad and i could not agree
so they said why don't you go to jail
and change your mind see
which which uh
which south vietnamese government put
you in jail uh see the first time i was
in jail was right
in 1965
when americans first got involved and we
did not want it because we knew it's
going to become an american war
and of course for vietnamese
it's not good
so so we i was quite against the direct
intervention
and so with a group of university
intellectuals we signed a petition
and uh then that was the first time that
we
i went to jail how long were you in jail
first time six months where
in saigon but you know it's they've got
different uh prisons so i've moved just
from one place
than the others
so then you came out after six months
and then did you live in saigon yeah but
you know
i was very beaten from having an
imperfection from teaching law
because they were afraid that i might
you know yeah sort of um
uh
get more support with my students and
all this
so the second time when two years and i
will release
they said now you're going to change
your mind
it was not and another two two years and
back again and six months
and they
my idea was that
the way we i mean history was made then
we were on the wrong
trail
and it means that
when the war will be over and victory
for sure is there because we know that
you know how the vietnamese people feel
in terms of
natural independence and peace and
reconciliation
so then it would mean that well just the
communists would hold monopoly
patriotism
so the challenge was there so i said
well i'm not a communist even though
they still put me
you know as communist and still now i'm
not is anybody member
you are not a communist no i'm not still
now and this is a very considered not
only in vietnam but in many other
associations before
as unique because
usually
you can never have somebody who would
lead the law commission at the national
assembly unless he
most of them is he
how would you describe your own personal
political philosophy then
i'm progressive
attribute
and i have to to be progressive and of
course in order to be progressive you've
got to
to do
to allow yourself
with the progress people they might
choose
their own political uh option
as long as they don't mind if i
choose my own
so we find ourselves having the same
ideas with those that were
trained
educated and politicalized by president
ho chi minh
as long as they don't
press me
to join the party or
they would discriminate against me which
is not the case do you think there ought
to be competition
in the races for the national assembly
oh it is definitely very very tight
will somebody run against you in june
when you run again oh yeah sure we would
be at least two or three but as i said
before you know they
this time we're going to have
independent
we've got individual
elector
many people think that this is progress
this is more democratic
through my experience
well i don't mind giving change to
anyone but i'm sure that the one who got
you know the backing of
very big important mass organizations
would obviously
be stronger in the race and one elective
would be able to do many more things
than the individual who just represent
himself
why didn't the americans
win the war
er not only the americans actually in
vietnam
the french before
the japanese
some what
chinese
79 the chinese border
and many years in the past it's just
because vietnam is a small country
and we know that we are small we're not
provocating anyone but by any means we
would defend our
used to say fatherland but now they say
madeleine because they think that women
have contributed a lot in the war you
see so it's not only the americans but
anyone you see that would do
the way
all those people did okay so now um we
are ready
uh
for cooperation to forget about the past
and to start on
equal footing for mutual benefit and
also there we've got a lot of
experiences
do you think
let me ask you not do you think but why
do you think
the american government has kept the
embargo trade embargo on for all these
years
and has it had any impact on vietnam
that um with the foreign investment law
and i was in new york
uh
more than a year ago for the first time
to
a
meeting that was caught on by the wall
street journal and with the first time
the presents i just said prison but i
don't think that they contributed a lot
so i would just say they were there
and i was
presenting
the views of the host country in terms
of foreign investment law
and again
just as they are when just as many years
before jason look we would very much
like you to be with us
but
if you don't want to history is still
going to be
done without you
by no choice
and now
in vietnam
i can say and everybody can see it
everybody is here except the americans
even those people that do not have
internet foreign relations with vietnam
like taiwan like south korea
but
again
experiences taught us
that we should not mix
the economic
even the political whenever possible
that is a kind of people-to-people
partnership
in exchange of culture
technique technology business and of
course
foreign this investment how do the
vietnamese feel about the americans
today
just to see we
all aware
that um well we feel very much
frustrated first of all because of the
embargo
but we
also
are very much aware
that our government
and again this is a very clever
leadership
they know
that
whether we
or anyone else when it or not
americans is a great america
they made a mistake because they thought
that power means
and i would call this the arrogant power
means that you got to destroy people
through the force of arms
so vietnam you know as backward
as we are
has given the answer nowadays it is not
the force of the arms that which prevail
and if we all agree
and that
and then me nowadays as long as we
respect our mutual respective political
economic options
then
cooperation is the only must
that is left
and we certainly know
and i especially those trained in the
u.s
it means see technology and
entrepreneurship and all this
so if the americans were here
the embargo was lifted then we would
become
as now the people start to call us
uh the next asian tiger you see i was in
singapore i see uh presiding over that
seminar and i feel uncomfortable
but then finally i told me that if
really we were given equal chance
then we would start to be a baby
tiger though what do you think
singapore is a modern
clean
successful
small country
what impact what did they do there that
you don't do here that might make it
better here if you were able to do it
well in the first place see i was there
for the first time
two months ago
to introduce vietnamese for investment
law
to that
seminar was called vietnam the next
station tiger
and i was telling them
that i'm there to learn not only to
introduce you know my own legal system
but to learn because you know we here
what we really like is the
the
sense
of
uh
the
consciousness of the rule of law
see which
if everyone if he would
respect it
then we would have law and order
and
this only happened with a industrialized
country vietnam has not reached that
stage
so it is very a sort of peasant
mind today is like that
and
tomorrow is different
and everyone would you know it's what we
call a short views what are you going to
have to do here to become like singapore
well it's uh we are moving towards what
we call a market-oriented economy which
means competition which means
individual incentive
which means also discipline
but
we have more than what singapore has
it's not resources
it's the
human resources and all of this is
brand new
if the trade embargo was relaxed and
americans could come here and get into
business are they allowed to own their
business 100 percent sure this is true
for everyone the law is the same and it
is what we call the quality of the law
is this new this is uh
in the law of foreign investment but now
is in the constitution now it's in the
constitution it is in the constitution
why did you put it in the constitution
uh again it's because
we think
that after all
we
are right in choosing our national parks
but for many people
they still are suspicious in terms of
what is socialism
with all this example of the word etc
even though we ourselves think that it's
different
but
still to draculize the people and we
need we i mean our aim now it's to build
the vietnam which is
rich
prosperous democratic
and obviously
open the policy to welcome
everyone here
so how could you attract
create huge capital and new technology
unless
you would you have to make a sort of
safe
guarantee that what they honestly
lawfully earn
then they would be protected by the law
and able to bring home
and all of this uh commitment
that the government of this country
has to give up
let me go back to what you said earlier
about being in jail
five five different times or for five
times five years
what impact did it have on you being in
jail what was it like in jail
well i've got all kinds of experiences
i've learned later on that for americans
it was a very unique case because they
would like very much also test
and find out how it's like
an intellectual see that would be in
general such a long time usually they
think that with just a few months
intellectual would be tired and then he
would give up the struggle
as far as i am concerned i again
my uh
feelings was that
i was very proud to be educated in the
west i know the value of it
but
if we lost all our political credit
so how could we be on equal footing with
all other vietnamese
political sector segments
so that as far as
national independence
they self
self how would i say
choice
self
governing
political option is concerned then
that's the vietnamese themselves
but back to what your own ex personal
experience in jail how did how do they
treat you that is why despite all kinds
again trials
trying to intimidate me to get me tired
to get to get me change my mind all
kinds of things funny i still
came out with the same idea because
otherwise i would not be prepared to
take the next challenge of our people
that is to say to build and get them in
peace
were you then a member of the viet cong
no that's again that's a big challenge
i'm not you've never been a comedy i've
never been and even though we had the
same policy in terms of
willing to end the war
uh national reconciliation
reunification of the country but i still
don't want to join they come in this
party i did not even want to join the
south vietnamese
viet cong as it is called so we will
call the third political
uh segment would you how would you
describe to our
audience the difference in governmental
philosophy from what you have right now
in vietnam and from what you know we
have in the united states a lot
for example
here now that we are preparing for the
elections
the first consideration is sim of course
it changed
each time the first time was the idea of
the whole vietnamese
country unified so we've had the
representatives of
all the different parts
the second term
was more already in terms of we would
need education
see so that the credit of loyalty
and the contribution to the war what
means how much you are at and able now
to build the country
and next this time
it's still
even
harder
we're hard in terms of
political target it's been renovation
so this is perhaps other for our
company's
friends
because they've got to somehow to forget
about some of their
ideas
and to say that well we're not going to
consider the uh foreign investors or the
vietnamese categories as exploiters and
not only that we will welcome their
money their technology their
entrepreneurship
see
so every time standards are different
let me ask you about things like
television stations you have what one
television station here we have we used
to have the uh with the soviet union's
orleans and all this
uh i think it's not so bad after all see
but steve is different are you ever
going to expand that to more channels oh
sure sure that's what our that's our
uh it's not only that but you know that
with the
open door policy
and with the asean people
cooperating so closely with us namely
seeing singapore lift embargo so
obviously mass media television is very
important
and
i think it would somehow help
us namely our communist
leaders
that yet and not
don't have as many as occasion as i have
for example to go outside
see that would help to them to welcome
or to see
or to share the benefit of
international cooperation you studied in
new york city at columbia university
in paris yeah and in barcelona yeah
how did you law school
law schools how did you get to do that
just that you know i was a little bit
naive at that time you see that thinking
that was coming from
what would we say
a colony
this is terrible conflicts of
inferiority
so some say well we are going to beat
them by arms
either by class struggle others by some
different things being intellectual i
thought that this is going to be by the
brain
so if i would study
as much
because in vietnam before we didn't have
the equality even though the quality in
terms of diplomas but not in terms of
citizenship to know the french
so this is the feelings frustration so
i'm going to beat you i'm going to learn
as much and more i'm going to teach you
what i did the international faculty of
law
and besides we had socialist capitalists
third world
scholars there
and then after some time that i enjoyed
doing that
having some sort of the revenge of
history but i found out that this would
help me to have the country unified and
peace restored and vietnam to be
a new modern country so i decided that i
must go home
and set the way and then of course
being home i have to join with the
struggle of the people
not too far from here is the ho chi minh
mausoleum and thousands of people lined
up to go through there
is he an important figure in this
country today well this is the whole
symbol
of vietnam
and
for the
mp before every national assembly
session
we all go and pay
homage to him
and namely that
we
think
that after all what's happening in the
world
that he thought
now is really
valuable and has a very important impact
on our choice on socialism but this
socialism has to be a vietnamese one
and coming back
to the 40
last years
during our struggle against the car and
economies
etc
so now we think because with a reaction
and
the new
renovation policy that
ho chi minh thought
is
definite and should definitely reach you
know this sort of universal could you
define
the essence of what ho chi minh
philosophy was yeah it's
equality
for everyone for everyone
should everybody live the same
not
mechanically speaking
see what i mean for the people and each
individual
but you cannot have individual freedom
you cannot have what you say in the west
uh what the human rights
you see when the whole people is
enslaved and we share the same
fate as other people in other countries
that are not
what we call
[Music]
what liberated
this is true for the people this is true
for the women this is true for the
worker how many women will there be in
the national assembly after the june
elections
well this time i think that we are
trying to make it more
you see how many our trouble is this
but out of 500 how many are there
it was about 18
18 but it was less than the
former time
the explanation is very simple same with
the man
you are good loyal
a lot of merit but you cannot you are
not quick enough see to reach with the
demands of our time in terms of
education in terms of
that so now it's going to be very
selective
it's not only a question of quantity but
quantity go back to the equality of ho
chi minh
does that mean that everybody has a job
or that everybody's paid every month or
that everybody has a place to live this
is the minimum
that everyone
should deserve
but of course it doesn't mean at all
that immediately you could have this
and that is why even though we are
having now what we call a market
oriented economy it doesn't mean at all
that we're going to spouse the real
capitalism because you think that there
are still
many difference in that
believe me what will be the difference
when you're finished between the
american capitalism and the free market
here in vietnam well it's just that uh
because nowadays a lot of people still
don't have work
job
housing and all of this we're here or in
vietnam see
so
this is still an idea an idea not
reality yet
but you should not give
one a chance to become multi
multimillionaire there
whereas whereas the other one got
nothing
will people be allowed to be a
millionaire here they are but they would
have to pay accession
this is to discourage
and get this money
to
implement our social welfare policy when
a company then like if americans came
here to build a company and they owned
it a hundred percent would they be taxed
very high uh
that would depends on our foreign
investment policy
if
this
cap is i mean we have got already by now
the list of priority
projects
and this is uh
i mean this goes together with the
incentive in terms of succession and
other things
so that the whole country will enjoy
and at least
a chance to
to develop
at the same time which countries are
coming in here
and investing right now
everybody is here but the best
one and perhaps the leading one now it's
this is again
a very interesting fact
those who do not have
diplomatic relations with vietnam
taiwan south korea singapore hong kong
so this means that if the americans are
here it's not because we do not have
diplomatic elections yet but it is
because of the embankment
and this
uh actually frustrated everyone not just
nagins even though of course the
american
businessman whom i met
said they are directly
just being uh frustrated but others are
too but despite all that yeah
earlier you said that you were not a
member of the communist party and never
have been why not
it's because you know i'm sort of
independent mind
and even when i am leading the lower
commission
since most of the people that in my
commission they are very top ranking in
the in the uh party in the government
but i understand the policy and i try to
influence a lot but i don't want to be
linked
you see a sort of framework like this i
want to i wouldn't say maneuver but at
least keep my freedom of
action as an intellectual who have been
your political heroes over the years
what you
let's mean that's did you ever meet him
yeah when i was a kid here when we just
have the uh national independence so i
was one of the very first
pioneer
of independent vietnam
and since i was i came from an
intellectual family so i know how to
play piano and all this so i was having
the
young group of musicians so wherever
president hojim was going so we just
jumped join him
very informal way it's spontaneous so
it's lovely
and that has all you know all the time
impressing me
and you are there is there anybody here
in the country that doesn't like ho chi
minh
no i i think that even those who do not
like
communism you see or socialism still
i have to admit that without him then
vietnam would not be an independent
nation and even now for many of us
we think that our cages i mean the
party members and all these if they'll
be rockers
many things they should still learn from
see the teaching president ho chi minh
never told them and on the country he
was warning them
that the moment we the party
see uh that lead the can the people to
struggle for independence will hold
power then the temptation abuse of power
will be there
see so you got to be very cautious and
all the time be the
people's power
and don't forget that you are here
by the
proxy of the people then you should
get your
uh
work committed to the people's
benefit
see so this is this was his teaching and
now nowadays i think that many of us
should
and that is why every time before we
meet
or have important meeting then we have
to go and
and pay homage to him so that those who
pretend to forget or interpret
you know what you mean thought in
different way then they would remember
that that man didn't tell those people
to be you know a lot of what
you know crying
uh looking down
and the people sometimes
directed
armies of power
you see
let me ask you one last question in the
constitution that you were one of those
in charge of rewriting the last couple
of weeks
you took out language that was
anti-chinese
anti-american and anti-french in other
words you had language in there i
believe that said that
we were your enemies but you took that
out of the new constitution how come
well this is um
we think
and that with some of us it was very
hard it was good i mean a lot of
arguments because some say well we
should give it there this is for
children
see history and they should learn and
don't forget it never forget it
then
and this was also the policy of the
party
that they would learn in the history
books
in school
but this is the constitution of this
time
since 1992
and socialist vietnam is going moving
toward
market oriented
economy with the open door
policy and welcoming our
farmers come here invest
regardless of the political
past religious options or this so this
is not the way
see and since the constitution is to be
amended for this
period of
history
it is not the past one
but then this doesn't mean at all that
the children forget it
it's because if we are independent but
they are so poor so backwards
so what's the use of being independent
so all of this was discussed a couple
quick personal questions i forgot to ask
you are you married
well yes i'm married my husband died
three years ago
and i've got four children and where are
they and uh the
youngest one she's now the dean of the
english department at the
grocery university she's just been back
from country university but she's got
her master's degree
and the other one is i mean all of the
three of them are in ho chi minh working
the
uh elders
he's working as he said now look i'm
taking a chance to be uh the fifth
sector which means individual i'm not
going to work for the state i'm not
going to be in collectively i'll just
work myself so he's teaching french
english at home
and of course he would take some time
tourists
group or things like but he wants also
to be his own on his own
see and the second daughter is in france
she's married to french manage that's
her option again
let's see
mrs tan thank you very much for joining
us thank you very much
and don't forget to see that um
we never got any
uh
tv
uh filming our
work at the national assembly
see
but the moment
the vietnam u.s
relations are going to be normalized
you will be the first one and i will be
there to welcome you
thank you and this is a challenge that
we both should take
you're watching vietnam revisited on
c-span
the mekong river stretches 2 800 miles
long the river begins in eastern tibet
borders part of thailand laos and
vietnam and then flows into the south
china sea
the land around this river is known as
the mekong delta located at the base of
vietnam
made up of nine provinces the delta is
famous for its fertile land which
produces enough rice to feed south
central and some parts of north vietnam
vietnam revisited continues in a moment
but first more aerial views of the
mekong delta
[Music]
you're looking at some footage right now
that should be very familiar to you if
you're one of the service people men or
women who served in vietnam that's the
mekong delta shot from a helicopter last
april when c-span visited there along
with the senate select committee on pow
mias tomorrow on c-span on friday we'll
be spending the whole day showing you
footage shot from our trip with the
senate select committee
we'll watch that for a minute and then
we'll take a look at tomorrow's schedule
in more detail
the schedule for our final day of
vietnam revisited friday september 4th
you'll see footage from the senate pow
mia affairs committee their arrival in
hanoi their tour through an army museum
tour through a former prison in hanoi
and the trip from the mekong delta which
you just saw a little footage of as
vietnam revisited continues on c-span
good afternoon we're on day four of our
re-air of vietnam revisited if you've
been with us you will know that what we
are doing is showing once again a
special series that we aired over the
memorial day weekend
got many hours of this and we had a
great deal of response to it the last
time around so we thought that
in light of all that response would give
an opportunity for people who saw some
of it and would like to see more or
missed it all together the first time to
see our trip to vietnam with the senate
select committee on pow mia affairs
and again tomorrow the final day will be
much of the footage shot with the
committee we traveled with them to the
mekong delta and other places in that
vicinity of vietnam where cameras had
not been
since the last american troops left
there so tomorrow an opportunity to see
some places that you may have served and
if you were a veteran of vietnam war
we have
some more footage to show you
from that trip and let's just give you a
look next at fuquak island from the
mekong delta area
was this all american this whole base
uh there was some vietnamese here too
yeah
we used to dock that was our dock right
over there
we come in here overnight
or get a couple days if our boats needed
repair we had a repair thing out there
that was floating
they'd lift the boat right out put it on
the
repaired hike and fix it up and
we had a barracks ship out there where
would you operate too from here which
way would you go straight back into the
whole peninsula we go back about a half
an hour over to hatian
and good up there and then we go way
down the end of the peninsula and work
off we had destroyers and
coast guard vessels re-harm us and
everything but we go into the rivers and
spend about a week
and you call the brown water navy
yeah
well it became known as that river rats
i don't know
but not when we were out here when we
were out here it was turquoise and
paradise it was beautiful look at this
stuff
this belongs to vietnam this part oh
yeah this is uh we had 15 000 prisoners
of war right up here in this island
and um this is where they make a great
fish sauce
mom
things no no but this is uh the reason
we came here today is that uh
our guys really wanted to talk to the
security people here a number of
americans have been arrested
in the waters here off of yachts and
other things some involved in narcotics
muggling other kinds of things and
our guys really wanted to get a handle
on how many and who had been
worked into their prison system
etc in order to be able to determine
uh in order to determine
um
who uh who might be the subject of a
live-siting report or something well
putting people into the system means
that we can if there are prisoners in
there these guys that went in with the
yachts and so forth we can track them
what we really want to push for is
records of born
apparently the information hasn't gotten
out here yet a little harder
don't worry
it'll be okay
hello
[Music]
oh
now be careful we don't want anybody run
over tell them to be careful we don't
want anybody in the car uh uh
how old is he if i may have seen i'm
saying pepsi
too young he didn't fight in the world
he saw them in central vietnam uh before
1975. oh before 75 when i was living
there
were they part of the military effort
[Music]
um
that's just a short glimpse of what
you'll be seeing tomorrow on c-span our
final day of vietnam revisited it was a
trip to the mekong delta with several
members of the senate select committee
on that tape you saw of course senator
john kerry of massachusetts the chairman
of the committee and his vice chairman
senator bob smith of new hampshire
republican and tomorrow 12 to 5 eastern
time we'll take that trip along with the
members of the committee they were there
in april along with our c-span cameras
and for those of you who are not
familiar with the geography of vietnam
let me show you on the map we have here
a little bit about where this area of
the country was that we were just
showing you and where you'll see
extensively tomorrow again the mekong
delta area is the very southernmost part
of vietnam and the mekong river feeds
into the whole delta area it is right
here on the map we were just in two
places on this piece of
tape the event that you just saw
jacquia which is right in here and also
which is right also in this area here it
dumps into the gulf of thailand that
area of vietnam to give you some
perspective on the
places visited by the senate select
committee along with c-span cameras
their
trip there was to
visit some former bases also to do some
early investigation on some live
sightings as part of their fact-finding
overall on the pow-m-i-a issue tomorrow
on c-span again five hours our final day
of our re-air of vietnam revisited we
have time now to open up our telephone
lines for your calls and comments and
this segment once again is open phones
which means no guest in our studio just
an opportunity for you to
voice your opinion make an observation
or comment your feelings on this
particular issue and we'll take our
first call which is from palm desert
california
hi yes sir i spent 18 months in vietnam
house of greenberg sarge batoon
i like to know what kind of show this is
it's a disgrace for the vietnam veteran
it's just like
you try to
make the president's
north vietnam
hero
i was watching yesterday it sounded like
using hero
all right sir thanks for you you haven't
finished your comments i'll be a jewish
personal
hitler
hero you understand that i understand
your comment and thank you for calling
in and sharing it with us appreciate
your observations
long island new york is next go ahead
yes i'm lee whitmer on long island
uh through a family association with
vietnam over 30 years we find ourselves
sponsoring a vietnamese family
and looking forward to another family
coming soon the question that the
youngsters ask is will we ever get back
to our country i wonder what your
comment would be
i actually will
pass that on to our next guest who is a
former vietnamese national who is now an
american citizen living and working in
the u.s so let's get his opinions during
our next program when we have a guest in
the studio
uh warwick rhode island you're on for
open phones what's your comment please
uh well i haven't i've been watching the
same thing now going on three three days
and i hold the silver star from vietnam
and i haven't seen nothing about the
central highlands where i was stationed
at
like the lot or anything like that
well tell me a little bit about what you
think about this whole issue we've been
exploring here about what's next for u.s
and vietnam well i i think the embargo
should be lifted
first of all because i have nothing
against the people over there it was the
the worst part of it was how i was
treated when i got home
you know
and i i really think that those
armies they should be helped out
you know i really think they should i'm
willing to spend 125
you know all right sir thanks very much
that's rhode island about that
particular area of the country might say
that our trip there was very short and
the major reason for going was to
accompany the senate select committee on
where they were going and then we also
had a base in hanoi so not an
opportunity to show the entire country
we hope we can get back in the future
and explore a little bit more
and show
the many millions of people in this
country who have an interest in in
vietnam
some other parts of it as well this is
our last call for open phones and it is
from orange county california
yes
my name is dean
sir can i interrupt you for a second
turn down the volume on your tv set your
your volume is up and it's causing a
feedback and we can't understand you as
well
my name is dean and uh i came to this
country in 1980 after being in
eradication camp for three years
uh i just want to mention
for you that during your conversation
with mrs tan she was not elected anymore
i do not share
her view on
president ho chi minh what you call but
i came
after you
in late april june to vietnam on a
united mission
uh on the economic united mission and i
see that
the country is very poor and
if we can
change the embargo it will help the
country to open
a little bit more and
help the
what mr webb told about the equal
treatment for the former vietnamese
people working for the government of
vietnam
that's my two comments all right sir i
will compliment you for the balance
uh what you call program thank you very
much appreciate your comments caller was
from orange county california
we have
next to show you the metropole hotel
which is in downtown hanoi if you've
been watching our program you've heard
some discussion of it you may have seen
some footage of it earlier on
this hotel in hanoi is a joint venture
partially partially owned by the french
as well as the vietnamese
and in our next segment we will be
talking with the general manager of that
property a bit about his operating a
business in hanoi let's take a look
[Music]
mr ricardo perron general manager of the
metropol hotel here in hanoi
how did this hotel get here how this
hotel get here it's a long story in fact
and
i think the negotiations took about more
than two years
and as far as management companies
concerned the group occurred
and we we came on board the name in
november so we are just three months and
a half to open this hotel
how many rooms do you have 109 rooms and
we forecast an extension of
let's say about 150 units between hotel
rooms and apartments starting mid 92.
how long have you been open
since march 8th
and are you full
yes
we are food what does it cost the night
to stay here oh nice to stay here let's
say we had a special price for this soft
opening and our regular rates are
starting from 115 u.s there is 240.
is that the most expensive room in hanoi
yes because we are the first
international hotel chain
and we are
let's say
uh
roughly nine with the floating hotel in
saigon another general adventure
do you have do you own part of the
floating hotel in saigon two years
is that partly the part of this company
uh no not at all not at all
and where do you come from i am coming
from
i was born in france and uh living in
canada since more than ten years now so
i am a french afghanistan and with the
group accord i was in canada working for
them and
i was in china recently i came to open
this hotel has this been a hard thing to
do open this hotel here
you know an opening is not an easy
matter in
any countries but i should stay here of
course it was not easy but
we could not have opened this hotel in
three months it's without a good
cooperation and understanding of the
vietnamese of partners
why do you think a hotel will work now
in hanoi
um
i'm sorry justin why do you think a
hotel will be successful today versus
say a couple years ago
um but you know the age of vietnam is
taking off and uh definitely we need
we need hotels like that and not only at
the four or five stars level but also at
the mid scale level
why because the business would be
increasing more and more and vietnam is
a kind of a country when
where there is room for tourism what's
been the hardest part of opening up the
hotel the hardest part in fact
starting let's say from scratch it's to
find
the right people but we could say that
um
more than 95 percent of our staff have
no experience at all
how many of your staff here are
vietnamese no let's say 200.
and how many do you have on your staff
altogether uh 230.
until you've had to train the vietnamese
yes
has it been hard
not
not so much why because these people are
ready to listen ready to learn and
they are very reactive and
and they show us
their will to do well
have you had many americans stay here uh
that's starting definitely we could say
that sixty percent of our clientele is
coming from asia and forty percent
between europe and north of america and
who actually owns the hotel um
let's say it's a joint venture sixty
percent on the vietnamese part forty
percent on the foreign pop and how does
that work i mean how do you split the
profits on that
uh like uh john ventura
yes
it's normally managed and
do you have total control over the
management yes
and the profit then if there is a profit
goes the 60 goes to the vietnamese
government yes
but first we have to meet our financial
requirements because
this project has costed about 9 million
u.s dollars and
we can say that the financial
financial
part is
very important how long has the metropol
hotel been in this location
not the new one but the old one that's
the old one i think is
is the construction of this hotel
is from
1911 i would say one of the things you
keep reading about
the metropole before it was renovated
was that people that stayed here used to
see rats all the time
okay but that was not there but you're
right and
what did you do to get rid of the rats i
was not there also but imagine they have
destroyed everything and to clear
all this um
so what if somebody comes here say
they're wanting to come to hanoi to do
business what's available can they make
telephone calls directly back to the
united states it's coming definitely and
in the coming uh let's say coming week
we should be able for the guests from
the rooms to phone directly
from their rooms what other available uh
facilities facilities of course we have
idd line we will have a business center
swimming pool one bar one restaurant we
have a tv satellite tv
what kind of programs do you bring here
from hong kong for the moment but we
could get some other programs it's up to
us to have a lot more receivers and what
about cnn is that we could get we could
get just to have the proper receiver and
perhaps to change
the the position of the satellite do you
know of anybody coming to this country
in this city to do a competitive hotel
a new one anybody playing
it won't be before let's say two two
years and a half to have um
um that's a project completed it takes
about two two years and a half or three
years so the next one coming on board
will be let's say 1995. you know of
anybody that's already announced that
they're going to come in in 1995 has
anybody said they're going to build a
new hotel
anybody else uh
any other company oh yes of course you
have already no chimin and of course it
will be coming in hanoi
what about the embargo the united states
embargo on trade will that make a
difference if that's ever lifted for
your hotel oh man definitely yes
why
because of course i think
the take off the economical takeoff of
vietnam will be at a higher speed
next year definitely
thank you very much
okay
um
vietnam revisited continues
in 1977 vietnam became the 149th member
of the united nations
it's one of the poorest countries in the
world with a per capita income of one
hundred thirty dollars a year
blue collar workers in vietnam earn
about thirty dollars per month with
professionals earning half that amount
just ahead street scenes from the former
french quarter in downtown hanoi around
the sword lake
so
[Music]
oh
okay
okay
[Music]
so
me
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
oh
[Music]
wow
baby
[Music]
go
oh
wow
is
okay
[Applause]
me
um
why
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
come here
[Music]
[Music]
would you describe the current state of
relations between your homeland vietnam
and your new country the united states
right now
well i think right now everybody's
talking about it's being on the verge of
normalization now what it means is under
the one hand we have the road map which
is defined by the united states on the
other hand it depends upon the
conditions that it at which state at
this stage we are not too sure as to how
the elections in cambodia will go for
instance
and then also
the
the united states government have said
that vietnam would have to give a good
pretty good accounting satisfactory one
about the mia pow question
how do you personally react respond to
the
debate over normalization
well personally
i am one of these person who is very
much in between because on the one hand
is my old country and the other hand is
united states on the one hand it's it's
a group
in power that for against whom i fought
yeah
and so of course somebody like that
would have to be very much caught in
between
i think that everybody is for uh
normalization if it means that it brings
about a certain amount of
liberty and freedom for the
vietnamese people i think the vietnamese
have been denied that for so long that i
think it's a it's to the point that
if we have any division at all in the
vietnamese community united states it
has it it falls on that point is that
how much
guarantee should we have so that all our
prisoners
not only those who are re-education camp
but now
uh religious leaders writers
intellectuals uh businessman
ethnic minority people of which there's
still tens of thousands in in jail for
really no particular reason
uh there for instance father chanting
two who is now
86
and when a british parliamentarian asked
the vietnamese ambassador in london why
is he still in jail
they were given the explanation that
he's represented a threat to the
national security of vietnam
these are the type of questions things
that that put vietnam in very much
it has a credibility gap right there
elliot tiden you represent one u.s
company northwest airlines and we've
been talking a lot about the trade
embargo u.s trade embargo
what does it mean right now what does
when there is an embargo what's the full
extent of it what's the impact
it means that there can be no and i
underline the word no commercial
relationships of any kind with the
country of vietnam or any citizens of
vietnam or any of
any possible agents of the country of
vietnam
and as a result
for northwest airlines for example we
cannot
fly directly into vietnam
we are allowed now to help arrange
travel into vietnam that was a recent
loosening of the embargo applicable to
travel into and out of vietnam but in
terms of having direct commercial
relationships with vietnam they are
absolutely prohibited
the only way we can carry people into
and out of vietnam is via a connection
with the vietnamese airline in bangkok
which would be air vietnam but the
subject is very much under debate right
now in this country the the subject is
very much under debate there are many
countries there are many companies who
are very interested in restoring
commercial relationships with vietnam
northwest airlines certainly is one of
them other u.s airlines also are
interested in resuming service to
vietnam of course consistent with what
the united states government's policies
are and and consistent with achievement
of the objectives of the road map that
mr bick was speaking about but yes we
are very much interested we have an
application on file with uh u.s
aeronautical authorities to permit
restoration of service by northwest
vietnam which agencies or branches of
government have responsibility for
deciding the question
primarily the u.s department of
transportation but in a case such as
vietnam with great sensitivity it would
also be the department of state and
to a lesser extent the department of
treasury which administers the embargo
regulations congress have any role
i'm sure that the administration would
consult with the congress about
something as sensitive as restoration of
relations with vietnam but the congress
doesn't have any direct statutory or
administrative role in restoring air
service for example mr pick i want to
take a few minutes out and introduce you
uh to our audience uh you your homeland
is a vietnam you came to the united
states when and under what circumstances
well in 1975 as a refugee from vietnam
and
could you tell me a little bit about how
you got here and where you first arrived
well
yeah i got here because
i left
saigon only someday like about 10 hours
before the
comedies came into town
and we went out to see
and our ideas basically just to go out
to see
we didn't know where we'd land we have
no idea who's big to get us up but we
are lucky to be picked up by an american
cargo boat it's called american
challenger
and
the there's no
there's no real
living facility since it's a cargo boat
the capacity i understood was something
like 1100 people in the end they pick up
7 500 people so standing room only under
the sun and the rain and everything over
the pacific and we we after seven days
and nine
and eight nights we landed in guam
in on the 7th of may
1975.
from guam
we stayed there to process our paper and
then we went to another transit camp on
the us continent that is in eglin air
force base in florida and then i came up
to this area mainly because i had family
here so
when you come here to a country
panelists i think you have to depend on
families and friends
you are now a u.s citizen i am now u.s
citizen i'm the acting director of the
office of bilingual education at the u.s
department of education when did you
attain your citizenship
well it was in 1980 because after five
years of permanent residency was that a
difficult decision for you
uh to acidic extensive because i have to
be very honest that when i prepare my
life i first came united states way back
in the 1950s and 56 on a fulbright
scholarship to go to princeton
university
and all my studies and everything were
certainly done with the purpose of of
helping vietnam
you know develop and then
reach
you know catch up with the 20th century
if not the 21st century so
it's a whole reorganizing restructuring
of your life that you need to go through
in order to make it here and then
eventually
become a good and productive citizens of
this country we have some
tape that we'd like to roll to show you
saigon and show our viewers saigon i'd
like to get your impressions because
that was where you lived right uh in
fact you should tell our audience that
for a time you served as acting
chancellor of mekong university located
in saigon but let's show you saigon 1992
and maybe you can tell us a bit about
your impressions as you watch this
this is the andong market in saigon
what does it look like with regard to
prosperity and economic conditions as
you look at this
well i understand andong has uh has
expanded quite a bit and so as far as
the uh
economic um how they call prosperity or
at least the the affluence of
saigon now
there's no doubt about that i think
that's a the glaring difference between
vietnam and many of the eastern european
country and even the soviet union where
i was in 1990
so
that
is owed definitely to the economic
so-called emilia and renovation that
came in 1986 after the comments realized
how much of a failure the earlier
collectivization
policy
you know had uh
uh
had done to the country what do you have
a sense of what general living
conditions would be like for someone in
saigon today
it's a pretty good it's pretty good
although it's a
it's a catch as you can
situation because
it much of it is done in a kind of half
zone of legality and illegality it's not
it's not that everything is thoroughly
illegal and because uh like in many
communist countries
there's a lot of
amnesty of barriers
that
you either have to bribe your way
through or
you know use use
extra legalistic
actual legal measures in order to uh to
do it but i guess there is a question of
atmosphere so the atmosphere is that in
saigon this thing now is accepted and
it's catching up even in the north so
you see a certain amount of hanoi
coming alive too it's not just a
question of science what is the primary
industry how do people generally make
their living well the primary industry
of saigon has a hinterland which is the
mekong delta so um
rice is definitely one of the big
smaller to make things it flows through
saigon for export and rice is one of the
great earning
merchandise of vietnam now
then the
saigon is a little bit like hong kong is
that it's a manufacturing
center
so that people do a lot of things like
um they
they take
clothings materials things like that and
and make suits and things like that
that's what sell
especially you sell quite a lot in the
eastern european market and then
there's a lot of other things that flows
through saigon
coffee rubber
there's only a few things that are that
do not exactly throw through saigon
which are big areas of vietnam like the
oil industry or or
the marine products
is it a country of both rich and poor
very much now in saigon in fact
that's a concern expressed by the
government in vietnam inviting a lot of
people in the papers because with the
liberalization some people could afford
it and then i guess
you have to be a little bit willing to
live with that kind of uh
uh of world
where
you have to depend a great deal on your
connection and things like that if you
don't have any connections if you have
not a great deal of capital of course
you're very very poor
and uh one of the things that you see
that is that
the large gap that's just forming right
now yeah have you been back
no but i have a lot of contact with
vietnam
at one point i used to run a vietnamese
language
radio broadcasting program here in town
and so i had to read
up i'm familiar with practically all the
publications in vietnam and then all the
people who come out i talk to them or
sometimes i call
friends on the telephone
since the resumption of
telecommunications you've been
interested in going back to visit i i do
at some point uh where things
clear up a little bit yeah would you
ever see yourself living there again not
uh not in the present conditions yeah
the the government would have to change
and the whole economic
i'm saying is that the government
is if you're talking about government
being a number of people and things like
that i they think that matters so much
as
you have real
freedom so that you do not feel
threatened
uh what the the situation of vietnam now
is that on the one hand the paper talks
a lot about this economic situation
which is improving clearly and and
vietnam is is getting more and more
investment from abroad although there's
some problems there on the other hand
there's the other
which is the political aspect of it
which is just as repressive as ever
our goal during this program here is to
talk about economic issues and future
relations issues and in a bit we will
open up our telephone lines for your
questions from around the country our
two guests uh mr bick and elliot seiden
whom we will turn to to learn a bit more
about
your perspective on this
if if you if the embargo were lifted
what would happen next with regard to
your interests in the country
we would immediately or as soon as we
felt economically prudent to restore
service uh petition the
various agencies of our government for
permission to fly to vietnam that would
require various regulatory
procedures at primarily the department
of transportation and once those
procedures were finished and we were
given a license is called a certificate
of public convenience and necessity
then we would be free to commence
operations to vietnam
must you then get clearance from the
government to land is that an aspect of
it as well it's part and parcel of it
the the restoration of air service
requires not only a domestic license
from u.s regulatory authorities it also
requires an agreement of some sort
between the two governments there are
two ways governments can agree one they
can agree simply to allow planes to fly
on a basis of comedy and reciprocity
another way which is more prevalent in
the world is for the governments
actually to negotiate and sign a treaty
an air services treaty which prescribes
all of the terms by which airlines of
both sides may fly in and out
either way would be sufficient for
northwest and other airlines interested
in serving vietnam to fly how many other
u.s airlines are also interested in
vietnam we know
from public statements that united
airlines is i haven't heard uh
expressions of interest from other
airlines so the only ones i'm aware of
so far are united in ourselves where
would you land what would the airport be
that you use probably the airport in ho
chi minh city
formerly saigon yes do you have have you
been to vietnam no i have not do you
have any sense of what the facilities
are like there
the we know that the airport is
sufficient to take the uh the size
planes that we would want to operate we
have in fact flown
um
our largest aircraft 747s into vietnam
in 1991 we were fortunate enough to
become associated with the in with the
international organization of migration
um which was assisting with the with the
orderly departure program from vietnam
and in the months of june july august
and september of 1991 we were able to
operate a charter flight once a week
into and out of vietnam between ho chi
minh city and bangkok and so through
that program we did get a familiarity
with the facilities and they're
certainly adequate enough to handle
anything we would want to do so i
understand that period that was the
orderly departure of refugees yes from
from vietnam and cambodia as well it was
primarily vietnam
and the refugees i think primarily were
destined for the united states although
that's no there's no requirement about
where they go we still do
through
interline arrangements with air vietnam
at bangkok carry almost 2 000 uh emma
grays a month uh from vietnam to the
united states so at that time were the
are you the only were you the only us
carrier operating at all in any capacity
yes we this was the only time since 1975
that a u.s flag
air carrier set set down on vietnamese
territory
what kind of
i don't know if you know at this point
what kind of restrictions or
requirements would you have doing
business in vietnam with regard to
your profits uh taxation of those uh
requirement of using um local citizens
as employees in your company
any of those circumstances we don't have
any idea at all how that might sort out
in in many countries around the world
those kinds of what we call in the
airline industry doing business problems
do materialize
and one would hope that there would not
be significant doing business problems
but there are in various countries
repatriation of funds problems and
taxation problems the one you've the
ones you've mentioned but because we've
not been able to do any kind of
serious exploration of restoration of
air services yet we don't know what what
awaits us in those respects what kind of
a market would it be for you what are
you expecting with regards to business
we
we
kind of identify three market segments
one is certainly we we have a population
in the united states of almost a million
vietnamese immigrants
we
we expect that there are a lot of people
who miss their families and would like
to get back and visit
that's a fairly significant population
we certainly expect business to come
from that sector secondly we do expect
um
business people
to become interested in a variety of
business ventures in vietnam
and the vietnamese are very
entrepreneurial industrious people and
we would expect that once
normalization occurs
that there would be a very rapid buildup
of business activity between u.s
industry and vietnamese industry and we
would be in a position to carry those
people on our airplanes now you say once
normalization occurs the number of
people that we've talked to over the
past couple of days have
not said
not if but when and is that what you
believe as well yes i do believe that
normalization is inevitable
my guess about when it might occur is
not any more valuable than anybody
else's but i but i do feel it's
inevitable would you explain to me about
i guess the level of controversy or
sensitivity this question of
normalization has for company a us-based
company in 1992
well
it's
on the one hand we want to be in a
position to take advantage of a valuable
commercial opportunity on the other hand
it's very important that we not be
insensitive nor appear to be insensitive
to the important issues that have
prevented normalization from occurring
particularly the issue of of resolving
once and for all
the pow mia problem and so we we would
want to make it very clear that
we don't have any interest in serving
vietnam until that issue is is is
satisfied
to the satisfaction of really everyone
involved in it
for both of you a response to a caller
that i had just before you came in it
was an open phone segment who was a
vietnam veteran who and who suggested
that the discussion of this alone does
disservice to the many people that lost
their life in the co in the vietnam
conflict would you respond to that
well i think
even some very painful issues sometimes
still need to be discussed
otherwise you know you
personally i prefer discussion
to uh having to fight it out or
something like that and uh with the
world the whole world you know just
shifting around us
we need to
assess even let's say even if
normalization is not happening uh we
still need to discuss vietnam because
precisely because vietnam is such an
important part of the recent history of
the united states
uh you do not you just cannot wish a
problem away
mr said
well i guess i would say that
um we we have managed to find ways of of
reconciling ourselves with a number of
countries with whom we have been enemies
over the years and now some of those
countries are are among are counted
among our closest allies and
although feelings run deep and
legitimately so
still a way must be found for us to
eliminate
old hatreds and reconcile ourselves
and i think that
a lot of time has gone by it's been
almost 20 years since the fall of saigon
and i think ways must be found for us to
finally reconcile ourselves and
and restore normal relations with
vietnam i want to take a minute out and
give you the telephone numbers a few
more minutes yet before we go to calls
but let me give the numbers so that if
you have a question or comment you can
begin dialing you live in the eastern or
central time zones the number here at
c-span is 202-628-2525
if you live in the mountain or pacific
time zones it's 202-783-2727
and if you have called us in the past
we're going to ask you
if you've called us within the past a
month hold off let other people have
their opportunity to participate we have
very busy phone lines during this
program and want to get as many people
as possible especially people haven't
watched c-span in the past and are
experiencing our call-in programs the
first time give them an opportunity to
get through
i have another piece of tape this time
of hanoi um but i just want to show it
not particularly talk about hanoi so
much is to talk to you a little bit more
about the number of the vietnamese
people currently living in the united
states we learned earlier from mr seiden
there's a million
almost a million and what parts of the
united states are there large population
centers well the largest constitution is
definitely california which accounts for
about 40 percent of the vietnamese
population united states
the second largest states would be texas
and then followed by places like
washington state
illinois new york and in this area this
area which is always
give impression is under count because
it really split into three
three states you know dc maryland
virginia
but actually the community live as a
whole as one community rather than three
split up groups
what kind of people generally were
successful in immigrating what what i
guess class of society is there any
distinction at all of all kinds of folks
no uh in the first wave in the in the
spring of 1975 was mostly people who are
pretty well placed in the government and
in the military
who had contacted united states who had
exposure to the west who knew a foreign
language and so on so forth were
educated but
even then even in 1975 there was also a
small group of people who were just
plain fishermen
who happened to be near the sea and
therefore who saw an opportunity and
they came here and also became very very
successful
and then in 1978 because there's uh this
the policy of attack the the vietnamese
wood is really attacked the capitalists
so
they closed the 35 000 enterprises in
one day
and
and so a lot of people some people
took their own lives other people
scraped whatever they could and then
fled and in that particular group
there's a lot of chinese vietnamese
because the chinese population in
vietnam was mostly engaged in business
not so much in the academic field or in
government
but then later on you have also other
people so that out of the million
vietnamese now united states you find
not only just the upper custody of the
society
but also a great many businessmen a fair
amount of fishermen and farmers
and not just simply people from south
vietnam
people from north vietnam where they got
a chance to and especially in february
of 1979
when there was a fight between china and
and north vietnam uh
you know almost 400 000 north vietnamese
also left the country after
30 some years of under communism and of
those who didn't hear too much mainly
because about a quarter million of them
are now in
china and china is interested very much
now in returning those and vietnam
doesn't particularly care for
you
the resettlement here in the united
states you've mentioned a couple times
that
that people were very successful was it
an easy transition
it's never easy you know when you go
into another country and
you you look different you don't speak
the language the culture is different
the religions are different everything
is different so it certainly cannot be
very very simple process on the other
hand as mr science just said the
vietnamese are known to be a very
enterprising active
kind of population
and so we're willing
to to undergo all this difficulty in
order to to make it in a new society and
i guess that's the motivation besides
any immigrants group not just the
vietnamese the jewish the irish what
have you in the past you see exactly the
same pattern when you're faced with
some very very uh tough uh decision you
just will take it you don't have too
much choice right there and uh so
besides that the the the vietnamese have
done a little bit better i think partly
because we still have a very much
community based society one which is the
family comes together and try to go
through difficult times together and
that helps very much
if the vietnamese are in fact a very
entrepreneurial very successful people
what's the base basis for that where
does it come from
gee that's a difficult one
i think probably because of the
challenges we have
we have been faced with throughout
history
the chinese
this is one thing the vietnamese learn
is that
never differentiate among the chinese
they all are like in many
to the vietnamese in this sense in the
center every time china becomes strong
we were under the manchu the mongols
under the chinese under the communism or
any other form of government
each time china becomes strong the vlbs
get invaded once twice three times so uh
so in order to survive and keep our own
uh
our own identity we just have to face
this kind of enormous challenge
we are about ready to go to calls new
and yuck bic our guest who is now deputy
director of the office of bilingual
education and minority language affairs
at the u.s department of education been
in that post since 1991
and eliot sidon who is vice president of
law and government affairs for northwest
airlines been in that position since
1990 to the president present his
airlines is interested if the trade
embargo is lifted in
doing business in vietnam having landing
rights and regular routes to vietnam
your airlines flew regularly to vietnam
at any point in in past
during the entirety of the conflict
northwest airlines was one of the major
airlines that was supporting the
military effort through a program called
the military airlift command or mac and
at the height of our participation in
that program we had 10 airplanes
dedicated exclusively to the military
logistical support effort so we have a
long uh history of serving vietnam for
many of the vietnam veterans who are
watching this program will remember the
mack flights the mac flights and as will
the persian gulf war veterans because
that was also part of the effort to get
the troops to uh absolutely
the u.s the u.s scheduled airlines
carries 65 of all the troops to and from
the persian gulf so you're right let's
take our first telephone call for our
guest waynesville missouri you're on the
air
hello susan this dave lay thank you very
much for taking my call
um
first of all i'd like to say that i've
enjoyed your programming very much and
and we
i feel very
deeply that it's time that we do
reestablish normal relations with
vietnam
i had three tours in vietnam during the
war
i felt quite different at that time than
i do now obviously
i would also like to congratulate c-span
though on your
ability to
show an even-handed
type of
perspective on
relations i thought the programming of
having mr webb follow mr chad was
beautiful
it's hard for someone like me to
appreciate the position of someone like
mr chad
getting his
citizenship
so-called re-established
without having ever had the opportunity
to pay his dues
thank you thanks very much
uh since that wasn't a question we'll
just move on to our next which is from
satellite beach florida you're on the
air
uh yes um
yeah i see you people have gone back to
vietnam and that but i'm also wondering
if you're ever gonna go back to laos and
talk about uh laos people and everything
all right thanks very much um
i guess i'm gonna turn that over to you
mr sutton with regard to the economic
question do you know anything about laos
and what current status our countries
have we we really haven't had an
opportunity to do any uh any serious
economic investigation of
of air service to laos and so no my own
information kind of stops at the
vietnamese border
and for c-span no immediate plans this
is our first opportunity to get to that
part of the world and
i from the response from viewers and our
own interest in learning a great deal
through this one trip i hope we do get
an opportunity to explore more there
let's take another telephone call san
bruno california
yeah uh good morning good afternoon
actually uh i have a question for the
gentleman who's headed the northwest
airline
um
if
vietnam and america is normalized are
you planning to
have a hub
over there and is it gonna run by
uh vietnamese or is it gonna run by
uh the people
over here
we have several ideas under
consideration
in terms of our own air service into
vietnam
i would expect that it would not be a
hub in vietnam but it would rather be a
spoke off our hub in tokyo's narita
airport or perhaps our operations in
seoul korea
we now serve
between tokyo and bangkok thailand and
when we ran our charter flights into
vietnam we ran them via bangkok it is
possible we would do that as well
as for a more extensive participation
in air service in vietnam it is possible
that we would be interested in a joint
venture operation with the local carrier
in vietnam
to provide technical uh and operational
and marketing support for their own
operations through a joint venture and
so in that sense if we did become
involved with air vietnam that way
and it is under consideration
then then we would be involved in a hub
operation in vietnam
take a call and then we will listen to
senator john kerry of massachusetts
talking about the economic embargo
houston you're on the air yes uh
this is directly to the vietnamese
gentleman i understand that when you
came to the united states you were
getting given some aid for settlement by
the united states
and i had heard that it was uh
25 000 in cash and five years exemption
from income tax and i'm curious about
this i was wondering if you could give
us an outline exactly what you were
afforded when you came here well i have
yet to see this uh 25 000
if you really
wanted to know in my particular case my
family
got housing help
for two months
and then we were on our own and that's
the extent of the help that i got in
1975
yes there have been others who have been
here who had to stay longer on welfare
but at no point anywhere
do we get 25 000 cash
question for you we had a caller again
earlier without without a guest here uh
a woman who was uh sponsoring a
vietnamese family and the little girl
she asked wanted to know when she might
be able to go back to vietnam if one
wants simply to go at this point can you
absolutely no no restrictions whatsoever
if you are a former vietnamese citizen
can you go back no restriction
whatsoever in the sense that the only
the only
i think caution that you have is that
united states is still not represented
diplomatically in vietnam so if anything
happens to you as it has happened time
time to
vietnamese going back to vietnam then it
will take much longer for the united
states to come and intervene on your
behalf
but
right now the situation is such that the
vietnamese government needs very much
your dollars and therefore is willing to
look the other way and give you as
little problem as possible earlier this
week senator john kerry who chairs the
senate select committee on pow mia
affairs
joined us by satellite as part of our
vietnam revisited program we asked him
about the economic
embargo let's listen to his response
senator smith was with us by phone
earlier senator kerry and he says that
the vietnamese and the oceans are
holding up on some information that he
said until access
uh better access is given
that uh the vietnam trade embargo that
the united states the united states
trade embargo with vietnam should
continue what's your opinion on that
well i don't think it i mean the issue
at the center of of the pow mia
resolution is has nothing to do really
with the trade embargo that's a
different political question
and my own personal belief is that the
united states would be aided and i
underline we would be aided
in getting the answers to the plwmia
issue
if we were to
perhaps lift portions
of the embargo
as we go down the road here building a
stronger relationship
i
absolutely want to distinguish and i
want every listener to carefully
distinguish
the difference between
lifting a portion of an embargo
in an effort to show good faith in this
process
as distinguished from normalization
i am not and no member of our committee
is advocating normalization which means
full embassy uh full uh recognition
imf loans credits a whole lot of other
advantages that go with it we're not
talking about that we're really talking
about building the relationship
building trust so that we can get the
answers that we want and ultimately
vietnam
can secure some of the needs that it has
mr seiden from a business perspective
what's your reaction to that
well from we we have to take our leads
from the government and and we're trying
very hard to do that we we can't nor
should we get out in front
of the government
it may be possible for us to do business
in uh in a regime that is something less
than normalization but but
involves the lifting of the embargo if
it were possible for us to do that and
if we had the blessing of the government
then we would consider going in under
those circumstances
from the sense of a an elected official
or politician
distinguishing the two issues they are
two very distinct issues politically uh
senator kerry said the pow issue and the
embargo from the practicality of a
business person are they
well
yes i think they are
northwest airlines for example needs
to have a certain legal and regulatory
regime available to it to be able to do
business and if the united states
government authorizes us to go that far
then we can do business i must say it is
difficult for an airline to try to do
business in a country that doesn't have
a u.s embassy
international airline operations are
very complicated and frequently become
politically difficult
and without having your own government's
representatives on the scene it can be
can be quite difficult so that would be
an issue for us if if there were no
diplomatic relations but the government
was saying you can go in but you're on
your own
we might have to say it's too risky mr
vick you're nodding your head at that
something you agree with
yeah very much so
because i think that uh that's why you
know
the argument right now in vietnam
reaching even i'm right inside the
communist party is this question is that
one party uh that is the conservative
that said okay liberalization yes but
only economically no political
liberalization and there's a smaller
group of people who are deliberate who
said
impossible you have these two things
have to go together
just as mr seiden said
or the earlier example the vietnamese
tourist if he goes back there you're on
your own
and anything happens to you there's no
way they can be represented your
interests can be represented so these
two things will have to be go hand in
hand it just cannot you know you just
cannot
just say the same person you just cannot
have a face and not a back you know
jacksonville florida
you're on the air
hello yes sir what's your comment
jacksonville uh yes miss wayne uh this
is from mr big there i'm a vietnam
veteran yes i've done quite a few tours
over there all over vietnam
and uh everybody wants to open uh
business with vietnam the u.s should do
this and u.s should do that
everybody says what the u.s should do
for vietnam what can vietnam do for the
us f with that open relations
well i think the answer is very simple
the united states have made it very
clear that is concerned about several
things one is vietnam should help
resolve the cambodian situation
two
vietnam should help resolve satisfactory
the pow
mia questions and then three uh which is
comes like in stage four of the road map
is that we do want to see
some uh
minimal respect of human rights
democracy and such things in vietnam so
the united in vietnam in order to you
know respond to the united states
overture
we'll have to deliver on these issues
these are only
one of the things i think
from the economic point of view yes
vietnam has a certain amount of
resources
that
the oil industries are interested in
northwest and others because the
infrastructure in vietnam is so
is so disrupted that there's a lot of
opportunity or business opportunity
there the only thing is that
these things you have to go hand in hand
with some political conditions
if i may bring in laos here and quickly
and it is you see
the relationship between the united
states and laos are much better than
relationship between united states and
vietnam even now
and yet the lao have yet to deliver any
single
information on the three of
573
mias in laos and that's that's
incredible that out of that number
there's no one who's surviving
canyon city colorado hello miss wayne
and you mr seiden uh
i had a question about the mountain yard
tribes people in vietnam the 31 tribes
of mountain yards and and as you know mr
bick
the vietnamese government has really
persecuted these people over the years
and absolutely and i wonder uh
mr seiden and mr bick what your feelings
are about normalizing relations until
they are
the mountain yards are treated in a
humanitarian way
as well as clearing up the pow issue
somewhat
i couldn't agree with you more that the
the treatment of montana is part of the
whole human rights
issues broader human rights issues in
vietnam
we have right in north carolina here a
group mutanya who came here now there
are about 200 of them although they left
the vietnam
4800 strong but the vietnamese companies
you know went after them and killed them
so much so that by the time they got out
of vietnam there's only 200 people left
out of 4 800 people and these men women
children really try to flee vietnam
right now the some of the biggest
problems that vietnam has now is not so
much in south vietnam yes there's still
the full role that is the the montana
resistance group in south vietnam but in
north vietnam now that that the
vietnamese government is having the most
trouble now with the hmong and some
other groups
for two reasons a party because the they
are nomadic people and the vietnamese
government wants them to become
sedentary and so they resist that very
much and what they resist that they get
they get discriminated against and
sometimes persecuted sometimes even
exterminated and then another thing too
is for some reason in recent years many
of these montana in north vietnam
particular have have taken on
christianity you know suddenly all of a
sudden they said there's a revival of
christianity among their
these people and the vietnamese
government didn't like that at all and
therefore again persecuted them for
religious region as well and this is
brought out in another amnesty
international uh
uh report in june of this year mr sutton
that question was also addressed to you
does your company have an interest in
human rights issues that's connected to
this policy of course we're we're we're
all american citizens first and business
people second and we have a strong
interest in that um
we support the us government policy
without qualification on
the roadmap policy
i think it might be fair to characterize
the policy as a carrot and stick policy
you you
you want to bring about the result of
respect for human rights and democracy
in vietnam and the real the only issue
is what are the best tactics what is
most likely to bring about the desired
result and and so what the united states
government seems to me is doing is
providing
a taste of benefit of of trade with the
united states
in exchange for
vietnamese change in policy in a lot of
areas including human rights and and i
think that's probably the right policy
clarksville tennessee
uh yes ma'am i'm a vietnam veteran also
i spent four combat tours there
and i also worked at the vietnamese
peace talks in paris
a lot of people don't understand that
out of the 500 000 americans serving in
vietnam less than one-seventh of that
were actual combat soldiers
and
as far as the paoww mia thing goes
a person that was captured in vietnam
stood a lot better chance of living if
he was captured by a north vietnamese
army unit
most uh
clandestine units viet cong units
if they captured soldiers they didn't
live very long
they didn't have time to transport them
and take care of them things like that
because they were constantly on the move
and i think that
this country
is the greatest country on this earth
and
everybody knows that and i think that
we're going to have to
bend just a little bit
because
if you think about the war in general
the vietnamese really didn't do anything
to us
we started that war
we got involved in it it wasn't the
doing of the american soldiers it was
our government's involvement
and
i don't think that would bring any shame
on this country
if we
made some reparations for the damage
that we did to that country we uh
destroyed acreage and agriculture areas
that
they'll never in my lifetime be able to
grow any anything to eat on all right
sir thanks clarksville tennessee mr pick
well i think i have to disagree a little
bit i think on the part of
the question of how generous this
country should be or is i think there's
no doubt that this is a very generous
country you just look at what the united
states did to
germany and japan and many other
defeated countries
it's clear the united states have been
very very generous
the situation of vietnam is
according to the author of that
statement is that
the vietnam haven't done anything i'm
not so sure when it comes to um to the
question of vietnam war
it's it's ho chi minh who brought
communism to vietnam
it's a ho chi minh
test testament that leaves vietnam a
socialist country and that leaves the
vietnam in such a poor
situation so i didn't think that the
united states should take all the blame
but yes any war is destructive
and
with the firepower the united states
have
clearly the order was quite a bit of
destruction of the country on the other
hand we should not exculpate
the
the vietnamese communist side
it's because they they themselves
created a lot of havoc to their own
country
in fact
in recent years and since north vietnam
has been devastated by floods and those
floods were not owed to american
bombings whatsoever it just owed to a
totally indiscriminate
exploitation of the forest land in
vietnam so that it has been creating
this terrible flood whereas in south
vietnam there was a certain amount of
chemical use on the forestry and things
like that but we didn't have any such
floods mr sutton your bio says that you
graduated from college in 1967 which
would put you right into the middle of
the whole debate on this in this country
i remember it well what about your own
personal thoughts or feelings about the
vietnam war have they evolved or changed
over time oh that's a very that's a very
difficult question how many hours do i
have uh yes of course they have um
being in college in uh in those years
the the primary objective or the primary
thought
shifted away from
history and
math and science and to worrying about
the war
and
it was it was truly a preoccupation for
all of us in those years
i i certainly have
have come to have a much deeper and
better understanding than i had then
about what our what our own soldiers and
fighting men were going through
it was a terrible difficult awful ordeal
for them and
made no easier by the way they were
received by our country when they came
home
and i think that generally
most americans feel that that was wrong
and unfortunate and a men's need to be
made
but
i i think that
generally looking back on it
i think we got into the vietnam war out
of the best of impulses and but but we
misread
i think what the true situation was and
what was really going on there and we
probably shouldn't have gotten involved
at all i think that we got involved
because we thought we were
we were saving friends
and and it worked out to the to the
detriment of everyone did you serve
no i was i received my induction notice
and i went to take a physical and i
failed
charlotte north carolina is on the air
next go ahead please
yes thank you i was just calling to say
that it's time that everything gets
healed
all right sir the trade
with the with the country it won't hurt
us
if anything maybe it can heal some more
i mean the war is over were you a
veteran of that war yes i was
all right thank you for participating
this afternoon uh
when we uh earlier talked to a member of
the assembly
now a former member of the assembly
there are elections like
she basically described what they were
working towards was market-oriented
socialism do you believe that the two
things can mix successfully well that's
the kind of semantic games people are
willing to play these days
when you're really talking about a
market economy
one that is relatively without
restrictions you're not going to have
such a thing as market
economy socialism
but
[Music]
you know the newspeak is is nothing uh
new to communism therefore uh the
chinese communists the vietnamese
communities the cuban communists all of
them are claiming now that they are for
the market economy
uh i think mrs moba tying is caught in
exactly the same game herself personally
i understand that that interview took
place in april she certainly was full of
hope that she would be re-elected
and yet
you know the story of the new election
international assembly there's 42
so-called independent
candidates
before the election 40 of them
were either retired or found to be
illegal or in some way
not fitting for it so there's only two
who actually ran of the two actually ran
they also lost so in the end it's
beautifully 100
communist composition of the national
assembly and right after that mrs
mubatang herself is is the one who has
given a very famous um
interview to bbc where she said the
whole thing was rigid and it's totally
illegal and things like that so she's
caught in her own game does the
political system at the other end matter
to you with regards to doing business
oh very much so um we have found it much
more difficult to succeed in
economies that are
managed very tightly in a in a political
economic system of the type that vietnam
appears to still have
they tend governments like that tend to
have very tight currency controls
tend to clamp down very much on
the regulation of the movement of funds
and it's more difficult to do business
in that kind of an environment
the next uh scenes we will show you are
from hanoi and this is uh street scenes
and market in hanoi but you will see in
this quite a lot of american goods
why is that
well strangely enough
despite all the ills that we hear about
the american economy and all this kind
of thing american
goods and commodities are still very
much appreciated abroad if you know that
even president ho chi minh himself you
know never could give up his permal uh
cigarettes then
i think there's something to say for the
uh for the capitalist society that we're
living in so how do they get there how
do these goods get there well the black
market and this was the thing that i was
referring to earlier all these extra
legal half legal cmy legal whatever it
is it's never fully legal uh but um
nothing nothing holds them back the
simple reason is that the whole system
is entirely corrupt from the top to the
end
fort collins colorado your question
please yeah i was going to ask the
gentleman from
vietnam why we should uh you know
maintain our uh
you know our embargo on vietnam based on
a criteria of human rights when those
human rights were not extended to the
communists after 1954.
in fact i think there was like a reign
of terror against the communist
party in south vietnam after that
yes
well there was a time where the mudisim
government which is the first republic
in south vietnam uh did
did try to bring the the communists to
trial and all these kind of things
but people tend to exaggerate that on
the other hand forget such thing as the
land reform
which took to something like 50 000
lives by the by the minimal
assessment
uh
50 000 lives in a matter of three years
which is incredible because the
vietnamese had a war against france
which lasted eight years
and out of these eight years 42 the
vietnamese lost 42 000 lives
whereas in three years of peace
throughout the land reform
the communists put through
the sword 50 000 people and they are
vietnamese and so you know what are you
talking about human rights and all this
kind of thing you have to keep all of
that in
in perspective the same thing with the
communists when they came into hawaii in
1968
when they when they left the cities
they killed
about 6 000 people then we still had the
mass grave to
to show that so
you know there are human rights
violations here and there
but we all have to keep all that in
perspectives new york city
yes hello there i would like to address
mr seiden
about the policies of commercial air
flights
flying into the benoit area in 1968
i was on one of those commercial flights
and i had to hover around so to speak
the airfield because the airfield was
under attack and i was just curious in a
light sense
any of those stewardesses received
hazardous duty pay
i don't know at the time
in 1968 i was in law school
and i don't really
know what was going on
i don't think they were receiving
hazardous duty pay however those were
the military air command flights you
were talking about earlier what we found
uh in our recent persian gulf war
experience is that the the employees
who who actually work the aircraft the
pilots and the flight attendants
feel a great bonding with the with the
men and women who they're delivering to
a war zone
they they feel they experience
tremendous emotional experiences when
they watch
these young men and women get off the
planes because they know some of them
may not be coming back and
there was an over subscription that is
the men and women of northwest were
standing in line to be able to serve on
those flights of the persian gulf and i
rather suspect it was like that in the
60s as well lakeland florida
yes this is k.r bonahan yes sir i went
back to vietnam with permission for the
vietnamese government in
february and march
and we were allowed to film all the
battle sites
which we didn't complete yet
i was wondering uh
would mr ceden's company be interested
in
possibly helping some of these
post-traumatic syndrome victims
as far as lower prices
yes i i think that
one of the areas that we would regard as
as
part of what our opportunity would be in
vietnam would be
providing opportunities for service men
and women to go back we we suspect there
are
many many of them who will want to do
that
and
we we work with veterans groups now
there's a there has been there's been a
tremendous
interest in going back to world war ii
battlefields um in the last couple of
years because of 50-year anniversaries
of various battles and northwest has
been sponsoring with veterans groups
various
visit tours back to the battlefields of
the pacific and we do make available uh
special tour prices for those purposes
so the answer is yes we would be
interested in working with veterans
groups to do a lot of those kinds of
things if do you have any idea how long
the flight would be for the united
states to vietnam
it's a long flight uh it's uh
it's probably in the order of about 18
or 20 hours
and if one were to go today commercially
do you have any idea how much it would
cost for a coach ticket
i i really don't uh there are so many
different fares available yeah that's it
you know the range isn't but it's uh you
know in some packages it's quite visible
something like about 2 000
in some other package could be like 3
500 yeah
sierra vista arizona it's our last call
i'm a korean war veteran
and i've been following this series the
last several days been very interesting
thank you
i think that if i were a
japanese or
korean businessman
i would want this embargo to continue
simply because we're missing out
i think the us would be missing out on
furthering commercial and trade
interests
monetary interests
and
i think it's in the interest of
any asian businessman to keep the
embargo going
mr sun
well i think that that's probably
correct but the fact that
there may be some
some business people who benefit from
our embargo
shouldn't be dictating u.s policy u.s
policy has to be based on overall u.s
interests and the fact that some
business people in asia may be
benefiting by our inability to
participate in the market is
is just a temporary benefit they receive
but i agree with you they they probably
are rooting for the embargo to extend
for a long time mr vic
it's a i want to follow a question on
that particular issue and that will be
our last because we're just about out of
time but but we've heard a lot of
discussion from the united states
perspective of whether or not we should
work towards some semblance of
normalized relations or lifting of the
embargo but from the from regards to the
government of vietnam if they do have
quite a lot of countries japan france
others who are interested in willing and
are currently investing does vietnam
care if the united states normalizes in
relations yes vietnam cares very much we
cannot the united states
is the leader of the western world
whether we want it or not and so once
the united states has lifted their
embargo has normalized regions
everything becomes simple even the
japanese you know they would there's
things that they could go in as a joint
venture between the united states and
japan and so on and so forth and all
these things are very much interlinked
on the other hand i do think that we
seem to be obsessed with the
what they call the japan factor in in
vietnam i think it is a misreading a
total misreading of the situation
the largest investors in vietnam now
as mrs gubathan said earlier countries
that have no relations with vietnam the
largest investor is taiwan
almost
almost 750 million dollars
hong kong
singapore
south korea all these countries don't
have any relations with with vietnam
japan was 11th at last count and
i think it's climbing up to number 10.
japan has so far invested in vietnam
about 110 million dollars
and these are so-called only capitalized
investment it's not the whole money
hasn't gone over to the vietnam has only
what they planned to to use in vietnam
so that's a that's a pitiful thing said
to be obsessed by the japan factor
whereas uh uh the the the the other
countries are in there in much greater
numbers in closing for both of you uh
given the current state and progress of
the discussions and the level of debate
and dialogue in this country if we check
back ask the same question about uh
relationships between the two countries
that we started out with we do that in
two or three years what will the answer
be well in two to three years it's more
than likely we have something either
full normalization or something very
close to normalization the embargo will
probably be fully lifted by then
and uh i hope that you know if uh if the
vietnamese american voice is hurt uh
that by then these the situation would
have improved in such a way so that we
have uh thoroughly
livable uh human rights and democratic
society uh who's going to be run by we
don't know but at least
because as i said in my it is my firm
conviction that political liberalization
economic liberalization go hand in hand
it can oh this is maybe a slight gap but
it will catch up in the end elliot
seiden i agree with that i think before
the end of the next term
of the next president whoever it is
whether it's president bush being
re-elected or
a president clinton administration i
think before the end of that administ
that first term or that term you'll see
a normalization of relationship
we're out of time gentlemen thank you
very much for being here for talking to
the c-span audience elliot seiden of
northwest airlines and new enyak bick
who is with the u.s department of
education for your perspectives on the
u.s vietnam relations appreciate your
time thank you very much
we are continuing our program series
vietnam revisited next we'll let you
listen into some comments we received
from viewers on a special viewer
response line when we first aired this
program over memorial day weekend
watched your weekend long coverage of
the senator's trip to vietnam what i was
struck with was the same thing i was
struck in 66 and 67 when i was there for
a year
the enormous cultural clash we never did
understand that country
it's obvious from watching the trip we
still don't
the only difference is this time we're
not killing anyone i believe your
program vietnam revisited is very good
i'm a vietnam veteran 69 to 70 flu by
about 10 miles south of way i support
open trade with vietnam now watching the
senate committee headed by senator john
kearney
senator kearney acts like the ugly
american he tells instead of ask and
senator kearney could have learned at
least two words thank you in vietnamese
as a disabled veteran i want to let you
know i like the programming but uh and i
want to know i want you to know that i
think we should not nationalize we need
to get our pows back out there i am
wondering if the united states is
missing a big investment opportunity but
by not opening up relations with vietnam
your program said japan and korea and
other companies were in there in a big
way i'd like to hear a discussion of
what opportunities we are missing about
the marine corps corporate star wars
vietnam 65-67
and
i generally liked your program but i
feel as many of your cars said i don't
think we need these people and i think
that uh
the press did do a number on the
veterans that they did induce a guilt
um
feeling
i don't think the politicians really
know what's going on i am a vietnam vet
uh
1965-66 i was in vietnam
i was the first infantry division and
end up with the fifth darwin ranger
group and i feel as an american soldier
that we should be able
to give a little to get a little this is
one businessman
who is is going to stand up for american
standards
western civilization and fight for them
and if i will never do business
ever
with those bastards out of southeast
asia in vietnam and they're going to sit
there for 100 years and think about it
vietnam revisited continues
hanoi means the city inside of the bend
of the red river
ha means river noi means in or on the
inside
it was chosen to be the capital of
vietnam in 10 10.
just ahead the sights and sounds of a
recent early morning on the streets of
hanoi
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
okay
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
you're looking at some street scenes
from hanoi the capital of vietnam from
when c-span traveled there in april 1992
along with the senate select committee
on pow mia affairs
c-span's coverage of vietnam revisited
continues we have about an hour and 20
minutes left today and then a reminder
tomorrow 12 noon until 5 pm eastern time
and that will be primarily footage from
the mekong delta area of vietnam
traveling with members of the select
committee as they went to
former air bases and other villages
investigating the m.i.a issue in vietnam
next
on c-span we have
an interview about 30 minutes long with
the gentleman who has a long history
involved with the government of vietnam
in fact at one point he served as acting
prime minister 1965 to 1966 also earlier
was the senior economist with the
international monetary fund here in
washington dc
this gentleman whose american name is
jack owen he was a student and then
later a an instructor at harvard
university and that's where he acquired
his american name uh mr owen uh we'll
talk a bit about investment and
economics in vietnam he in fact wrote
the foreign investment provision of the
vietnamese constitution 30-minute
interview with
jack owen in vietnam
john
what is the investment and management
consulting corporation
uh
this is a government corporation to
begin with
but since i have taken it over since the
last two years i tried to privatize it
so it is now a mixed corporation
uh about
one two thirds belongs to the government
and one third belongs to ourselves
i mean the stocks because this is a
joint stock company
what do you do
well we promote investment
we sort of uh play the role of the
bridge building
between the 40 investors and the
government
understand you went to harvard
yes i did
what years and uh well it was i
graduated in 1954
after that i went on teaching for quite
a number of years and then i joined the
international monetary fund in
washington dc how long were you there
for about 10 years seven years i'm sorry
in washington in washington dc yes why
did you come back
well the government
asked me to come back invited to come
back
and i was given the job of the
chairman of the
national bank of vietnam that means the
central bank of vietnam
and then after about three months they
move on to the
position of the deputy prime minister
and all that has taken me about
six years i think
but in the process i was also the acting
prime minister
on two occasions
where were you during the war
uh in the war i was
in japan and in the united states i left
this country in 1939
i went to japan i got my ba degree in
japan
and then i moved on to the united states
and i stayed for 15 years altogether
are you glad to be back
uh well in the sense i am
do you miss the united states very much
what are the big problems here
well the big problem is that
we have switched from a centrally
planned economy to a market-oriented
economy
and
there has been very little knowledge
about it
we don't have the competent managers the
bankers the financiers
and in particular the production
managers are completely missing at the
moment
when was the switch made and why was it
made well the switch was made officially
in 1986
but we started way back in 1981 in 82.
i remember because i was
i wrote articles in position papers for
the government at those time
and i must say that then i was not a
member of the
the
the
machinery i was completely freelance
writer in those days
in fact i was
free from house detention
where i stayed for about almost one year
when i was three i begin to to read
and write
uh read the
communist
literature
and then i write articles against the
government telling them what is wrong
what is what they should do
so ever since 1982
i
advocated
the abolishing of
the
planet economy
and advocated the
market-oriented economy
and by and by they accept that
it was hard
to push then but by and large i think
that they know what is wrong
and i think that with the circumstances
aiding
i i i seem to have been dried all the
way
you say you're under house detention or
in-house what's that mean that means i
was house arrested
why well i was a member of the
previous government
and you know that nothing saw
warfighting in those days
and why does the government now allow
you to be in this prominent position
well because it proves that i have been
right from the very beginning
what in fact
i keep on saying that if i did not say
those things in those days that means
about
eight years ago we wouldn't have vietnam
today
are people here free to say anything
they want to say without arrest uh no
until
until the
new policy which as i mentioned to it
took place in 1986
until then it was almost impossible to
say anything
but
i have the real courage of someone who
doesn't know the
social structure
and i i spoke out of my conscience
as someone who knows something about
about the economy
and in fact i did get in trouble in the
first place
but by and large i guess the leaders
know that
i am not speaking just for the fun of
of creating an argument
but i spoke with the constructive
ideas so that they finally took it very
seriously and this is why the
start of the the the
restructuring of the economy has come
about where were you born
in and of
whereabouts hanoi in hanoi yes
when did you move from hanoi uh about in
1937
i moved down here to the south
and i took
to the boat here from the south
to japan first where i studied there for
quite a number of years
is there any way to describe your
economic philosophy
well
i mean and for americans who would you
follow what economist
are you most uh
well i would say that uh
at harvard we are very liberal in that
in a way that we
we we we always sort of uh
try to look what is new in the field
and in my days keynes who was john
maynard keynes was a british economist
uh has the
the
most of the
his ideas
fresh out and almost everyone then
and still now if they
follow that
but i must say that the keynesian
theory has been
changed tremendously ever since
but basically it's the idea of
how the economy is structured
the national income accounts
the way you
started have you have an impact upon the
government
open the economy rather by the
government policy
how you do all these things has come out
of cain's thinking
and i would say that this is strictly
uh
some kind of
theoretical background which would allow
the government to take
decisions
to get out of a
a recession shall we say
and
to
create sort of right the right policy to
impact
the government and and the economy uh so
by and large i think as i mentioned
earlier this has become quite different
now the original policy but i think it's
still very much just a thinking
uh this is what sometimes we call the
new economics back in in harvard in
those days
it's quite different now you have
different clarities now but
because harvard never stands still as
you know so it's quite different now but
still i think the idea is that
and watching the world in the last five
years and communism have a tough time
surviving why is communism still here's
strong
or i don't think it is as strong as
mentioned
but let's mention this
uh the leaders of the country are rather
frustrating
and they are very pragmatic
they have tested
experiment experimented
with the centralized bureaucracy
with the centralist management
of the socialistic management of the
economy
and they have failed
so
they're
looking up a new policy a new formula
by which you can
invigorate the economy
and my presentation of the market
economy just happened to be there
and they like it and they took it
so shall i say that
they have tried experimented
with the old model
and now they have adopted this
market-oriented
sort of structure which i think seems to
work well
i can mention a couple of examples
in 1988 we had a family here in this
country
famine a family yes
but since we
just one year after we we abolished the
sen the central planning
we have turned this country
from a food deficient country to a food
surplus country
to the extent that we have exported
every year about
over one million tons of rice
the first year which were exported was
in 1989
at that time it was 1.7 million tons of
rice this year i think it's over 1
million
so by simply
stop meddling with the farmers
let it allow the farmer to
produce whatever they think is trying to
do
let them them so let's say let's say
charge the prices which the traffic and
bear
then in other words allowing the market
mechanism to operate
or shall i say
the invisible hand to operate
then you have a
very very sort of a
good thrust
which i think would take out
would sort of would bring this economy
from the stagnant stagnant
situation up to a better level at the
moment
and if we did it right
i think we might able to take a take off
by the end of this century
take
the
product of rice
and
tell us
what happens in a planned economy versus
a market economy with just that one
product in the planned economy all
factors of production belong to the
state
now we allow the farmers now to own
their own land now now they can own
their own now they can own their own
land now they can own the factors of
production
they are free to decide what to produce
and how to produce we don't meddle with
them
so they select the right crop
the right technology the right
fertilizers and they go ahead and do
whatever the things tried to do it's
free enterprise economy if you will
so
all of a sudden as i mentioned from a
food deficient country we have turned
ourselves into a food service country
in one year
without no chance at all in the
agricultural agricultural policy of the
of the
of the country except allowing the
market mechanism to operate
you notice when you come here today that
you never see an american product sign
you see japanese and
go down the list germans french how come
well the result of the embargo
and what impact is the embargo and
explain what an embark what does it mean
to have an embargo embargo means that
all the
united states to begin with and it's
alive
cannot
invest in this country
there has been very little trade
let's say between the allies of the
united states and vietnam
or most of these that are in the realm
of humanitarian aid basically
but by and by since the roadmap has been
out
mr solomon's roadmap i should remember
then there has been increased trade
but no investment has taken place here
unless you're from japan or from south
korea and some
some
allies of the united states but we have
received so far 2.7 billion dollars of
investment from all the other countries
the first one the first
the country which has invested the most
here is formosa
hong kong
australia
france
italy
but not the united states not japan and
not
south korea which
they are waiting at the door now without
doing much at the moment preparing
themselves to jump off but
not actually investing in vietnam
is the embargo working do you think from
the americans i think it's working
against the interest of the united
states
why
well i think that you have prepared 50
in vietnam
but all the the invitees have come not
yourself
let me ask you though
the
country begins to has begun to open up
the different areas that the united
states wants to look at from mis and
pows would they have done that
if the embargo had been lifted
uh
well i think the question has been
politicized and it's very hard to say
one way or the other
when do you think it will be left
well we all hope that would become soon
but i think it depends as i mentioned it
has become a political
question so it depends very much on the
president himself you would have to make
the decision
think it will happen before the election
i doubt it
knowing the president i think is very
conservative about what to do
and he would not hurt himself out
all the elections i doubt it
what's a day like for you
what do you do every day
i run this this firm
i meet the various delegations from the
various countries
yesterday we had about a 42-member
delegation from formosa
two days ago we had a
220
member delegation from the from malaysia
and
we had a
six or seven member delegation from
great britain
and i think the former prime minister of
singapore mr lee kuan yew isn't annoying
at the moment
so i think there's a lot of movements at
the moment and it's only hope that the
united states would come here
what happens when a
220 member delegate from malaysia comes
to a country like this what who's in the
delegation and what do they do well the
prime minister leads the delegation with
all most of the members of the cabinet
and but basically
the private sector of malaysia has to
come here
very strongly for
for for investment for looking for
opportunities for investment and trade
what kind of opportunities do they have
right i think are very good
because i think that we need some of the
commodities which
malaysia can't provide
and we can exchange ours
but when they come here what kind of
meetings do they have i mean all those
they don't all meet the same time do
they uh well they divide up and they
meet in almost at the same time the
prime minister first met with
the the the captain in hanoi but down
here they have met with the
the people's committee of portugal city
what do they want
they tried is the fight fighting tour
but they try also to
hook up the
the
the traitors between the
malaysia and vietnam so that something
concrete could come up out out of the
whole thing
who's vietnam's largest trading partner
right now
well in fact i think something like
mexico which is one of the
government operated
trade
export and import company
and we have about
oh charlotte say easily about this in
this town alone city alone about
40 outfits like that
what are they selling
everything you can think of the
the trade the balance of trade now is
about two million dollars still very
very small but this is about quadruple
what we used to have in the past
give us the if you can some statistics
on vietnam how many people
what's the gross national product
what's the average per capita income
every year the population is about 66
million at the moment
it would go up to about 70 million by
the end of this decade
uh it means that the rate of growth is
much more than we expect it to be
we will hope very much to keep it stand
still if possible
because we know that
for every dollar which we have
augmented our national income
we have to feed the new
newborn which doesn't leave much
for investment for the country
[Applause]
the
industry we actually say the
the structure between agriculture and
and manufacturing is about eight to two
which means that about eighty percent of
the labor force is still engaged in
agriculture and only about twenty
percent in the manufacturing sector of
the economy
the national income is the pro-capital
income is about
300 dollars for ho chi minh city
for other areas yes for other areas it
should be less than that it should be
about 180
but when you average it out
it's about 200
per capita income
how can you live on that uh well uh
i think that
to live on the local levels needs
you need very little for that
the country is very abundant in terms of
food and everything you need
but
it needs capital it needs know-how it
needs transfer of technology to really
become a
industrialized country and this is what
we are we want to do at the moment to do
in such a way that we invite the foreign
investors to come in to industrialize
the country by the time this interview
is run on the network
some major announcement may have been
made but i wanted to ask you why
this country and if in fact it is
thinking of asking lee kuan yew the
former prime minister of singapore to be
up an advisor to the government is that
accurate
yes
the our prime minister who went to
singapore in the month of february i
think as many
friendly
semi-official request
that mr lee gang who has been very
successful in singapore
would come up with some
recommendations for our master plan for
development
of course this is sort of a diplomatic
on the high level
but we have worked out many sort of
master plans for the economy the
strategy for economic development but
it's a matter of
letting everyone know that we want very
much
friend relations with everyone if
possible which government in this part
of the world or any part of the world do
you most admire and the way it's been
run well i think that
in this part of the world i think the
japanese i think are
very much up in my mind but we cannot
follow the japanese model
our model perhaps is non-existent
but if anything close to it i think it
should be the formosan model
because it is a model of small and
medium-sized industries
now vietnam is still a poor country
there isn't enough capital to go around
so i think the smaller medium-sized
industries
fits the
model of development of vietnam but they
have very high regard for these south
koreans who have been extremely
successful
and from mr lee guangzhou of course to
singapore who have turned a
a is done and
town of singapore into a
sort of one of the
best
industrialized countries in this area
in order to get to what singapore is
today or taiwan or south korea what what
do you have to do here how do you make
the change well we have started to make
the change now that means we liberalize
the economy
we go for
the market oriented economy that means
decision should be made by the private
initiative themselves
the government the government should
intervene the lease in it
just let the people do what they think
that the right to do but have a very
good legal framework
so that people wouldn't
do sort of illegal things
things which should work against the
government
and then
we need a great deal of help from the
various members of the
world
family
of nations
we need transfer of technology we need
capital
we need friendship that is all we need
so at this moment the asean countries
want us to come back to
the asean as you know
and i think that countries like japan
south korea formosa all want to come in
here because they call it this is the
last frontier for investment
labor is still very inexpensive the
factors of production the raw material
are very abundant
so it's up to the
good businessman to take advantage of
that
with all the problems united states has
been having the last couple years with
balanced budgets and deficits and all
that why is the dollar still as
important as it is in the world well if
it is a good
hard currency it is no one can change
that
and we like it
what do you think of how the united
states is around this business
pardon me what do you think of of how
the united states is currently running
its business well i don't know much
about the internal economy because i
have been way far
too long to know anything about it
but i think that
we should sort of uh let bygones be
bygones
and look at the future and give a
helping hand to vietnam
is it true they called you jack when you
were at harvard well they called me jack
owen in those days
jack has been my christian name
and own is the anglicized
vietnamese name which i have how did you
get to harvard in the first place i
simply applied for that when i was in
japan graduating from that for the year
1949
i applied for harvard
and since i was the third of the
graduates
from that university
they have accepted me
and i went there i worked hard and i got
my the highest grade possible
for any graduate school
from foreign graduate students i was
often fellowship
i went teaching for quite a number of
years in fact i was going to go to the
fed
with the federal reserve bank
of doing research with some of my
friends there because one of my
professors happens to be the vice
president of the federal reserve bank
but then i
didn't have my citizenship by then
i didn't know that i must have the
american citizenship to do that
so since i still have my american
decision my journey citizenship i could
get to the to the bank and i went on
teaching for about seven years
and then i was called by the
international
monetary fund and i was offered a job
and i stayed there for odile quebec
vietnam did you ever think about
becoming an american citizen of course
could you still do that
i don't know it's the regulation is so
different now
you know it's hard to know when you come
into a country
really what's going on here but i guess
regarding the government
how do you think people feel about
saying what they want to say doing what
they want to do having this the freedom
to
build what they want to build well i
think in the sense that they're very
happy about it i would say that they are
elected about a new kind of freedom they
have enjoyed since 1986
because until then it wasn't like that
are you ever nervous about speaking out
no because i speak the truth
and you don't think there'll be any kind
of reprisal no i think that uh
if i was able to print
my ideas on newspaper in articles which
have been
sort of a
free access to anyone i think that i'm
doing nothing wrong about it
i'm talking my
mind my conscience as a
professional economist so i don't worry
about that let me just go over the dates
again how long have you now lived in
saigon
i have been here ever since 1964.
but
you have been here straight through
since 64. yes
how has it changed for those americans
that were over here during the war to
what it is today
dramatically
for the good or the bad well
first for the bad enough for the good
people say that that live here that it
really started changing the
paint on the buildings and all that and
cleaning up the place in the last year
and a half so now if you came here three
years ago you wouldn't have saigon as
you see today
what started it started 1987
on seven before four years ago and who's
who's behind that who's doing it
the free enterprise theory
so let's do it
for if foreign business people
especially american business are
listening to you talk about
the vietnamese economy and they want to
come over here
can they come and buy a piece of land
and put up
no
because we have a landlord which states
that online belong to the state
but so what you can do you can lease it
you can lease it
25 years with options for renewal
that means 50 years or even longer
depends on the kind of investment you
make here in vietnam
so you build a factory you want to make
widgets
uh that's impossible can you own 100
yeah you have three form of investment
here the first one is
business cooperation
it means that you keep your own identity
the vietnamese side keep its own
identity
they
collaborate on certain projects project
by projects
that's the first one the second one is a
joint venture it means that
either side would lose its identity but
they would build up a third identity in
vietnam in the laws of vietnam and they
operate through that legal
entity
so
the ratio of capital contribution could
be anything between 30 to
28 or 90
in favor of the foreigners
and then you have the 100
foreign capital
so far we have about
550
projects approved
with almost 3 billion dollars it was 2.7
billion dollars should be about 3
million right now
but of these 550 projects which have
been approved
about
95
fall into into the category of joint
venture
because most of the foreign investors
want to take advantage of what is here
the low cost of living the local labor
the availability of
factors production of raw material
when it comes to the
you know the opportunities of business
should people expect to get a lot of tax
well tax has never been a
sort of a welcome
thing to anyone in every country but i
mean here they're going to be taxed well
yes they're going to be taxed more
definitely
too high
no i think still is about the lowest tax
in the whole world
in fact you know that the income tax is
hardly
applied at the moment
it started just last year
so i think it takes time for the
economy to build up a good tax structure
and
we are still in the midst of
reforming the tax system now in the tax
collection
of all the new projects you've seen come
in the last year what's the most
intriguing to you
uh well uh most of them
are in the
consumer's goods industry
but quite a number of projects have been
now in the
infrastructure the bridges
the roads
housing
but what what intrigues me more than
anything else is the
office building and the
and hotel combinations
in in my hand now i have about three
projects
the smallest one would be a 10 million
dollars
the largest one would be 65 million
dollars
for a
five-star hotel
right on the river front here
is it going to happen yes
we hope it's going to happen is it a
joint venture is joint venture
and why are the people involved that are
interested what's what's drawing them in
here pardon me what is drawing them in
here what's
well i guess the
opportunities are here
if you go into a cost benefit analysis
you would see that the
the price the the
the cost of producing almost any
commodities
is lower than any other countries here
and the law for for investment would
sort of uh
cater
to the needs of the wishes of the
foreign investors
taxes
on manufacturing is about from
10 to 25 percent
of group of gross
corporate income
drawn thank you very much for your time
thank you very much for coming
my last question to you is this
some people in the united states
are convinced
that there are some people being held
here
tonight i'm still alive
how do we resolve this issue between our
two countries how do we answer these
doubts
um
m
because he thinks it's such a strange
thing for people to think that
is this a strange idea
[Music]
so he's been in this area since the end
of the war
what why is it strange
when many frenchmen
after diane benfoo in 1954
remained long after the war as prisoners
[Music]
his surprise
uh reaction and the reason he thinks
it's a strange idea
is based on his experience in this area
where because he has so much experience
in this area because he's never heard of
any such report because he's so familiar
with this area he knows there can no be
there could not be any such
uh event in this area therefore
taking from his limited experience and
expanding it psychology he reacts in a
very surprised way can you finish the
answer to my question of how we resolve
the issue how do we
how do we get rid of the doubts later
it's all
[Music]
that was a piece of what you'll see much
of tomorrow that was senator bob smith
of new hampshire and senator john kerry
of massachusetts the chairman and vice
chairman of the senate select committee
on pow mia affairs in one of many visits
they made to various
provinces and towns in vietnam that was
in kanto province c-span accompanied
them on their fact-finding mission and
tomorrow on c-span from 12 until five
five hours of videotape accompanying
them on their trip
through the mekong delta area
and you'll be able to follow along with
them no open phones tomorrow because the
videotape encompasses the entire five
hours of our program tomorrow so during
this next hour we have two segments
scheduled in with our phone lines open
for your comments from around the
country if you have not had a chance to
comment and would like to do so we
encourage you to dial in during this
final hour and we'll open up our phone
lines right now as a matter of fact take
a couple of telephone calls from around
the country
with your opinions again no guests here
just your chance to comment and we'll
put the c-span phone numbers on the
screen and take a few calls now and then
a few calls again before we wrap up here
at the six o'clock hour
eastern long island new york you're on
the air hi uh this is john mcauliffe uh
we're the organization that sponsored
jack when he came to the u.s
a couple of times his only two visits to
the us in the last couple of years
and i wanted to mention
that your viewers who are interested in
what
is going on among american
non-governmental organizations that work
in vietnam
or who are interested in work to end the
trade embargo can get a directory of
information
if they call our office which is uh
212-764-3925
and it's a non-government the
non-government nonprofit organization
though we
we have
very good working relationships with
both the u.s and the vietnamese
government and also the cambodian and
lao governments and again that number is
is 212-764-3925
and what kinds of questions can you
answer for people well if people want to
find out they're about 50 american ngos
that have programs in vietnam nine of
them have offices in hanoi
so that if they're interested in helping
on humanitarian aid projects or if
they're interested in potentially
working
for one of those agencies they can find
that out
is a number of american businesses and a
number of
of academics and others who are working
to end the trade embargo and bringing
about normalization and and people could
also contact us to find out how to reach
them all right sir thank you for phoning
in this afternoon thank you
naples florida is our next comment here
on the air
well first of all i'd like to thank you
c-span for airing this kind of
information it's about time that we put
some of the ghosts of our past behind us
i am a businessman who does extensive
business in the area of southeast asia
mainly malaysia and thailand
and indonesia
and
many of the businesses that we do
business with in malaysia and thailand
have started flocking to vietnam it is
they they view it as an economic
bonanza to be
exploited and and and turned into a
profitable situation not only for the
entire economic uh region in the area
but the the the further development uh
and forward moving of uh socialization
of this country back into the normal
relationships with
the rest of the world uh
the embargo is something that has seen
its time and we are missing out
incredible opportunities in the country
and
i just hope that some of the the
americans who have served over there can
put some of that behind them and look
towards
a future
of building economic ties and and
helping our country in the same time
thank you thank you for the call last
phone call for this segment but if you
do have a ringing sound you are most
welcome to stay with it and we're going
to do another open phone segment later
on
before we wrap up here calum county
washington go ahead please
yes
i'm a veteran vietnam 6869 and vin long
in the delta the one thing that i
haven't seen covered that i would like
to know
is those of us who were advisors and had
very close relationships with our
vietnamese counterparts we don't know
whether they survived
after the end of the war in my case he
was a major
probably went into a re-education camp
if he survives battles
then i don't know whether he survives
that and i worry about him every day i
think of him he was as close as a
brother and how can we find out what
happened to them and if they didn't
survive how can we find out about their
wives and their children who we knew and
how can we help support them now
i i know our producer is listening in
and
as i mentioned we're going to be back
one more time
before our program ends at 6 00 eastern
time and if he has an answer for an
organization both either inside the
government or outside that might be able
to
help you out with your question we'll
tell you about it too before we end
all right thanks for the call that was
callum callum county washington phoning
in
next we're going to uh i combine the
issue of business and pow's mias with a
gentleman you know very well h ross
perot one small aspect of our trip in
late spring
made headlines unexpectedly
we conducted an interview in vietnam
with a vietnamese official
and the name h ross perot came up and a
little bit later when we were talking
with mr perrault in the early days of
his exploration of his presidential bid
mr perot had a chance to respond on
videotape
to that vietnamese official there you
can see on your screen some of the
headlines that came
out of that question and answer and
became a much larger story as you can
tell
what we're going to show you next is the
initial question to lee bong who was a
vietnamese government official
his responsibility is head of the
americas department for vietnam so all
americans coming in and out of the
country go through mr libong that's
about four minutes long and we'll
immediately follow it with our interview
with h ross perot and his response to
libong's comments
if you came here in 1986 or the 87
things
were much different
than now at that time this room may be
very
stuffy no air conditioning no
electricity or
very
deep light but now you can see
the
the room is better finished
you can go into the street and you see a
lot of shops and people going back and
forth
with a lot of activity i remember in
1987 when mr perrault ross perot
came here he said that one advice i can
give to you is that you should mobilize
your people
to work now
like
they work during the war and that time
we couldn't do that
people are very slowly at working but
now you know you see they
going
in all direction for working
everyone trying to work to develop
of course for money but also for some
uh other purposes to develop the country
you know uh i assume that mr perrault
might run for president
of the united states i see are you aware
of that
i heard and i saw some icons but
you know i
received his
advisor
many many times
at least
13
who came to vietnam for what reason
for a lot of reasons for maa issue
for economics issue
for humanitarian you know
issues
and he came many times
so i know everything about him did he
come more than other american
delegations certainly certainly 13 times
that's a lot since 1987.
what's his name
his name is the mr harry
harry harry mackelop
and did they did they offer you help
yes
what kind of help
for
school for university or for hospital
how many times has mr perot been here
why what did you think of him
i think that he is
intelligent
friendly
to vietnam at that time
but he has to carry out his promises
to vietnam yeah
has he done that not yet
what kind of promises did he make he
promised to have some of our schools
university
for textbooks
for
medicine equipment
and then
to
bringing u.s businessmen to vietnam
for
looking into the
economic situation in vietnam to
develop
their
relation in the future
we are still waiting his you know
advisor much love will come in a few
weeks i
think do you think if he runs for
president uh that will help you get the
aid that he promised you
um
i don't know i have to look forward to
because you know
for the past four or five years
we haven't got from him
we only got advices maybe he
very strict
to
carry out or to follow the embargo i
don't know
but
many
other ngos came here already
and they give aid already why not meet
you parole
did he tell you how much
in dollars he would give you no
never
are you surprised that he hasn't come
through on his promise
uh
no not
not not very surprised why
because you know at first he promised
and then second he didn't carry it out
on the third one so it's i gotta use it
anyway
and
we got a lot of americans come here
in
many many
how to say many
stratas or
elevens
and
maybe
some of them promised to not carry out
some of them did carry out and
so we we try to talk to everyone
let me ask you though about you you
basically have said this i won't ask you
though again you don't think that under
any circumstances if they if stories
keep coming out about your relationship
in close relationship with the next
administration will have no impact on
the voters out there that like you
well
i certainly get no indication there are
no more stories that's it you know
everything that ever happened is out
they
used me and i was happy to be used on
the pow project
my whole family's life was at risk from
1969 to 1973.
they used to come to canada and give a
list of people to kill and i was on that
list who's there that would come to
canada the vet the vietnamese would send
people to canada and give a group in
this country
a list
fbi and this is all public record in
terms of the fbi had infiltrated the
group knew who was whose life was
threatened and so on and so forth uh it
really really impacted my family now
let's go back to thin skin i never
backed off that pow issue for one minute
you're saying they first of all they ask
you to get involved they asked me to do
it
i had to do it with my money because it
had to be private do you remember who
asked you i've already told you
the president and henry kessinger and my
day-to-day contact was colonel alexander
hague
back in 1969 69 to 73.
do you remember why they asked you i
mean what was this i've told you that
was because
they were going to vietnam as a war
and they were convinced based on
intelligence reports that half of the
pows would die of brutality and neglect
now interestingly enough so it was an
interesting place to be in
you would have thought those pows were
henry kissinger's sons now henry
kissinger is thought of as a tough
old bird al hague
is they were his sons
al hague was available to me night and
day anytime he cared about those people
just like he was there or his son was
one of those people and so did henry
kissinger
and i really admired both of them during
that whole period because of their
concern for those men
a lot of stories have been written i
know a lot but a number of stories have
been written
that your real
reason for wanting to do this
is because of the pow issue and you the
way that president
bush treated you when he was vice
president
now you're a completely different point
do this the campaign talking about the
campaign in other words this thing goes
all the way from 69 your involvement of
the pow mia it comes up to the recent
years you're still involved in it and
that you're upset because of the way the
reagan bush administration treated you
and trying to continue to solve this
problem no no no if i had been upset
about that
let's assume that i was that shallow and
vindictive which i am not
and i'm not this is this is
this is a thick more fiction coming out
of you nowhere
that's just not true
that's the simplest way there's no point
in the library it's just not true
if there was a shred of truth to it the
time to have moved into action would
have been in 88
can i ask you whether why would you wait
till 92 just do it in 88 get it over
with while you're still while it was
still a fresh memory the 86 experience
before i forget it has president bush
ever called you in the last couple of
months to say hey let's sit down and
talk this out
not
have people indirectly all i have to say
i've answered your question i don't want
to yeah not directly
i have had i not had a call in the
president but if he called you and said
ross perot let's get together and talk
this out there's too much at stake here
what would you do that won't happen
that won't happen it will not happen but
let me let me give you on an abstract
basis
with as many adverse experiences as i
have had
in terms of
in texas we have a term around horses
used hard and put up wet that mean you
took him out you wrote him all day and
just put him back in the barn didn't
clean him up
dry him off
you know i've been ridden hard and put
up wet by those folks
on a number of occasions
but
on causes that i felt were important and
i did it and i'm glad i did it
uh
and but all of that would make you you
know those are experiences that are
behind me but if the president united
states called me and wanted to talk to
me certainly i would talk to him but
this this that's if he just calls i need
to talk to you certainly i would talk to
him i can't imagine a citizen that
wouldn't talk to the president united
states
that won't happen though and there's no
politically you're in a political
framework that won't happen there's no
way he could talk you out of going ahead
with this thing
he won't try
why not
oh this can you this is a guy
surrounded by a thousand handlers and
image makers
uh by the time they could think about
whether or not it was a good idea or not
the election be over would the reverse
ever happen if you were in that position
and somebody was that you knew was doing
this would you call that was doing what
running for president okay just i'm not
you're the president now wait just a
minute if people i'm suddenly i'm the
president suddenly and i'm going to run
again and suddenly people at the
grassroots in all 50 states want to put
someone else on the ballot
i would think that's a healthy thing
what democracy is supposed to be all
about
i wouldn't panic i wouldn't
send whole teams of people out to try to
uh
see if there's not some way i could
do negative destructive personal things
i would say well that's a healthy thing
that's going on
have you ever been a republican or a
democrat i'm an independent voter which
means i have voted for both republicans
and democrats and you've never
registered republican or democrat in
texas you don't really register you vote
in either republican or democratic
primary
but that doesn't mean that you can't
split the ticket when you go to the
general election
let's go back to the pow mi a thing um
do you think there are still american
servicemen alive in southeast asia
i know
we left people in laos
the question is is anyone still alive
if you go to old public newspaper
accounts
there is
substantial evidence at the end of the
war
that well the prophet
boasted that they had large numbers of
prisoners that's pretty
substantial stuff at the end of the war
we didn't get anybody out of laos
so the real question is and we had all
kind of intelligence information that
they were there and alive on our side
and they know and they and the prophet
laos said they had them and then we
never got anybody
and on that was in february of 1973 when
the men came out of hanoi
april 13 1973
our country declared there are no more
living americans in southeast asia now
keep in mind watergate was in full
flight right
we had the big media events about the
people the prisoners coming home which
was a great concern the american people
there's just one question and that is is
anybody still alive
uh
and
then if they're i would say logically
and rationally
you would certainly expect some of these
several hundred to still be alive and
we certainly have an obligation to
anybody we send
out on the battlefield to not leave them
behind and very sadly we left them here
now this is not a new thing
it had the same problem in korea
we left several thousand the russians
took several thousand prisoners at the
end of world war ii
it's all you can all go back into the
records it's there
the question is
uh is anybody still alive
as you know i told you before the
cameras roll that we're doing this
30-hour special next weekend right
on vietnam we took our cameras to
vietnam for some 30 hours of tape we
talked to people in the government
and um
one of the gentlemen we talked to is the
acting director of the americas
department meaning that he's the
spokesman in the vietnamese government
for any relationships with north america
his name's lee bang
and in the course of this interview
unprovoked he brings your name up
although he first calls you richard
and he talks about
this was in the context of
americans come here all the time he said
and i said who and he named a bunch and
they named richard perrault
and i said he said he remembered you
came in 87. to make a long story short
he says that you came once
and since then
an aid of yours has come 13 times
and that you made promises to vietnam
the vietnamese for money and
schools and education and medicine and
all that stuff but nothing's ever been
delivered can you clear this up for us
yes
they
sent me a written invitation unsolicited
by me
to come to hanoi while i was making the
last pow study for vice president bush
and president reagan at their request
i did not initiate it i did not ask to
do it i did not want to do it
they wanted me to be on the tac
commission which preceded my study and i
said no
then after the attack commission there
was a lot of controversy and basically
their position was people
have a high regard for you ross and we
would like for you to go through all of
this and take a formal position because
whatever your position is
uh with your credibility the american
people will believe it i said now before
i do this
are you going to just talk about it are
you going to do something about it
i was assured they would do something
about it then i said
uh i really don't need to do the study
because just a casual observation of
what i told you a few minutes ago will
tell you we left men in laos
so why don't we just focus on that and
skip the study well they wanted to do
this day i did as i was doing the study
i suddenly got the invitation
then the vietnamese from the vietnamese
unsolicited now these are the facts
i immediately went to the white house
and i said they sent me this invitation
uh what do you want me to do
and in the meantime i sent back to them
that i would not go
until i had somebody go in ahead of me
and determine that this was going to be
a worthwhile constructive meeting
and keep in mind these guys tried to
kill me for three years
so walking into the mouth the alligator
was something i had to take step by step
they agreed to that i sent people in
they talked to them came back they said
they thought it would be a constructive
meeting
so finally i was asked now iran country
had hit full tilt by this march of 87.
at that point nobody cared about pows
nobody cared about hostages in beirut
everybody was shredding right and left
everybody was running for cover
and trying to survive okay real world
that's what was happening in the
executive branch
and i raised the issue i said do you
want me to go or not well you know they
were changing musical chairs everywhere
and the
chief of staff
had been replaced by senator howard
baker
finally as we got close to the date
senator baker said
to meet with me in washington i met with
him
he told me they wanted me to go he gave
me a list of things they wanted me to do
while i was there
i went i did those things i came home
and i reported back
and i gave them all my conclusions of my
study
and i went on with my life
nothing happened because
they were buried in iran contra they
just the whole thing died right there
but
uh i will not get more specific about
what they asked me to do so on and so
forth but this is what really happened
if facts matter to anybody i did it at
their request i went now anytime you
talk to the vietnamese
they would talk about
their problems like the needs for
schools for hospitals for this set and
the other
and i would explain to them that if we
could ever get this issue resolved
and i kept focusing them on laos too
because of this total
non-return of pows
we could ever get all these issues
resolved that i thought the rest of the
issues they were concerned about could
be taken care of did you ever offer and
i said
not any no
no
no has your aid been there 13 times i
don't think that's a proper number they
now let me say this
anytime anybody ever has gone back it's
because they have asked him to come back
on one occasion when their top people
were in new york at the united nations
they asked to see me
and i went up and sat there and i
visited with them and i reported it to
the white house
and all of these things
typically just are conversations
their big concern
as i talked to them
it was
how could i think or they think that our
government was concerned about
prisoners of war or missing in action
when we had declared them all dead in
april 1973 now that's a pretty valid
question for them to ask that's about as
deep as i want to go
should the trade embargo
that is
has been in effect since 1975
uh with the south and 64 in the north uh
be
lifted i'd have to have a lot more
detail than i have access to to answer
that would you
people when they talk about this say not
until we know where every missing and
pow is will we let should we lift that
embargo do you feel the same way
it's more complex than that in my mind
and i like i say i'd have to have a lot
more detail i don't
lunge at decisions i get the facts and
make decisions and that keeps me out of
a lot of trouble do we have a
responsibility at all to the vietnamese
for any reparations in your mind
that's an interesting question
and
the short answer would be no
if you ever read the nixon reparations
letter though
say we didn't get to read that right
after the war it was classified
and uh the nixon reparations letter
doesn't leave a lot of outs it basically
was a commitment
and i would want to reread that letter
and study it and see what i'm back to
i'm a very simple person what did we say
we would do
what did we say we would do
then we ought to look at it in those
terms
texas businessman ross perot
in his response to
a
story told by lee bong who was a
vietnamese official during c-span's
visit to vietnam in the spring
mr
perot testified before the pow committee
on august 14th which c-span covered also
mr pro talks about the nixon
administration he also mentioned former
secretary of state henry kissinger
mr kissinger will be next to testify
before senator kerry's committee that's
scheduled for september 22nd and if that
happens we will likely have our cameras
there as we continue to follow this pow
mia issue and the whole embargo question
as well we have about 10 minutes more
left in our day here and we are going to
once again open up our telephone lines
for your comments from around the
country and that's how we'll wrap up our
day and tomorrow final day of vietnam
revisited and it will be videotaped all
day of c-span's journey with the senate
select committee all the way from hanoi
to the mekong delta let's take some
calls cape may point new jersey is first
hi how you doing um i was wondering when
the crew was over there and they asked
the guys on
the local officials if they seen anybody
any americans alive i think they should
have really asked the uh the local
people
if they have seen or heard of howard
stern
okay next call is from bedford heights
ohio
hi uh
i was under the assumption that i was
going to be able to ask mr pearl a
question no sir that was videotape from
the spring
well i just wanted to make a comment
that i think the media coverage on mr
perrault
was very slanted and i think
it leads to suspicions that
there is political influence
throughout the national media and it
gives a uh
a very uh
dimming view on the future of political
independent candidates and i think
uh independent commission should be
looked into
on how to keep political
spins that are very
very uh damaging
out of the national media
all right sir thanks very much los
angeles is next
yes so this is los angeles calling first
of all i want to say
i think c-span did a great job uh
covering both conventions and i wanted
to thank them for the coverage and i
think that
a lot of people are very interested in
politics when we really are able to know
the information instead of just some
kind of surface level information that's
given through most of the media
the next thing i want to say was ross
perot's interview was interesting it's
too bad that we can't really get an
in-depth interview and just
do what basically what he was suggested
and putting people before congress and
testifying and saying in effect they can
have immunity if we can really know the
facts because i think there's a lot of
information that man knows that would
help the country a great deal that's all
i want to say and thanks again to c-span
i really like your network thank you for
the call next comment comes from
farmington hills michigan you're on the
air oh thank you my name is jane and i
am a fan of c-span like many others um
august 13th i had a tour of c-stand met
brian lamb
and sorry you weren't there
any i told him i had watched the 30
hours memorial weekend and he told me
about the updated version
coming and so i've been with you for
almost 29 hours it's a wonderful
education why are you so interested in
vietnam just to watch this twice well
i'm a fan and um
i'm a product of world war ii so
i'm not um is well versed in vietnam
and i feel that we should become
more educated
even though we were not directly
affected by it well now that you've
watched all this what is your opinion
about where our two countries should go
well i think um
we should still
recognize the problem of the veterans we
must continue to address it but we must
move forward
and as we did with japan we ended up
having good relations we cannot just sit
back and wait until
the last question is answered and then
move on we must continue
to
offer a chance for
more monetary
availability to our
citizens
and
better relationships with the country i
know as mr perot says you have to read
more about it and study more and it's
programs like this
that give us a chance to be exposed
information that
i was i'm much older so i would not have
been studying in school but that many
students never learned which
i wanted to ask you a question in the
beginning of your program you talked
about the tape available
which i think is for 250
but that much has been
mentioned about it and i think it would
be a wonderful gift for anyone who
knows about vietnam
and doesn't know about vietnam and i
hope
you will repeat the inter uh
the information on it as well will the
book knows interview with lou fuller
ever be repeated that was marvelous all
right um i i'm gonna let you go i don't
know about mr um
lewis uh puller's uh book notes
interview uh that was uh aired right
around the the memorial day weekend as
well uh when we re we aired this program
first in
may over labor day weekend we did have a
special price
for the whole
50 hours
of programming which was 250
perhaps um
our producer can tell me whether or not
we're able to do that this time as well
i don't know whether or not we're making
that available with this whole new set
of tapes yes we are okay so if you call
c-span during working hours here it's
202-737-3220
they can put you in touch with our
viewer services department and tell you
more about how you can order this whole
set of vietnam revisited if you're
interested
thanks very much for the call and that
viewer mentioned coming on a tour of
c-span if you plan to be in washington
we would be happy to show you around our
network as part of your visit to the
nation's capital orange county
california is next go ahead please yes
um
because
i heard that about the pow and mia and
we also revisit our countries
quite some time
are you your vietnamese sir yes yes
and
we have some information
about
the maa
and we don't know where
we can report
well i'll tell you exactly where you can
call which is to call the united states
capital
at
the 202 area code
225-3121 will put you in touch with the
operator at the united states capital
and if you tell her you want to be
connected to the senate pow committee
they can connect you right through so
that's two zero two two two five three
one two one that's the united states
capital telephone number giving out a
lot of phone calls here and i'm gonna
try one more and i'm sorry to confuse
you with all this information but we did
have that gentleman in the earlier
segment uh that uh inquired about the
fate of his
vietnamese
advisor who
was with him side by side during his
tour of duty in vietnam and jim mills
our producer for vietnam revisited tells
me that if you contact the indochina
resource action center it's in
washington dc another telephone number
202-667-4690
that's the indochina indochina resource
action center
six seven 202-6674 six nine zero that uh
they may be able to help you
um with your question one last telephone
call and that will be it for day four of
vietnam revisited and it's from los
angeles you're on the air
hi this is uh fosee and
i
to the best of my knowledge at the end
of the vietnam war
we had an agreement i think with the
vietnamese
that we will pay them three billion
dollars if they were released mia am i
correct or not
we refused to pay it after the war was
over
i know you can't answer me immediately
but why doesn't somebody look into that
what happened
why didn't we pay the three billion
dollars so that we can get the men out
of there all right sir thanks los
angeles uh we'll let that go as our last
uh and i might remind you that henry
kissinger
who was involved with that issue
directly after the war will be in front
of the p o w m i a select coming in the
senate uh next couple weeks september
22nd and
that may be among the kinds of questions
that the committee will have for him
that's it for our fourth day of vietnam
revisited and i will remind you once
again that tomorrow no calls videotape
and
the day will consist of five hours of
our trip with the senate committee as
they travel the length of vietnam
starting in hanoi and going down to the
mekong delta in their search for some
information about the pow mia question
thanks to jacqueline pham jim mills
brett betzell and others here at c-span
for all the time they've devoted in our
vietnam revisited programming lots of
other names involved as well as you know
that and we'll show you credits at the
end of all this and thanks for those of
you who have participated with your
questions from around the country